COME TO ORDER. GOOD AFTERNOON
IN RESPONSE TO THE COVERT
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THESE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT PUBLIC
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL BUT SOME ARE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS PARTICIPATING REMOTELY.
TODAY WE HAVE THREE MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY CENTERS
GONZALEZ. CENTER HER TADO IN
CENTER LEYVA. AND IN HERE IN
THE SENATE CHAMBER WITH ME IS
SENATOR MINING. WE ALSO HAVE
SEVERAL WITNESSES WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY FOR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONE OR YOUR COMPUTER'S
THIS WILL GREATLY AID IN THE-
ELIMINATING ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. I ASK THAT EVERY TIME
YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED THAT
YOU USE THEY RAISE YOUR HAND
FEATURE IN THE PROGRAM. EACH
TIME YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK A POP UP WINDOW WILL
APPEAR ASKING YOU. ASKING IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO AND MUTE
PLEASE SELECT UNMUTE BEFORE YOU
BEGIN SPEAKING. OUR IT
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
MUTE WHEN YOU ARE DONE. ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND THEN
YOU'RE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW PUBLIC
ACCESS WITH LIMITED MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING ROOMS
TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT. THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER. ACTUALLY THE TOPIC
IS A TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND WE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
844-291-6364 AGAIN.
844-291-6364 THE ACCESS CODE
IS. EIGHT FOUR NINE SEVEN ONE
THREE EIGHT AGAIN. EIGHT FOUR
NINE SEVEN ONE THREE EIGHT FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES THEM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE
INDOOR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. FOR
TODAY'S HEARING WILL BE HEARING
ALL OF THE PANELS OF WITNESSES
ON THE GENDER PRIOR TO TAKING
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT. ONCE WE
HAVE HEARD ALL OF THE WITNESSES
WE WILL HAVE A PUBLIC COMMENT
PERIOD FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO
COMMENT ON THE TOPICS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA. PLEASE NOTE.
THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR
YOU CLEARLY AND AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY. OVER THE PHONE. IT
IS IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM
YOU AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHOSE DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE BEING
SERVICE ARE HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINED HEARING PROCESS AND
CONDUCTOR HEARINGS IN THIS
CLOSE TO MATT TO THE SAME
MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY. THERE
MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS TO ADJUSTING TO
THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TED TOOLS
OR TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
SO I WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU
FOR COMING TO DISCUSS THE ROLE
OF PRIVATE HEALTH INSURANCE AS
WE IN CALIFORNIA THE COUNTRY IN
THE WORLD TACKLE THE COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. WE HAVE
LEARNED SO MUCH BUT YET HAVE SO
MUCH MORE TO LEARN. THE CODE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC STARTED LESS
THAN A YEAR AGO. OUR HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM HAS COME SO FAR HAS
BEEN STRETCHED SO MUCH AND EVEN
TODAY WE HAVE HOSPITALS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY WHICH HAVE ARE
OVERFLOWING WITH PATIENTS.
HOWEVER WITH RESOLVE WE CAN
KEEP MOVING FORWARD AND
CERTAINLY HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE DONE BETTER THAN MOST BUT
STILL WE ARE STILL NOW THE
WOODS. SO I WANT TO THANK OUR
HEALTH CARE WORKERS IN ALL OVER
CENTRAL WORKERS TO CONTINUE TO
DO THEIR PART TO KEEP US SAFE.
TAKE CARE OF US HELP US PUT
FOOD ON THE TABLES BE SURE THAT
WE STILL HAVE ESSENTIAL
SERVICES. WE CAN ALL AGREE THAT
IN ORDER TO GET ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF THIS PANDEMIC. IT IS
GOING TO TAKE WIDESPREAD
TESTING. TRACING ISOLATION OF
THOSE WHO'VE BEEN EXPOSED OR L.
N. VACCINATIONS. ALONG WITH
SOCIAL DISTANCING COST BARRIERS.
ALONG WITH SOCIAL DISTANCING
COST BARRIERS RED TAPE AND
FEARS OF SURPRISE BILLS CAN'T
STAND IN THE WAY PEOPLE GETTING
NECESSARY CARE. THERE HAVE BEEN
MANY DIRECTIVES BULLETINS FAQS
IFRSS EXECUTIVE ORDERS
EMERGENCY REGULATIONS TO
OUTLINE ROLES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES DURING THE
PANDEMIC IT'S NO WONDER THAT
THERE IS CONFUSION AND
SOMETIMES POSSIBLY
CONTRADICTIONS BETWEEN THESE
VARIOUS EFFORTS. MY HOPE
TODAY'S THAT WE CAN GET ON THE
SAME PAGE AND IDENTIFY WHAT
POLICY LEVERS ARE NEEDED TO
ENSURE CLARITY AND CONSISTENCY
SO THAT PROVIDERS AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY PATIENTS NOT CAUGHT
IN THE MIDDLE AND IF PEOPLE ARE
ABLE TO GET. THE SERVICES THAT
THEY NEED. SO BEFORE WE BEGIN
OUR SPEAKERS AGAIN WOULD LIKE
TO INVITE THE PUBLIC WANTING TO
PARTICIPATE IN PUBLIC AND
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE END TO
CALL IN NOW. PLEASE DIAL AGAIN
THE TOLL FREE NUMBERS. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. AND PROP WHEN
PROMPTED PLEASE USE THE ACCESS
CODE. EIGHT FOUR NINE SEVEN ONE
THREE EIGHT. SO WITH THAT WE'RE
GOING TO GO AHEAD AND BEGIN
WITH OUR FIRST WITNESS- WHO-
WILL LISTENED- WHO IS- DAVID
SHARPE RESIDENT ALAMEDA COUNTY
IS GONNA BE SHARING HIS STORIES
AND THEN AFTER HIS TESTIMONY WE
WILL TAKE QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS- BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO
THE NEXT PANELISTS SO LET'S
BEGIN AGAIN WITH- DAVID SHARPE
WELCOME. YES HI GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS DAVID SHARP CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES ACTUALLY SPEAK UP
A LITTLE BIT IS A WAY TO GET A
VALUE A LITTLE HIGHER- SURE.
THERE YOU GO SOUNDS GOOD. I IS
THAT ANY BETTER YES. SO OKAY WE
SHOULD GAIN WITH THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME THIS AFTERNOON- GOOD
AFTERNOON TO ALL THE PANELISTS
AND- THE DISTINGUISHED GAS- I'D
LIKE TO TELL YOU- AND ON A
STORY ABOUT AN UNFORTUNATE
INCIDENT THAT HAPPENED TO MY
SON JEREMY- MY SON HAD A
POTENTIAL OCTOBER. EXPOSURE ON-
IN. ON SATURDAY- THE TWELFTH OF
SEPTEMBER WE RESEARCHED
LOCATIONS TO FIND- COULD BE
TESTING. YOU KNOW LIKE THOSE
DRIED UP- AND WE FOUND ONE AT
WASHINGTON HOSPITAL PARKING
LOT. SO MUCH AND MUCH OF THE
PARKING LOT OF WASHINGTON
HOSPITAL LATE IN THE DAY WHERE
TENTS WERE SET UP OUTSIDE THE
SIGN ADVERTISING FOR. OCTOBER
TESTING. IT HAS TO BE TESTED.
POSITIVE YOU KNOW A POSSIBLE-
AGREEMENT EXPOSURE. ONE IN ONE
OF THE TENTS AND ASKED HIM TO
COME BACK THE NEXT DAY BECAUSE
I GUESS IT WAS LATE IN THE DAY
SO THEY- DIRECTED HIM TO COME
BACK THE NEXT DAY. SO SUNDAY
NINE THIRTEEN- HE ARRIVED AT
THE SAME TENT AND I WAS TOLD
THAT THE TESTING HAD BEEN MOVED
INSIDE DUE TO SOME OPEN AIR
QUALITY. THE SAME PERSON AND-
DR MARK INTO WHAT WE SHOULD NOW
EMERGENCY- WE KNOW THAT TIME
BUT AND- AT THE COUNTER YOU
KNOW THROUGH SECURITY. AND-
THEY ASKED- IN THE EMERGENCY
ROOM ASKED HIM WHY HE WAS THERE
THE STATUS OF A TEST. THEY TOOK
HIM BACK TO A- WAIT QUITE A
LONG TIME- HE LEFT THE ROOM AND
WAS- TO GO BACK AND WAIT IN
THERE- SO HE HAS. A DISABILITY
AS AB DE. SAC KINDA HARD FOR
HIM TO UNDERSTAND EXACTLY
WHAT'S HAPPENING AND WHAT'S
GOING ON. HE JUST WANTED
ANSWERS TO WHY THIS DOES NOT
SEEM LIKE A PROTEST THAT WAS
ADVERTISED. SO YOU'RE MEETING
SAID THAT THE DOCTOR DID SHOW
UP IN THE ROOM. YOU CAN EVEN-
WAS ASKED WHY HE WAS THERE. HE
ANSWERED YOU GET A COLD
ATTACHED. HE FINALLY DID GET
SWAPPED- BUT HE TEXTED MOTHER
MY WIFE WONDERING WHY THINGS
WOULD TAKE THIS LONG MY WIFE
CALLED AND NOW REALIZE HE WAS
INSIDE THE EMERGENCY ROOM- HIS
MOTHER CALLED THE HOSPITAL AND
SPOKE TO SOMEONE IN THE-
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT-
EXPLAINED. THAT THAT HE WAS
ONLY THERE FOR A THAT COULD BE
TESTING. IT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
PERFORMED OUTSIDE AS
ADVERTISED. THE PERSON
INDICATED THAT IT WAS- THIS IS
NOT FREE TESTING OR ANYTHING
LIKE THAT BUT NOT TO WORRY
BECAUSE INSURANCE WOULD PAY FOR.
MY WIFE ASKED WHY HE'D BEEN
TAKEN INSIDE THE EMERGENCY ROOM
AND IF WE WERE NOW GOING TO GET
CHARGED FOR AN UNWANTED
EMERGENCY. ROOM VISIT. THE
PERSON TOLD HER YES. BUT- THEY
HAD NOT YET SENT THE TEST STAND
I GUESS THIS ONE TODAY TAKEN
AND- IF WE DON'T WANT IT YOU
CAN BE CANCELLED THE NOT SUBMIT
IT SO SHE TOLD THE PERSON YEAH
JUST. YOU KNOW CAN IT. AND- THE
PERSON THAT WAS ATTENDING TO
HIM TO GO AHEAD AND RELEASE
THEM. BECAUSE HE WAS MISLED
WHEN HE WAS TOLD TO GOING TO
THE EMERGENCY ROOM. BY THE
PEOPLE OUTSIDE CRITICAL YES. SO
JEREMY'S MOTHER EXPLAINED THE
PERSON ATTENDING THAT HE COULD
NOT REALLY UNDERSTAND THE
PAPERWORK AND EVERYTHING THAT
HE WAS GETTING YOU KNOW ASKED
TO SIGN BE DO IT DISABILITIES
BUT HE WAS ONLY FOLLOWING THE
INSTRUCTIONS GOING FROM IT INTO
A DIFFERENT PLACE TO GET THE
PUBLIC AT. THE INDEPENDENCE.
TWENTY LATIMER'S REMEDY LIGHT.
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN. MY SON
JEREMY WAS REALLY JUST TRYING
TO DO THE RIGHT THING HE WAS
TRYING TO BE PROACTIVE IN
PURSUING A CONTESTANT HE HAD A
POTENTIAL EXPOSURE. HE SHOULD
NOT BE CHARGED FOR AN EMERGENCY
ROOM VISIT THAT HE DID NOT
INTENTIONALLY MAKE AND NOT
UNDERSTANDING THE RAMIFICATIONS
OF BEING AN EMERGENCY ROOM.
VISIT SHOULD NOT BE COUNTED AS
EMERGENCY ROOM VISITS AND WE
ARE ASKING THAT HE OUR CHARGES
ALMOST NINETEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS
TO BE REVERSED. AND ONLY THE
TESTING BE CHARGED. WELL
TURNING A PROTOTYPE INTO A
NUMBER ROOM VISIT WAS VERY
MISLEADING AND WHAT RIGHT- AS
OPPOSED- INCIDENTALLY I WENT
BACK DOWN TO THE OUTDOOR TENTS
AND TALK TO SOMEONE ABOUT THIS
AFTER THE FACT AND SHE DID
CONFIRM THAT YEP WE ARE GOING
TO CHARGE YOU LESS AND HAD AN
EMERGENCY ROOM VISIT. AND- THEY
WERE RATHER AN APOLOGETIC ABOUT
THE WHOLE SITUATION IT SHOWS
THAT A LITTLE BIT UPSETTING TO
ME BUT- WELL AS I WAS THERE
THERE WAS STILL YOU KNOW PEOPLE
ACTIVELY WORKING THE TAX. AND-
STILL OPERATIONAL CARS DRIVING
UP AND I DIDN'T SEE THEM
DIRECTING ANYBODY INTO THE ER.
I WAS A LITTLE BIT- ABOUT THAT
WHOLE THING BUT- ANYWAY GOT
THAT'S SORT OF MY STORY AND I'M-
UNFORTUNATE INCIDENT.
UNFORTUNATELY I'M I'M GONNA
KILL IT BUT I GOT A FEELING
THIS IS GOING TO COST QUITE A
BIT OF MONEY FOR SOMETHING THAT
WAS SUPPOSED TO BE- I GUESS IF
THERE'S A SUCH A THING AS A
ROUTINE CO THE TASK BUT THAT
WAS OUR INTENTION WAS REALLY TO
JUST TRY TO. IDENTIFY IF MY SON
HAD HAD IT SO WE CAN GO THROUGH
THE NORMAL POLITICAL SPECTRUM.
ANYWAY THANK YOU. WE NEVER GOT
THE CHANCE. THAT'S HOW THE UP.
THANK THANK YOU SHARP FOR SURE-
YEARS AND THE STORY OF YOUR
FAMILY- THE DICTIONARY- I KNOW
THAT- SO WE'LL FIRST- TAKE UP
GOT QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- CENTER MONEY. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN. I DO WANT TO
THANK YOU IN THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THE- ORGANIZATION OF
TODAY'S MEETING IT'S VERY
TIMELY. UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE
HEARING. REPORTS SEARCHES THAT
SHARED BY MR SHARP IN MISTER
SHARP IF YOU CAN HEAR ME. IT
SOUNDS AS THOUGH YOU DID
RECEIVE A BILL FROM THE
EMERGENCY ROOM DID THEY
COMPLETE THE COVERT TEST THAT
WAS THE SWAB THAT. WAS
ADMINISTERED TO YOUR SON. NO
THEY DID NOT SENATOR SO THEY
DID NOT AND THAT WAS BASED ON
THE OPTION THAT WAS GIVEN TO
YOU. THAT YOU DIDN'T WANT TO
PAY FOR EMERGENCY ROOM VISITS.
SO NO RESULT ON THE TEST AND
YET AN EMERGENCY ROOM BILL. AND
YOU SAID UBS YOU PLAN TO APPEAL
IT. CAN DETECT YOUR FAMILY DID
YOUR SON HAVE PRIVATE INSURANCE
COVERAGE. YEAH THAT'S THE
REALLY THE REASON WHY I'M
SPEAKING ON THE PRIMARY ON THE
INSURANCE- AND- WE DO ROUTE-
ANTHEM BLUE CROSS INSURANCE AND
HAVE YET. STERN UHHUH. GO AHEAD
EIGHT YES THEY DID NOT THEY
DID- PICK UP ABOUT 40% OF THAT
BILL- AND- INCIDENTALLY I LIKE
TO ALSO COMMENT THAT THE BILL
DATE CONTAINS A CHARGE FOR THE
TEST. WHICH REALLY NEVER. GOT
TOTALLY I GUESS BECAUSE THEY
SAY THEY SWAP YOU MAYBE THAT'S
THE FOR. NO RESULTS WERE EVER-
ASCERTAINED- SESSION HAS
STARTED WITH THIS BUT IF YOUR
SON IS HE DOING OKAY DID HE
CONTRACT CODE DO YOU KNOW. NO
HE DID NOT THAN A LOT OF
COMMENTS HE WAS EXTREMELY A
SYMPTOMATIC RIGHT- BUT- WE DID
SORT OF QUARANTINE I'M NEVER
THE LAST- AND YOU KNOW. THAT
THE PROTOCOLS WITH THAT'S WE
COULD INSIDE OUR HOUSE AND
WHATNOT BUT- BUT USUALLY
RECEIVE NO RESULT OF A CO THE
TEST AND YET YOU ARE CHARGED
FOR IT. AND YOU SAY ANTHEM BLUE
CROSS. HAS OFFER HER PAVE.
PERCENT OF IT BUT THAT WOULD
LEAVE YOU. WITH 60% OF A TEST.
YOU DIDN'T ASK TO BE ASKED TO
BE ADMINISTERED IN THE
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT SACRAMENTO.
THAT'S CORRECT AND WHEN YOU SAY
TASK THAT'S ONE PART OF THAT
THE OTHER PART IN THE MOST- THE
MAJORITY OF IT IS B. E. R.
ITSELF WHICH I THINK WOULD BE
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED AND SOMETHING
DOLLARS RIGHT- MMHM SO THAT
THAT'S THE UNFORTUNATE PART.
YES IN. WITH RESPECT TO ANTHEM
BLUE CROSS BONTA PAYING 40% DID
THEY PROVIDE YOU WITH ANY
POLICY INTERPRETATION THAT SAID
THEY WERE ONLY RESPONSIBLE FOR.
40% OF A COVERT RELATED TEST.
ADMISSION TO THE EMERGENCY ROOM
YES. YES THERE WAS A BREAKDOWN
I DID ASK FOR THAT I FORGET
WHAT EXACTLY DOES THAT DOCUMENT
IS CALLED BUT I DIDN'T GET IT
WITH THE BREAKDOWN OF THE-
COSTS AND COVERAGES. I DON'T
HAVE IN FRONT OF ME CENTER I'M
SORRY- NO THAT'S OKAY YES I
JUST HELP THEM. IT JUST RACES
SEVERAL LAYERS OF. POOR
COMMUNICATION IN APPARENTLY
UNCLEAR POLICY THAT EIGHT YEARS
SON WAS TAKEN INTO THE E. R. B.
THEY DID A TEST SPIN NO RESULT
EVER IN C. YEAR CHARGE FOR AN
EMERGENCY ROOM VISIT OF QUICK
RELATED TO A CODE REQUEST. BUT
IF WHICH YOUR INSURANCE CARRIER
IS ONLY OFFERING TO PAY 40% OF
THAT SO. MISTER CHAIR RIGHT I
THINK OTHERS WILL HAVE
QUESTIONS AS WELL BUT THIS
HELPS CLARIFY. THE
CIRCUMSTANCES OF THIS
PARTICULAR WITNESS ANNA MISTER
SHARP THANK YOU FOR SHARING
THIS STORY WITH THIS TODAY MUCH
APPRECIATED. THANK YOU SIR ARE
NOT ABA MUCH MY PLEASURE THANK
YOU SENATOR THANK YOU CEREMONY-
I THIS POINT DO NOT SEE ANY
HANDS UP. SO OKAY DON'T SEE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE OTHER
SANDERS I DID WANNA RECOGNIZE
THAT CENTER RUBIO IS NOW
JOINING US- REMOTELY. AS WELL
AND- WELCOME HER TO THE
COMMITTEE COMING AS WELL- AND
ASSOLUTA- THIS SHARP I WANT
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR SHARING
YOUR STORY I THINK US OUR MONEY
PRETTY MUCH COVERED A LOT OF
THE GROUND THAT THINK THAT WE-
THAT- AS WELL AND HIS QUESTIONS
AND- AND- AGAIN- SORRY THAT-
THIS- KERR TO YOU I THINK YOUR
SON WAS JUST TRYING TO DO. YOU
KNOW WHAT HE WAS TOLD AND-
CERTAINLY IS THAT YOU SHOULD
NOT BE SUFFERING CONSEQUENCES.
FROM THAT AND- HOPEFULLY- THE
SITUATION WILL BE RESOLVED IN
YOUR FAVOR- SHORTLY. SO AGAIN
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR SHARING
YOUR TESTIMONY. AND AND-
PLEASE- KEEP A SURPRISE IF
YOU'RE WILLING TO- AS TO WHAT'S
WHAT WHAT TRANSPIRES IN THE
FUTURE WITH THEIR YOUR
SITUATION IF WE CAN BE HELPFUL
IN ANY WAY THANK YOU. CERTAINLY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT-
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT- SAID PANELIST SO FIRST
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE THE FEDERAL
PERSPECTIVE- ONE A WELCOME-
SABRINA CORLETTE. WHO IS A
RESEARCH PROFESSOR AT THE
CENTER OF HEALTH INSURANCE
REFORMS AT GEORGETOWN MCCOURT
SCHOOL OF PUBLIC POLICY- SO
WE'RE GOING TO ASK THAT THE US
THE WITNESSES ON THIS PANEL-
KEEP THEIR REMARKS TO THREE
MINUTES I'M SURE WE WILL HAVE
QUESTIONS THAT WILL ALLOW
PEOPLE TO LIBERATE. ON THINGS
AS WELL SO I WILL BE TIMING
THAT AND THEN SO AND THEN
FOLLOWING- SABRINA CORLETTE
WITHIN GOING TO HAVE A
CALIFORNIA PERSPECTIVE WITH US
THEIR REDEEM- WITH. OVER AT THE
DEPARTMENT HEALTHCARE. AND
BRUCE HINES AT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE AND
THEN KATHLEEN JACOBSON OF RED
THE CALIFORNIA PART PUBLIC
HEALTH BUT LET'S FIRST BEGIN
WITH THAT. AGAIN SABRINA
CORLETTE- WELCOME AND- I
UNDERSTAND YOU HAVE A SET OF
SLIDES TO AS WELL SO I THINK
OUR I. T. FOLKS HOPEFULLY. I
HAVE GIVEN INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN. SO. PEOPLE
TO MY SITE YES THANK YOU WELL
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN TAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
I'M VERY HAPPY TO BE WITH YOU
THIS AFTERNOON- AS MENTIONS I'M
GEORGETOWN UNIVERSITY'S CENTER
ON HEALTH INSURANCE REFORMS WE
STUDY HEALTH INSURANCE POLICY
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL- AS WELL
AS ACROSS ALL FIFTY STATES. I'M
IN THIS I JUST HAS A FEW WAYS
YOU CAN GET A HOLD OF US-
FOLLOW- OUR WORK. I AM SO FIRST
OF ALL AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
WITH RESPECT TO COLLUDED
NINETEEN TESTING. UNDER THE
RELIEF ACT AS AMENDED BY THE
CURES ACT. I KNOW FIRST MUST
COVER YEAH WE'VE COST SHARING
FOR. ROOMS DIED TESTING FOR
COPD NINETY. THEY ALSO HAVE TO
COVER I AND SERVICE THAT ARE
DURING A PROVIDER OFFICE URGENT
CARE UNIT HE OUR VISIT THAT
RESULT IN AN ORDER OR FLOOR OR
ADMINISTRATION KOBE NINETEEN.
THE LAW ALSO SAYS THAT THAT CAN
BE AN IN PERSON VISIT OR VIA
TELEHEALTH YOU SHOW UP AT THE
EMERGENCY ROOM- AND YOU GET A
PHYSICAL EXAM ARE THERE OTHER
TESTS THAT YOU GET WHAT OTHER
CONDITIONS THE INSURANCE
COMPANY IS SUPPOSED TO COVER
THAT. COST SHARING. BUT ALSO
EXCUSE OF PRIOR ON THREE. BY
THE HEALTH. AND REQUIRES. TO
TEST PROVIDE. EITHER APP
NEGOTIATED RATE. OR THE FULL
CASH PRICE CHARGED BY THE
PROVIDER AS LONG AS IT'S LISTED
ON A PUBLIC WEBSITE. AND THESE
REQUIREMENTS APPLY. THE
DURATION OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY WHICH IS CURRENTLY
SLATED TO END ON JANUARY TWENTY.
IN JUNE THREE FEDERAL AGENCIES
HHS TREASURY LABOR ISSUED.
GUIDANCE THAT CLARIFIES THE
SCOPE OF THE FEDERAL MANDATE.
AND IMPORTANTLY THEY STATED
THAT INSERTS ARE ONLY REQUIRED
TO COVER MEDICAL. PRETEST
TURNED BY A LICENSE HEALTH CARE
ACTION. THEY SAID THE PLANS
INSURERS ARE NOT REQUIRED TO
WORKPLACE. OR TESTING PUBLIC
HEALTH PURPOSES OR FOR A
SYMPTOM INDIVIDUAL AS LONG AS
YOU'RE NOT A ORDER. I'M ALSO
CLARIFY WHAT FOR THE COVERAGE
MERE TO KEEP THE END A CALL
CENTERS MUST BE ORDERED
MINISTER DOOR THAT THE. YES I
CLARIFIED THAT HOME THE TESTS
ARE INCLUDED THE MANDATE BUT
THEY MUST BE ORDERED BY IN A-
BY. C. MOBILE SEEN SOME STATES-
HI HERE AND MAYBE- REQUIRING
AND IT'S TO HAVE. AT COVERAGE
THAN THIS STANDARDS PARTICULAR
ANY TO CAL. WEST FOR BERMAN NEW
YORK AND THE DISH OF COLUMBIA
OUR WORK ENSURE TO TEN FOR
ESSENTIAL ARE OTHER HE WORK
PROFESSIONALS LIKE AS NURSE
HOME CHILD CARE WORKERS IN SOME
STATES SUCH AS MASSACHUSETTS
AND MAINE ARE REQUIRING
INSURERS TO COVER TESTS FOR
EXAMPLE IF YOU NEED IT TO
INTERACT HEALTHCARE SYSTEM LIKE
PRIOR TO THE SURGERY. I'M SO WE-
I AM I TO IT OVER AND BACK TO
YOU CHAIRMAN PIANO I LOOK FOR
TO YOUR QUESTION. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- THAT SERVED AND VERY
HELPFUL. NOW LET'S MOVE ON TO
THE CALIFORNIA RESPECTIVE
FRIENDS MADE THIS I THINK-
SABRINA CORLETTE MADE NOTE THAT
WE HAVE STRONGER PROTECTIONS
BUT LET'S GET INTO THAT AND- SO
LET'S GO NOW TO SERRA REAM
ACTING GENERAL COUNSEL
DEPARTMENT MANAGED HEALTHCARE
WELCOME. YES GOOD AFTERNOON-
THANK YOU FOR HAVING HAVING US.
ON AS CHAIRMAN HAS SAID MY NAME
IS THEIR READING AND ACTING
GENERAL COUNSEL OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT MANAGED
HEALTHCARE. OTHER TEAM MADE HIS
MISSION IS TO PROTECT CONSUMER
HEALTH CARE RIGHT MATURE STABLE
HEALTHCARE DELIVERY SYSTEM. WE
HAD A STATE AGENCY RESPONSIBLE
FOR LICENSING AND REGULATING
ONE HUNDRED THIRTY ONE HEALTH
CARE SERVICE PLAN. THAT PROVIDE
HEALTH COVERAGE TO MORE THAN
TWENTY SIX MILLION CONSUMERS
AND WE REGULATE MORE THAN 96%
OF THE COMMERCIAL AND
GOVERNMENT HEALTH PLAN
ENROLLMENT IN THE STATE. OF
ENJOY IN RESPONSE TO. LARGELY
RESPONSE TO THE- REGULATORY
COVERING FOR A GUY THAT WE'RE
THE COURT. ME I DO MAKE THE-
NUMBER BRAKE. TO PROVIDE
CLARITY AND- REGARDING PLAN
COVERAGE FOR KOBE NINETEEN
CASTING. THE REGULATION DOES
TWO THINGS BROADLY. FIRST THE
REGULATION OUTLINES WHEN AND
HOW PLAN WILL COVER COVER
NINETEEN TESTING AND WHEN THE
PLANT RECHARGE COST SHARING
PROTECTING. SECOND THE
REGULATIONS GENERALLY REQUIRE
HEALTH PLANS AS OPPOSED TO
PROVIDERS. THOSE ARE THE COSTA
CODE NINETEEN TESTING. THE
REGULATION ALSO PROVIDES
CLARITY WITH RESPECT TO THE
HEALTH PLANS REIMBURSEMENT TO
PROVIDERS. FOR KOBE NINETEEN.
REGARDING PLAN COVERAGE COVERT
NINE TESTING- THERE ARE THREE
CAT. OF AN BETTER WILL LEAD ON
A RELATED FOR TESTING PURPOSE.
GROUP OF. IS BASED ON THE LAW-
THIS GROUP INTO THE FIRM WILL
YOU HAVE THEM DONE. OCTOBER
NINETEEN OVER THE NEXT. YOUR
AVAILABLE A UNDER THE LAW THE
ENROLLEES CAN GET TESTED IN
THAT WORK OR OUT OF NAY. AND
WITH NO YEAR. THE RELEASE HAVE
TO COVER THE TWO RIG OF THE
EMPLOYER RECEIVED THE CAT. THE
FACT AND THIRD CATEGORY
MEMORABLE. ARE DEFINED IN AND
BEING THESE EMERGENCY REGULATE.
THE SECOND GROUP INCLUDE EIGHT
AS AND WORKERS TO NO NO OR JUST
EXPO TO COLD AT NIGHT SO EITHER
HM. POTENTIAL WORKERS WHO DON'T
HAVE NO INFO. THE REGULAR
OUTLINED TO WORK AND TO WORK
THE GROUP INCLUDES FOR. THROUGH
THEIR WORKER BUSH RESPOND
CORRECTIONAL WORKERS FUTURE.
AND WORKERS IN OUR IN THE THAT
POLANCO HIGHER FOR COLBERT NINE
EXPOSURE. FOR THEY SENT TO MY
OFFENSE WORKERS THE RADIO STATE
NINETY TESTS IT MAY NOW. AND
ALL K. THIS MAY THE HEALTH PLAN
CANNOT WORK THE WERE TO GET
AUTHORIZATION OR TO GO YOU KNOW
THE MAN. BEFORE GETTING INTO. A
CENTRALLY AT THE WORKER THINKS
THEY NEED A TAX PLAN MUST COVER
IT. HOWEVER THE AGENT ESSENTIAL
MCCARTY THE PLAN OR AN IN
NETWORK PROVIDER TRY TO GET IT
PASSED. IF THE PLAN FAILS TO
PROVIDE A TESTING APPOINTMENT
WITHIN FORTY EIGHT HOURS TO THE
WORKERS REQUEST. THE WORK AND
THEN GO TO ANY PROVIDER TO GET
ATTACKED. IN NETWORK OR OUT OF
NETWORK. I AGENT AMANDA CENTER
WERE UNDER THE- MAY TO PAY.
COSTS FOR THAT CAN. THE THIRD
GROUP A BUNDLE- EIGHT. PEOPLE
WHO ARE NOT A GOOD WORKERS.
SUFFERED EITHER IN HEALTH PLAN
MUST COVER COVERT NOW TEN. WHEN
ATTEMPTED MEDICALLY NECESSARY
FOR THAT. AND THE UNHOLY MY TO
PAY. COSTS DURING FOR THE TAP.
THE MUST OFFER THEIR AT A BOY.
WITHIN NINETY HOURS OF THE
REQUEST THE ANIMAL. AND DOES
FAMILY GO OUT OF NETWORK. I
FINALLY REGARDING THE FOR
TESTING REAR FOR PROVIDER.
DEREGULATION PROHIBITS PLANTS
PASSING THE FOR RISK OF CALL
NINETEEN TAP INTO. I LIKE THE
PROVIDER THE PLAN BUT TO GO
THAT POINT AND AGREED TO THE
PROVIDER WILL THE FINAL RISK.
THIS AN IMPORTANT PROVISION
BECAUSE MY PLANTS AND PROVIDER
CREE CULTURE THEY- AGREED TO
CONTRA IN WHICH PROVIDER TOOK
ON THE FINANCE RESPONSE. FOR DI
TESTING GENERALLY. HOW THE
PARTY IS LIKELY TO NEXT THEM A
WORLDWIDE PANDEMIC WHEN THEY
ENTERED INTO THE CONTRACT.
REQUIRING PROVIDERS TO ASSUME
THE FINANCIAL RISK RECALLED IN
NINETEEN TESTING COULD CROOKS
PROVIDER TO THE FINANCIAL
BRAND. AND ULTIMATELY
JEOPARDIZE THE STABILITY OF THE
ENTIRE HEALTHCRE DELIVERY
SYSTEM INSTEAD UNDER THIS
REGULATION THE FINANCIAL RISK
FOR KOBE NINETEEN TESTING
REMAINS WITH THE PLAN TOLD THE
PLAN THE PROVIDER COULD.
SPECIFICALLY AGREED TO
OTHERWISE. THIS IS A I CAN FOR
THAT PLAN AND THE PARKING. A
WEEK AGO A LOT THAT WOULD FILED
AGAINST THE DEPARTMENT IN AN
EFFORT TO HAVE THE PROVISION OF
THE REGULATION APPEAL. A REPEAL
BEGINNING IF THIS PROVISION IS
REPEALED PROVIDERS RATHER THAN
PLAN COULD HAVE GOOD SO THE
COST TO COVER NINETEEN PASSED
INTO THE PROVIDERS. AND THAT
MIKE HAD AGREED TO COVER.
GENERAL DIAGNOSTIC TESTING.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NOW LET'S MOVE ON TO BRUCE
HINES SENIOR PUBLIC HEALTH
POLICY ATTORNEY FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR I AM. HELD POLICY.
JOURNAL CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
INSURANCE- ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMISSIONER CAUGHT A LOT OF
TO. BROUGH REMARKS AND SINCE
THE BEGINNING OF THE CALL COULD
NOT POUNDS. ONE OF COME LAW OF
TALK OR HE SAYS TO PROTECT THE
HEALTH TRIUMPH. ARE PRESERVED
ACT TO TESTING. COMMERCIAL AUTO
HAS TAKEN MULTIPLE ACTIONS TO
HELP KEEP CONSUMERS MAINTAINING
ACCESS TO CARE OF CARE
INCLUDING SAYS THE TEST. HIS
FIRST RESPONSE TO THE CRISIS
WAS TO ELIMINATE COST SHARING
FOR COLD NINETEEN TESTING. IN
THE INSURANCE MARKET THIS
ELIMINATED COPAYS DEDUCTIBLES.
AND OTHER COST PLACED ON
PROJECTS RELATED TO TESTING FOR
KOBE NINETEEN. AFTER GOVERNOR
NEWSOM DECLARED STATE OF
EMERGENCY COMMISSIONER LADAKH
DIRECTED INSURERS TO SUBMIT
EMERGENCY PLANS. TO ENSURE THAT
AFFECTED POLICYHOLDERS CONTINUE
TO HAVE ACCESS TO MEDICALLY
NECESSARY HEALTH CARE SERVICES
INCLUDING BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PRESCRIPTION DRUG ACCESS. THE
LATTER IN LIGHT OF CONCERNS.
REGARDING MALE DESTRUCTION.
COMMISSIONER WATER ALL DREW
HEALTH COMPANIES TO INCREASE
TELL ACCESS SPOKEN. INCLUDING
REIMBURSEMENT PARITY BETWEEN
TELEHEALTH AND IN PERSON
VISITS. HEALTH INSURANCE
COMPANIES MUST CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE ACCESS TO MEDICALLY
NECESSARY CARE. THE CALIFORNIA
POLICIES SHOULD BE ABLE TO
ACCESS HEALTH CARE INCLUDING
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES
WITHOUT HAVING TO PHYSICALLY
VISIT THEIR PROVIDER WHEN
CLINICALLY APPROPRIATE. IN
ADDITION JUDITH CONSUMER
COMPLAINTS WE'VE RECEIVED THE
DEPARTMENT ISSUED OUT
FREQUENTLY ASKED QUESTIONS FAQ
THAT IN PART WAS RELATED TO
COVER NINETEEN TESTING COVERAGE
REQUIREMENTS. IS IT JUST SOME
OF THE RECALL ACTIONS THAT
COMMISSIONER WATER AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF TAKING ON THE
SPONSORED COVERT NINETEEN. WITH
REGARD TO THE QUESTION BEFORE
YOU SENATOR REGARDING WHO PAYS
FOR TESTING OF DEPARTMENT
SUGGESTED THE PRIMARY FOCUS
SHOULD BE ENSURING THAT TESTING
IS READILY AVAILABLE TO THE
GREATEST NUMBER OF PEOPLE'S FOR
ANALYTICS FRAMEWORK THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE HIS
INITIAL THOUGHTS ON THIS
MATTER. FOR THE FOLLOW WELL
SOME OF THESE POINTS WERE
DRESSED IN FEDERAL LAW AND
GUIDANCE BUT ONLY. FOR THE
DURATION OF THE FEDERAL
EMERGENCY. CAN COSTS SHOULD NOT
BE A BARRIER TO TESTING. THE
PERSON SHOULD NOT BE LIMITED IN
THE NUMBER OF TIMES THEY MAKE
IT TESTING. TESTING SHOULD BE
EASILY ACCESSIBLE. PROVIDER
SHOULD BE PAID EVEN IF A PERSON
DOES NOT HAVE INSURANCE WE NEED
TO BE GUARDRAILS IN PLACE
GUARDRAILS IN PLACE. OUT OF
NETWORK PROVIDERS SHOULD BE
LIMITED TO HOW MUCH THEY ARE
REIMBURSED FOR TESTING. AND
RELATED ITEMS AND SERVICES SUCH
AS WE HEARD EARLIER IN ORDER TO
AVOID OVER CHARGING AND DRIVING
UP COSTS. ALSO PROVIDER BALANCE
BILLING SHOULD ALSO BE
PROHIBITED FOR COLD AT NIGHT
TESTING. AND RELATED ITEMS AND
SERVICES. OF THE PROGRAM TIME
WOULD BE VERY HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. VENTURE
MUCH- AGAIN THANK YOU THANK YOU
BRUCE NINETY FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY- NOW WILL MOVE. ON
TO. HI KATHLEEN AND- THE- HELP
WITH THE CENTER FOR. EASES OF
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
PUBLIC HEALTH WELCOME. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS. I
AM DOCTOR CAMPING JACOBSON I'M
WORKING ON THE COVERED NINETEEN
RESPONSE ON THE TESTING TASK
FORCE. I'VE BEEN ASKED TO
PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF THE
CURRENT TESTING GUIDELINES AND
RECOMMENDATIONS. AS OF
SEPTEMBER TWENTY SECOND UPDATED
TESTING PRIORITIZATION GUIDANCE
WAS RELEASED. BASED ON THE FACT
THAT TESTING TURNAROUND TIME
AND CAPACITY- IMPROVED-
ADVISING ALL TEARS FOR TESTING.
HAD BEEN MADE EQUAL MEANING
THAT EVERY HAD EQUAL FOR TEST.
IN THIS GUIDANCE REMAIN AT THIS
TIME. INSTEAD THE STATE ALSO
RELEASED GENERAL GUIDANCE FOR
RESPONDING TO COMPETE NINETEEN
IN THE WORK PLACE FOR EMPLOYERS.
THIS GUIDANCE IS THAT TESTING
ON WORKERS IN THE WORKPLACE
SHOULD BE THE FIRST STRATEGY
CONSIDERED FOR AGAIN FOR THE
KITCHEN OF ADDITIONAL CASES IN
THE WORKPLACE TESTING MAY BE
DONE AT A SINGLE POINT IN TIME
WHERE AT REPEATED INTERVALS.
EMPLOYERS SHOULD OFFER ON SAY
COULD BE NINETEEN TESTING OF
WORKERS OR OTHERWISE ARRANGE
FOR TESTING THROUGH THE
COMPANY'S. NO WORD GENERAL
MEDICAL SERVICES PROVIDER THE
EMPLOYER IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
INSURING ALL WORKERS ARE
OFFERED IN PROVIDED TESTING
EMPLOYERS SHOULD ALSO PROVIDE
INFORMATION TO WORKERS WHO MAY
PREFER TO CONTACT THEIR
PERSONAL MEDICAL PROVIDER FOR
DISSENT A CALIFORNIA
CORONAVIRUS TESTING TEST FOR
SIGN. PROTESTING LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS MAY ALSO BE ABLE TO
HELP FACILITATE TESTING OPTIONS
IF NEEDED. AS OF SEPTEMBER
TWELFTH TWENTY TWENTY- HE- ON
THE CRUDE OF IRIS DISEASE
TWENTY NINETEEN MITIGATION PLAN
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR TESTING OF
HEALTHCARE PERSONNEL IN
RESIDENCE AT SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES BOB WAS REVISED AND
UPDATED THIS SUPER. THE NFL
TWENTY FIFTY THREE POINT TWO.
BOMB WITH THIS GUIDANCE
RECOMMENDS BASED TESTING OF ALL
ON NURSING FACILITY RESIDENTS
AND HEALTH CARE PERSONNEL IN A
NURSING FACILITIES. WHAT THE
FIRST AFL TWENTY FIFTY THREE
POINT TWO SNAPS WERE DIRECTED
TO CONDUCT BASELINE TESTING FOR
ALL MY NURSING FACILITY
RESIDENTS AND HELP YOUR
PERSONNEL AT ANY FACILITY THAT
DID NOT HAVE A POSITIVE CASE AT
THE TIME AND REPORT THOSE
RESULTS. OF THE TESTING TO THE
CDPH BY JUNE THIRTIETH OF
TWENTY TWENTY THE BANK BASELINE
TEST RESULTS CAN BE FOUND. NOT
BEING A NURSING FACILITY
BASELINE TESTING WEBSITE. I
THE- UPDATED NURSING FACILITY
GUIDANCE- ALSO HAS
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR TESTING
NEWLY ADMITTED AND RESENTMENT
THAT RESIDENTS TESTING NEWLY
ADMITTED RESIDENTS PRIOR TO
ADMISSION INCLUDING TRANSFERS
FROM HOSPITALS OR OTHER HEALTH
CARE FACILITIES NOT THE
RECOMMENDATION IS IF THE
HOSPITAL DOES NOT TEST THE
PATIENT WITHIN SEVENTY TWO
HOURS OF TRANSFER THE NURSING
FACILITY MUST TEST UPON
ADMISSION RESULTS FOR A
SYMPTOMATIC PATIENTS TESTING IN
THE HOSPITAL DO NOT HAVE TO BE
AVAILABLE PRIOR TO THE NURSING
FACILITY TRANSFERRED. BY
NURSING FACILITIES MAY NOT
REQUIRE A NEGATIVE TEST RESULTS
PRIOR TO ACCEPTING A NEW
ADMISSION- IF. OUT THE HOUSE
FOR TO TESTS ARE NOT. THE
ADMITTED FROM THE HOSPITAL
SHOULD BE QUARANTINED IN SINGLE
ROOMS OR A SEPARATE OBSERVATION
AREA ALSO CALLED THE YELLOW OR
OBSERVATION AREA FOR FOURTEEN
DAYS FROM THE DATE OF THE LAST
POTENTIAL EXPOSURE. AND THEN
RETESTED. IF NEGATIVE THE
RESIDENT CAN BE RELEASED FROM
QUARANTINE AFTER THAT FOURTEEN
DAY PERIOD IN A NEGATIVE TESTS-
NURSING FACILITIES MAKE. CENTER
AND CUTE YOUR HOUSE DAYS PART
OF THAT FOR DAY. KEEN
OBSERVATION FOR NO. AS LONG AS
IT'S CRIED ARE MET. I GUESS
YOU'RE A UP SHORTLY SO OKAY
SEARCH SCREENING TEST- NURSE
FOR HELP CARE CHRIS IN. WITHOUT
ANY COULD NINETEEN CASES THE
RECOMMENDATION IS TO IN A
MINIMUM OF A WEEK SCREENING OF
ALL CARE PERSONNEL. BROWN'S
NEGATIVE TESTS. DO YOU WANT ME
TO WRAP UP NOW MORE YES INYO
YOU CAN JUST WRAP UP YEAH SO
WHAT WE'RE FOLK ON- BUT AND
GET SOME OKAY GREAT THEN I'LL
GO AHEAD. FROM WRAP UP HERE.
OKAY ALL RIGHT FINISHED OKAY
THANK YEAH YEAH THANK YOU THINK
THEY YOUS RIGHT YOU VERY MUCH-
SO NOW- OPEN IT UP FOR
QUESTIONS FOR THEM- SEE CENTER
MINING- THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
IN THANK YOU MAY. MY FIRST
QUESTION GOES TO MISS CORLETTE
ON THE FEDERAL. DECLARATION OF
EMERGENCY SAID THAT EXPIRES ON
JANUARY TWENTIETH CAN THAT BE
EXTENDED BY EXECUTIVE ORDER OR
DOES IT REQUIRE- REENACTMENT OF
THE TO FEDERAL ACTS YOU
REFERENCED. WELL THAT'S WESOME
AND ANY MINUTE OF TO- AND THAT
BE EXT ANY TIME NOW AND THEN
AND- YEAH WE DON'T KNOW FOR
SURE- WHAT THE MISTER WILL DO
THAT MOST MOST BOOKS SIX. THAT
THE THAT OPERATE WILL X. THANK
YOU THEN FOR ANY OF THAT
CALIFORNIA. LAW PANELISTS. IS
THERE ANY EVIDENCE OF HAVE HAVE
THERE BEEN ANY HEALTH PLANS
THAT HAVE BEEN CITED OR
PENALIZED FOR NON COMPLIANCE
WITH THE STATE REGULATIONS. SO
I WENT OVER TO A TEAMMATE C. I
THANK YOU FOUNDER- I'M NOT THAT
WE ARE AWARE OF ALTHOUGH AGAIN
OUR REGULATION WENT INTO
EFFECT. IN MID JULY- TYPICALLY
IT DOES TAKE THEIR THE LAST SO
BUT PLAN WOULD NOT. COMPLY WITH
THE FEDERAL OR THE DAMAGE THE
REGULATION. ON THEIR WE BE A
BIT OF A LACK WHEN THEY BUY
OCCURRED AND THE DNA THEY WOULD
WOULD LEARN ABOUT IT BECAUSE
THEY WERE PLAN WOULD NEED TO.
DENY OR LIMIT COVERAGE THE
ENROLLEES WOULD TO APPEAL TO
THE PLAN AND THEN OLD COME TO
THE TEAM- BUT NO WE'RE NOT A OF
ANY SPECIFIC VIOLATION OF THIS.
ARE YOU AWARE OF COME BEING
FILED THAT HAVEN'T BEEN.
INVESTING OR FINALLY. WE HAVE A
CAME TO HIM OF. BUT SPECIFIC
REALLY TO GET IT QUITE AS MUCH
DATA QUITE A BIT WE PRETTY.
SOME CALLS TO OUR HELP. I
PEOPLE AT WHERE CAN I GET A
WHERE WHERE CAN I FOR A OR IT
TOOK LONG TO GET MY- BACK- I
WOULD TO GO IN. TAKE ANOTHER
LOOK AT THE ANSWER YOUR AS IF
WE RECEIVED OTHER TO A PLAN.
BUT I'M NOT AWARE THAT WE IF WE
A IT. THE RESPONSIBILITY OF A-
OF A INSURANCE PLAN VIS A VIS A
COVETED NINETEEN TEST. WELL
FIRST I WANT TO SAY I'M I'M
VERY TIRED OF HEARD ABOUT. MR
SHARPEN UP AT. IN THAT TO SAY.
AND YOU KNOW I'M A LAWYER GOING
HEAD TO GIVE. LEGAL ADVICE-
GOOD TO SOMEONE WHO'S MICHAEL I
BUT IT DOES. IT DOES IT DOES
SOUND LIKE THEY'RE SOME- I
DON'T THINK THE HOSPITAL OR AND
OR- ON HIS HIS- CARRIER OF THE
LIBRARY COVERING. HELP
INSURANCE FOR IT- I FEDERAL LAW
AND I WOULD I WOULD LOOK
PROTECT. WELL ON THAT. ARE
CAUGHT THAT THE COP AND THE-
OKAY THINGS AS WELL SO I TO
HEAR AN THE BRIDE INTO THE TO
HEAR ABOUT HIS. **** THE
PUBLIC'S WHO HAS SOME OVERSIGHT.
WE DON'T KNOW IF MR SHARP- DID
FILE ANY COMPLAINT WITH
AGENCIES SOUNDS LIKE HE
COMPLAINED TO THE HOSPITAL
NEEDS CHALLENGING THE BILL.
WHAT WOULD BE YOUR ADVICE TO
ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
QUARTER THEY GO IF THEY RECEIVE
A LARGE BILL FOR A CODE.
NINETEEN TESTS. WELL I TELL- AS
I SAID IN MY TESTIMONY THE
DEPARTMENT HEALTHCARE WE
REGULATE OF THE MAJORITY OF
COVERAGE FOR A COMMERCIAL
COVERAGE IN THE STATE. SO I
WOULD DEFINITELY SAY AND
SOMEONE RECEIVED BALLOT BILL OR
SOMETHING THAT SEEMS. OUT OF
THE ORDINARY OF THE PROJECT
THEY SHOULD IF THEY IF THEY'RE
KNOW COVER. WHERE THEIR HEALTH
PLAN PRODUCTS I WOULD
DEFINITELY RECOMMEND THEY CALL
OUR ANYTHING HELP CENTER OUR
GOAL. I COULD BE MADE THAT
BEARD .COM AND FILED. ON IF
THEIR HEALTH PLAN IS COVERED IT
IS RIGHT BY THE BMA TO ON WE
CAN WE CAN PROVIDE THEM WITH
THAT THE- IF THE CAR IS NOW.
REGULATED BY THE BMA WE CAN
HELP PERSON NAVIGATE TO THE
REGULATORY AUTHORITY IT BE A
THE HIGH. A DEPARTMENT OF LABOR
SELF. PRADA WE CAN PROVIDE THEM
WITH THAT ASSISTANCE THANK YOU
IN THIS YEAR DEPARTMENT DO ANY
OUTREACH TUNE. CONSUMERS WHAT
THEY'RE RIGHTS ARE AND FOR.
WITH TO NINETEEN. TESTING. WHAT
WHAT THEY'RE WHAT THE ENROLLEES
RIGHT THE ARE IN THE OF PROCESS
SHOULD TAKE TO- GET AND HAVE
FOR THAT TESTING THANK YOU IN
MISTER CHAIR FROM JUSTICE ASK
THE TO WITNESS IF THERE ARE
AWARE IF THERE DEPARTMENTS HAVE
RECEIVED ANY COMPLAINTS OF.
OVERBILLING OR POSSIBLE
VIOLATION OF PATIENT RIGHTS
WITH RESPECT TO COVERT NINETEEN
SURE WELL IT YEAH SAY GO NEXT
TO DO I DON'T KNOW SEE PAGE
WOULD C. P. WHATEVER TO THIS
NOT. BUT MOST ARE DELIGHT.
THANK YOU SAN ARM ARE. THROUGH
CONCERN SERVICES DEPARTMENT HAS
WERE. A IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD OF
ABOUT. FIVE- COMPLAINTS. A
CONCERN CAME TO KOBE BILL IN
BEEN DISCUSSING TO- MANY OF
THOSE WERE. IN FEDERALLY RIGHT
PLAN AND THEIR OUTSIDE ARCHERY.
WELL BUT ARKANSAS SERVICE PART
IN HIS MAINTAIN. JOBS AND- THE
REST TO THE COMPLY. THAT OCCUR
IN BECAUSE WE'RE VERY OF THE-
WHERE ARE AT TESTING. AND WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE.
IN THE FOR BENEFITS OF THE.
WITH PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICERS BY
COUNTY THERE THE LEAD AGENCY
ON. ENFORCING THE TEARS AND-
THE VARIOUS PUBLIC HEALTH
PROTECTIONS DOCTOR JACOBSON IS
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
DOING ANYTHING TO. EITHER
ABOUT THEIR RIGHT TO COPE WITH
TESTING IN THE RIGHT. UNDER
CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES FOR THAT
TO BE PAID FOR BY THEIR HEALTH
PLAN. HI YEAH I KNOW COUPLE OF
THINGS THAT ARE HAPPENING THERE
IS THAT THEY HAVE BEEN WORKING
ON COMMUNICATIONS TO THE PUBLIC
FROM ABOUT THEIR RIGHT TO TEST
AND I. HOW THAT TESTING IS
COVERED BY VARIOUS ENTITIES.
ADDITIONALLY I IN REGARDS TO I
ENFORCEMENT- I KNOW THE BAND
CGHS TOGETHER AND- TASK FOR I
DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO ABOUT
THAT BUT- I NOTED THAT SPENDING
THE WORKS THE LAST. OF WEEKS OR
SO IS. THANK YOU AND THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN WOULD JUST CALL.
WITH ALL OF THESE ARE. OF STE
TO. INCURRED EXTRAORDINARY
REDOUBLING OF EFFORTS WE THANK
YOU FOR THE WORK YOU ARE DOING
THAT YOU ARE THE LINK TO THE
PEOPLE WE REPRESENT TO THE
PUBLIC TO PEOPLE THAT HAVE
EITHER BEEN EXPOSED TO HAVE
MAYBE MANIC SUPPOSED INCLUDING
ESSENTIAL WORKERS. AND WOULD
ENCOURAGE. MASSIVE PUBLIC
EDUCATION AN INVITING. THE
COOPERATION OF LOCAL MEDIA WITH
PUBLIC SERVICE ANNOUNCEMENTS TO
MAKE SURE PEOPLE ARE AVOIDING
TESTING. BECAUSE OF THE FEAR OF
NOT BEING ABLE TO PAY FOR IT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. THANK
YOU CEREMONY JUST ONE QUICK
QUESTION BEFORE MOVE ONTO OUR
NEXT- CENTER IS GOING TO SPEAK
WHICH IS GONNA BE CENTER RUBIO.
FOR SURE READ. A SOMETIMES YOU
DON'T KNOW WHETHER THEIR PLAN
IS A STATE REGULATED PLAN OR
FEDERAL REGULATED PLANNED- SO
IF THEY COME TO TEAMMATES SEE
AND SAID I HAVE A PROBLEM AND
IT TURNS OUT TO FEDERAL PLAN-
DO YOU HELP THEM WITH FILING
WITH THE FEDERAL. FEDERAL
AGENCY OR WHAT HAPPENS AND- YES
THANK CHAIRMAN WE DO. HELP THEM
ACTUALLY WITH FIRE. BUT WE
CERTAINLY DO OFTEN THE WAR HAND
TO THE APPROACH- THE
APPROPRIATE AGENCY FOR THE
RADIO PLAN- WE CAN ALSO THEM WE
CAN BOB AND I PEOPLE COME TO US
AND- THEY HAVE ACTUALLY. ADULT
INSURED THAT IS IN THE- BY A
AND- WHAT LOOKED LIKE IT.
LICENSE HEALTH PLAN SO WILL AT
THEM IN. FINDING ME UP. TIME
USUALLY DEPARTMENT OF LABOR AT
THE END OF FEDERAL LEVEL TO
ASSIST THEM WITH THE- I'M SO
WHAT WE- THEY'RE NOT THEY FALL
OUTSIDE OF OUR GREAT. WE DO DO
EVERY WE CAN TO GET THAT CAN
WITH THE RIGHT. THE RIGHT. OKAY
THANK THANK YOU THE AWAYS VERY.
CENTER RUBY. YES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I WILL OF ALL IN TAKE FROM
A TO STATE YOU TO. ALL OUR
FIRST REACHED. AND RIGHT CHECK
YOU KNOW NURSES AND DOCTORS WHO
ARE. AND THE THREE OF DAY SPENT
AND HELPING EVERY DAY DAY OUT
HAVE A- THAT ALONG THE THAT MOM.
I THINK SARAH GREEN YOUR BILL
THE ONE DISCUSS THE LAYERS AND
TRY OF THE PLAN WHEN THEY MUST
PAY. AND BORN WHEN IF THEY IT'S
A COST PLOUGH WHICH IS YOU KNOW
I. THINK WE TALKED ABOUT YOUR
TRUE THREE I'M A LITTLE.
INSULET OVERWHELMED FOR THAT
ARE OF IN THIS. BACK FOR THE
ORDER. I YOU KNOW CITIZEN NOW
THERE IN THIS NEED- IS THERE A
DAY OR I IN FOR. WHERE YOU KNOW
THAT PLANTS REQUIRED TO HOLD OR
GIVE THE STATE'S. NOW WHETHER
IT'S A- LOOK AT WEBSITES OR-
WHERE WITH THE WHICH THE- WAY
FOR THEM TO GO SEARCH IT THERE.
WE ALWAYS SAY ONE OF THE BEST
RESOURCES IS THE DAMAGE THESE.
PUBLIC WEBSITE- WE HAVE- FAQ WE
HAVE- LETTER TO PLAN WE HAVE. A
CALL THE NIGHT AT DEDICATED
AREA FOR COLBERT NINETEEN Q. NA
SO THAT WOULD BE AN EXCELLENT
PLACE FOR SOMEONE WHO NEED MORE
INFORMATION TO GO TO THAT
WEBSITE- BUT WE ALSO LOOK
THROUGH OUR PLAN HEALTH PLAN
PARTNERS TO ACCEPT IN SPREADING
THAT. THAT MESSAGE OF HOW
PEOPLE CAN GO ABOUT GETTING
TESTED AND WHAT THE- WHAT THE
COSTS ARE MAY BE OR OR NOT BE-
AND THEN WE ARE TALKING- AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER WE WERE
TALKING WITH ON CONSUMER
ADVOCACY GROUPS- WE'VE TALKED.
WITH REPRESENT FROM. AND OR-
JEWISH. TO THOSE. ARE WHAT ARE
REGULATION. THE HEALTH PLAN YOU
DO THEIR EMPLOYEES. CAN GO
ABOUT GETTING GETTING TESTED
WHAT THE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
COST SHARING MAY. SO WE ARE
REALLY TRYING TO GET THAT
MESSAGE OUT THERE BUT I WOULD
SAY THAT ONE OF THE BEST
RECORDS FOR. AND WILL LEAD IS
THE DAMAGE THE PUBLIC WEBSITE.
THE WELL HAD A WEALTH OF
INFORMATION. THANK YOU I HAVE
ONE MORE COMMON TO ADD TO THAT
I THINK I HEARD ON TIER TWO ARE
YOU CITY SYMPTOMATIC IT'S
ESSENTIAL WORKERS IN YOU
INCLUDED. TEACHERS AND AYE
CATEGORY. I KNOW SEVERAL
TEACHERS WHO WOULD NOT KNOW
THIS INFORMATION LIKE- ONCE
AGAIN I KNOW THAT THEY CAN GO
TO THE WEBSITE BUT I THINK
COLLABORATING WITH LIKE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO LET THEM KNOW
WOULD BE IDEAL I KNOW. SEVERAL
WHO DON'T TASK BECAUSE THEY
BELIEVE THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO PAY OUT OF POCKET. SO IS
THERE EFFORTS OR AGAIN I'M JUST
TRYING TO- YOU KNOW- FIND OUT
FOR PEOPLE THAT YOU KNOW AND
JUST TRYING TO SEE THERE IS A
NEED THAT WE- NEED TO
COLLABORATE CLOSER WITH WITH
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT'S WHAT'S
YOUR OPINION ON THAT- I I'VE- I
APPRECIATE THAT. THAT
RECOMMENDATION I'LL TAKE THAT
BACK. WE HAVE. A DEDICATED TEAM
ON ON OUTREACH. I WILL TAKE
THAT BACK TO THEM TO SEE IF
THEY HAVE. GOING DOWN THAT PATH
AND IF THEY HAVEN'T WILL
CERTAINLY. ONLY TAKE TAKE THAT
AND RUN WITH IT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THAT'S ALL DR PAN THANK
YOU THANK YOU SIR RUBIO- I
DON'T SEE OTHER ANY OTHER HE
ENDS UP AT THE MOMENT- SO. I DO
HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS AS WELL-
SO FIRST. LET'S START WITH
SABRINA CORLETTE AND AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
ABOUT THE WHAT'S GOING TO
FEDERAL LEVEL- AND WE HEARD
ABOUT MR SHARP'S- STORY- WHAT.
WHAT SHOULD CALIFORNIA DO A
WHAT CAN CALIFORNIA DO YOU KNOW
WEDID HEAR FROM MY TEAMMATES
ABOUT HOW THEY DO A WARM HAND
OFF. DUE TO HELP PEOPLE IN A
SHORT POSITION IF HE HAS IF
YOU'RE A SELF REGULATED PLAN
ARE PEOPLE WHO HAVE. A SELF
REGULATE PLAN SINCE WE DON'T
HAVE THE STATE AUTHORITY OVER
THOSE PLANS. FOR SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT- OUR STATE SHOULD
CONSIDER DOING THAT REGARD.
RIGHT IT'S CHALLENGING BECAUSE-
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IT IS
PREEMPTED UNDER FEDERAL LAW
FROM IMPOSING REQUIREMENTS ARE
COVERAGE MANDATES ON SELF
FUNDED PLANS- UNDER THE FEDERAL
LAW. ARISSA I DON'T KNOW WHAT
TYPE OF COVERAGE- MISTER SHARPS
HIS- AND IF IT IS A SELF FUNDED
PLAN IT WOULD BE GOVERNED UNDER
FEDERAL LAW AND NOT STATE LAW-
IT. IRONICALLY ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT MAY HAVE. AFFECTED
HIS BILL IS THE FACT THAT HE
ASKED FOR THAT COULD BE TESTED
BE REMOVED FROM THE BILL. I'M
BECAUSE UNDER FEDERAL LAW THE
COVERAGE REQUIREMENT ONLY KICKS
IN IF THE TEST IS ORDERED OR
ADMINISTERED DURING THE
EMERGENCY ROOM VISIT. IF
THERE'S NO COAL BUT NINETEEN
TEST ON THE BILL THAT THE
INSURANCE COMPANY RECEIVES.
THEN THE COVERAGE REQUIREMENT
WOULD NOT. AGAIN- UNDER THE
FEDERAL LAW. THANK YOU CELLS
CELLS LIKE WE HAVE TO. ASK OUR
FEDERAL PARTNERS TO HELP US OUT
THERE HOPEFULLY THEY CAN KEEP
THEIR REGULATIONS AS WE CAN'T
DO THAT- THEN THIS IS NOW THIS
QUESTION FOR BOTH- MISTER HìNH
Z. AND NUMBER SIGN Z. AND SERRA
REDEEM- THIS TRYING TO YOU
TESTIFIED AND CERTAINLY- IT'S-
REASONABLE SAY THAT OKAY WELL
IF SOMEONE'S OUT OF NETWORK
CARD IT SHOULD BE A REASONABLE
COST WHICH IS NOT GO PAY
WHATEVER- WHAT WHAT KIND OF GUY
GUARDRAILS IS DEAL- I. HAS THE
ARE PUT IN PLACE OR IS
CONSIDERING PUTTING IN PLACE IN
REGARDS TO THOSE PAYMENTS AND
THEN ALSO I'M HOPING THAT-
SERVING COULD ALSO PERHAPS
COMMENT ON- WHAT OUR PLANS
EXPECTED TO PAY IN TERMS OF
TESTS. IF YOU GET A BILL THAT
MIGHT THINK IS A BIT LARGE ARE
ARE EXCESSES SO I NEED TO START
WITH MR NINETY. THANK YOU
SENATOR- RIGHT NOW THE
ENVIRONMENT THAT CONTROLS THE
LAW COMPENSATION FOR THE
TESTING IS THAT PROVIDED BY THE
FEDERAL FAMILIES FIRST ACT
INDICATORS ACTS AND THAT IS
THAT THE PAYMENT IS EITHER THE
NEGOTIATED RATE OF THE PROVIDER
FOR THE TESTING- AND THE
PROVISION OF THE TEST. FOR D.
IF THERE'S NO NEGOTIATED RATE
THE TEST THE EXCUSE ME THE
PRICE THAT THE PROVIDER POSTS
ON A PUBLIC WEBSITE. MMHM
THAT'S THE STRUCTURE OF THAT
NOW DEFINES WHAT. INSURERS NEED
TO PAY ON THE ACCOUNT WHAT
MATTERS CAN BILL FOR. LIKE ALL
THE OTHER FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS
HOWEVER THIS IS LIMITED TO THE
DURATION. OF THE FEDERAL
EMERGENCY SO HOW SHOULD WE LOOK
FORWARD TO A TIME WHEN PERHAPS
THE STATE MAY WISH TO HAVE A-
LONGER EMERGENCY THAN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DECIDES HOME
DISTRICT CENTURY MAY WISH TO
CONSIDER LEGISLATION TO MOVE
SUCH CONCEPTS OVER INTO OUR
CODES THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU-
SERINE GEN ONE COMMENT. YES I
WOULD ECHO WHAT THE DURING THE
BAD ON THE GLOBAL AND ADDS THAT
OR- UNDER THE DAMAGE TO
REGULATE WITH RESPECT TO.
ENROLLEE WHO ARE A SYMPTOM OR
WHO DO NOT HAVE A RECENT
SUSPECTED OR KNOWN EXPOSURE TO
COAL BUT NINETEEN. THE HEALTH
PLAN WOULD HAVE WOULD BE
EXPECTED TO PAY I'VE EVER BEEN
ASSOCIATED RATE IF THEY PLAN ON
THE PROVIDER HOW ONE. OR IF
THEY DO NOT IF THEY AND MOULAY
HAD GONE OUT OF NETWORK AND
THEN PROVIDER WOULD BE
COMPENSATED AT THE REASONABLE
AND CUSTOMARY RATE FOR KOBE
NINETEEN TESTING AND THAT IT-
KEEPING IN LINE WITH WHAT THE
KNOCKED. KEEN ACT. BUT
GENERALLY WITH. YOU OUT OF
NETWORK- BUDGET. SERVICE AT.
OKAY THANK YOU HAVE A QUESTION
ACTUALLY IT IS- FOR- DOCTOR
JACOBSON AT THE CITY PH AND A I
UNDERSTAND YOU'RE ON THE
TESTING TASK FORCE AND- WELL I
THINK CERTAINLY C. PH IS MORE
FOCUSED ON THE PUBLIC HEALTH-
RISKS AND- AND MANAGEMENT OF
THIS PANDEMIC- AS THE- THE
DEPARTMENT LOOKS AT. HIM
BASICALLY- ESTABLISHING
SURVEILLANCE OR OTHER TYPES OF
TESTING IN WORKPLACES AND IN
THE COMMUNITY- BUSINESS IS
THERE ALSO ANY DISCUSSION AS TO
WHO IS EXPECTED TO PAY FOR A
SURVEILLANCE TESTING IN
DIFFERENT SETTINGS INCLUDING
WORKPLACE SETTINGS AND THIS
THEIR SURVEILLANCE TESTING THE
COMMUNITY- IT'S THAT THERE'S
THERE BEEN DISCUSSION AT CDPH
ABOUT WHICH ENTITY. SHOULD BE
PAYING FOR IT IS THAT THE LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENT IS IT- WORK
THE BUSINESS'S AT THE INSURER
FOR THE EMPLOYEES THAT PERHAPS
THE BUSINESS EVEN IF PAYING
PARTLY FOR THE WORKERS
COMPENSATION WHO WHO IS THE
ENTITIES EBITDA BEEN
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT WHICH
ENTITIES WOULD BE PAYING FOR
EXAMPLE SURVEILLANCE TYPE
TESTING THAT HAS. DEREK OUT
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM CDPH. SO
THE FINE DETAILS OF THEM I
MEAN- I DON'T KNOW THE EXACT
ANSWER SERVICE I DON'T OKAY I
DON'T WANT TO MISS SPEAK BUT
I'M HAPPY TO TRY TO FIND THOSE
ANSWERS I KNOW SOME OF THE
GUIDANCE AS TO HOW PREFERENCES-
TO- OCCUPATIONAL HEALTH- THAT.
DOES HAVE SOME OF THAT
INFORMATION AVAILABLE ON. SOME
OF THE CADENCES BUT I'M HAPPY
TO FIND OUT MORE DETAIL FOR YOU
AND GET BACK TO YOU OKAY SO
OKAY I JUST WANTED TO FIND
OTHERS EVEN DISCUSSION OF THAT
IN THE TASK FORCE OR NOT- AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT. YOU KNOW THE
FIRST ROLE CDPH IS TO ESTABLISH
THE- STANDARD OF CARE IT'S
BASICALLY STATUS TO STANDARDS
WE SHOULD BE FOLLOWING BASED
PRIMARILY ON PRIME PUBLIC
HEALTH GUIDELINES BUT- I KNOW
OF THOSE PARTS QUESTION. YEAH
OFTEN OFTEN PART OF THE
DISCUSSION. OKAY ALL RIGHT. SO
I GUESS SO THEN MOVE ON TO- THE
SIMILAR QUESTION BUT FOR BETTER
TEAR REMAND- BRUSTEIN Z- SO. IN
TERMS OF PAYING FOR THESE THE-
SURVEILLANCE WORKPLACE SAFETY-
I GUESS ONE COULD DISTINGUISH%
BETWEEN THOSE TESTS THAT WERE
DONE BECAUSE THE WORKPLACE HEAD
DECIDED THEY WANTED TO DO IS-
VERSES THOSE THAT WERE
SPECIFICALLY REQUIRED PERHAPS
EVEN THROUGH PUBLIC HEALTH
ORDER BY. THE PARM PUBLIC
HEALTH SO IN YOUR OPINION IS
THAT SOMETHING THAT HEALTH
INSURANCE SHOULD BE RESPONSIBLE
FOR OR OTHER ENTITIES IF THERE
IS TESTING WELL FIRST OF ALL
THAT IS REQUIRED BY PUBLIC
HEALTH GUIDELINES THROUGH
PUBLIC HEALTH ORDER. AND THEN-
WHAT IF THERE IS- LET'S SAY A-
A- AND- BOX AGREEMENT LET'S SAY
BETWEEN THE WORKERS ARE UNION
AND EMPLOYER FOR TESTING THAT
MIGHT EXCEED THAT OF. PUBLIC
THAT PUT OUT BY A TAPE LOCAL
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER STATE
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER- FOR
SURVEILLANCE TESTING WHO SHOULD
BE PAYING FOR THAT TESTING- IS
THAT SOMETHING INSURANCE SHOULD
BE RESPONSIBLE FOR SENSE
ESPECIALLY PUBLIC HEALTH ORDER
IS SOMETHING YOU HAVE TO
FOLLOW. SO I NOTICED NAY BILL
START WITH THAT CERA REAMS DID
YOU HAVE ANY. THOUGHT ABOUT SO
WHAT HEALTH PLAN SHOULD BE WITH
TO DO IN THAT REGARD. SURE AND
WE'VE ACTUALLY HAD A FAIR
NUMBER OF CONVERSATIONS WITH-
REPRESENTATIVES FROM INDUSTRY-
FOKKER BANNING- BUILDER
CONVERTIBILITY THAN AND SIMILAR
SORTS OF PLACES AND OUR ANSWER
HAD BEEN UNDER A REGULATION
WELL FIRST LET ME BACK UP UNDER
THE CARE OF AN AFFECT THE R.
THE FEDERAL ACCESS SOMEONE HAS-
IT'S SYMPTOMATIC- HAD THE
CLOSURE THEN THEY CAN'T BE
TESTED. OUT OF NETWORK I
WITHOUT A HOT WITHOUT QUESTION-
IF WE HAVE THAT FOR EXAMPLE
EXENCIAL WORKER- THAT NURSING.
EMPLOYEE ARE NOT THEY'RE NOT
ACT STRUCTURE AND OUR REGULAR.
REALLY DO CONTEMPLATE THAT I
ROWLEY WILL TO THEIR PLAN OR
THEIR IN NETWORK PROVIDERS TO
OBTAIN THAT HAS- THAT STRUCTURE
AND DOES NOT CONTEMPLATE THAT
THE EMPLOYER WOULD BE BRINGING
IN- YOU KNOW A MOBILE TESTING
UNIT FOR EXAMPLE ON THE TEST
ALTHOUGH ALL THE EMPLOYEES- AT
ONCE AND THAT HEALTH PLAN WOULD
BE WOULD BE PAYING FOR THAT
THAT'S SIMPLY NOT DOES NOT.
REALLY SQUARELY FALL WITHIN THE
STRUCTURE OF THAT OF AN ACT CAN
ACT BUT IT'S AN ESSENTIAL
WORKER. I CHOSE TO BE TESTED
MULTIPLE TIMES IN A WEEK- THAT
YOU KNOW IF THEY THEY WOULD THE
PLAN WOULD HAVE TO BE REQUIRED
TO PAY FOR THAT CUTTING THE
LONGER THAT WATER WENT THROUGH
THE HEALTH PLAN OR THE IN
NETWORK PROVIDER TO OBTAIN THAT
TESTING. SO WITH RESPECT TO THE
QUESTION OF WHO SHOULD PAY FOR
IT- I CAN'T ANSWER THE QUESTION
THAT UNDER THE KNOCKED KEEN.
ACT THE HEALTH PLAN. HEY FOR
AND FOR THE- WORKERS WHEN- NEED
THE ESSENTIAL WORKER GOAL TO
HELP PLAN FOLLOWS THE REQUIRE.
OF THE OF THE REGULATE AND THE
NOT AT. OKAY THANK YOU-
PRECISELY FOR DEAL I. THE THANK
YOU CENTER- AND I FOUR CREW
GREG. RELEASED THE IRAQI.
SAFETY AND HEALTH CARE FOR CAL.
BASED ON. THERE'S THAT- FOR
WORKPLACE EXPOSURES WHICH ARE
SPECIFICALLY DEFINED CONSISTENT
WITH THAT- CDC GUIDANCE HELLO
FIVE FIFTEEN- CUMULATIVE
MINUTES A TWENTY FOUR HOUR
PERIOD OF EXPOSURE TO A- ON
KNOWN OR SUSPECTED SOURCE OF
CODE NINETEEN. THESE ARE- CAL
OSHA- PROPOSALS WOULD REQUIRE.
THE EMPLOYER TO PAY FOR
TESTING. IN THE CONTEXT OF THAT
EXPOSURE NOW THE CURRENT
FEDERAL LAW THE FAMILIES FIRST
AND CHARISMATIC REQUIRE
COVERAGE BY INSURERS IF A-
TREATING PROVIDER TENDING
PROVIDER WHO NEED NOT BE
DIRECTLY PROVIDING CARE BUT
HAS. REVIEWED EIGHT PATIENTS ON
A STEP UP SITUATION DETERMINES
OF THAT TESTING IS MEDICALLY
APPROPRIATE GENDER PROTECTIONS
OF THE FEDERAL LAW REGARDING
OUR COVERAGE WITHOUT- COST
SHARING- CAMPBELL LIKE APPLY.
AND SO WE GET TO THE QUESTION-
REGARDING OF THE IMPORTANCE OF
EARLY SYMPTOMATIC SPREAD THAT
WE'VE BEEN LEARNING ABOUT IN
RECENT MONTHS THAT YOU MAY NOT
HAVE A SITUATION WHERE- THE
PROPER FILTER IS WAITING FOR
PEOPLE TO HAVE SYMPTOMS BECAUSE.
WE WANT TO CATCH THE
SYMPTOMATIC- FEDERAL WE
MEDICALLY OF. BASED A-
REVIEWING PROVIDERS ASSESSMENT.
OPENS THE DOOR TO POSSIBILITIES
FOR ON THE- APPROPRIATE TESTING
OF PERSONS WHO ARE NOT
DEMONSTRATING SYMPTOMS FROM WHO
DO NOT HAVE OCCUPATIONALLY
DEFINED EXPOSURE BY ARM IF THAT
PROVIDER THINKS THAT THE TEST
IS MEDICALLY APPROPRIATE THEN
IT GETS COVERED WITH THE
PROTECTIONS OF THE ACT THAT'S-
OUR CURRENT SITUATION OUR
CURRENT PATH. AGAIN THE STATE
MAY WISH TO ESTABLISH A
STRUCTURE THAT PROVIDES THAT-LEVEL ON THE HOME. COVERAGE
WHERE INSURERS WILL BE PAYING
FOR SEX- TESTING- SEPARATE AND
APART FROM THE CURRENT SOMEWHAT
TEMPORARY OF FEDERAL LAW THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU AND
THEN FINALLY WHEN- A QUESTION
ABOUT- WELL- SO PLAN RIGHT THEY
GET THEY THEY GET THE- REQUEST
REIMBURSEMENT FROM THE PROVIDER
OR TO FIGHT OR SEEN THE
PATIENT- HOW ARE THE PROVIDERS
INSURANCE COMPANIES SUPPOSED TO
DISTINGUISH BETWEEN THE TALK
ABOUT THIS TEARS- S. B.
ESSENTIAL WORKERS FROM THE-
OTHERS. SO MANY OF DIRECT THAT
TO- SERRA REAMS- SO WE HAVE THE
DIFFERENT TIERS YOU TALKED
ABOUT BUT- HOW TO SORT OUT
WHO'S IN WHICH HERE- AT LEAST
IN THE PLAN I GUESS I GUESS A
PROVIDERS OR SEEN THE PATIENTS
DIRECTLY IN FRONT OF THEM
ALTHOUGH AGAIN WE COULD BE
REMOTELY OR SOMETHING. HOW DO
YOU DISTINGUISH BETWEEN PEOPLE
OF DIFFERENT TIERS AND THE PLAN
GETS THE REIMBURSEMENT REQUEST
SO HOW DO THEY TELL. YEAH
ADMITTEDLY I BUT I COULD SEE
THAT IN AND PRACTICES YOU KNOW
I OTHER COULD BE SOME
DIFFICULTY THERE. HOWEVER WE
HAVE PUT IN THE REGULATION AND
FURTHER GUIDANCE- AFTER THE
REGULATION. THAT THE HEALTH
PLAN CAN'T FIND OUT. THE
PROVIDER BOB. WHAT THAT'S AN
ESSENTIAL WORKERS AND IF THE
PROVIDER BECAUSE YEAH. YOU KNOW
I THE PERSON WONDER BELIEVE AYE
THEY WEREN'T A WORKER I'M BAD
AT ALL THE EVIDENCE THAT THE
HEALTH PLAN CAN ASK. FOR
PUTTING THAT PERSON IN THAT
HERE. A HEALTH PLAN WE WANTED
TO SURE THAT. PLANT IN THE
PROVIDER NOT GET A BACK AND
FORTH. WITH THE HEALTH PLAN
OKAY ELECT SHOW WITH THE PROOF
SHOWING WHERE THE FOR WORKS
WHAT THEY- ALL THE AND BELIEVE
ME NEED DO WITH YES I AT THE
I'M A SOCIAL. AND THEY INTO
THAT BUCKET. WE WANTED TO MAKE
IT AS AS- AND EASY AS POSSIBLE
THE OFFENSE WORKERS TO. A
TESTING. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. RIGHT OKAY. NOT
SEEING ANY HANDS UP- I TO THANK
EACH OF YOU YOUR- AT- AND A-
NOW. TO ON TO- SERVER RESPONDED
SO HAVE TO ACTUALLY SEE.
WITNESSES FOR. THE FROM MANY
TO. PERSPECTIVES ON THIS VERY
ISSUE OF- PAYMENT FOR TESTING.
ENSURING PEOPLE ACCESS TO
TESTING. TERMS OF- SO. THAT WE
HAVE KILL C. R. WALDRON WHO'S
WITH THE- BAY AREA LEGAL AID
SCHEME HEALTH COMMUNITY CENTER.
DR WILLIAM EISENBERG- CHIEF
QUALITY AND SAFETY OFFICER AT
SUTTER HEALTH. THE JURY. DUTY
KENNEDY PRESIDENT OF- BEEN
ASSISTED HEALTH INSURANCE
SERVICES. AND CHAIR OF THE
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE THE LOS
ANGELES THIRTY OF HEALTH
UNDERWRITERS- TRINA GONZALEZ
FACE. PRESENT POLICY FOR THE
CALIFORNIA. HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION WILLIAM BARCELONA
WITH AMERICA'S PHYSICIANS
GROUPS CHRISTINE FOR A FROM THE
CALIFORNIA'S CLINICAL
LABORATORIES ASSOCIATION IN NYC
LOUISA'S FROM THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH PLANS SO.
I'M GONNA ASK EACH OF YOU TO
KEEP. YOUR REMARKS TO TWO
MINUTES OR LESS SAID. THAT SO
TOO DID THE HIGHLIGHTS AND- AND
THEN WE'LL TAKE QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS AFTER THAT SO WE'LL
BEGIN AGAIN WITH GUILTY WALDRON
AWAY HIS ATTORNEY AT THE BAY
AREA LEGAL AID. STE HEALTH
CONSUMER CENTER WELCOME. I
THANK YOU SO MUCH- MY NAME IS
KELSEY WALDRON I'M AN ATTORNEY
BAY AREA LEGAL AID BAY AREA
LEGALLY AS PART OF THE WHOLE
CONSUMER LAND. I'M SO SORRY
THERE'S SOMEONE GOING THERE. IS
DISTRACTING. JUST GOING- HOW
THE CONSUMER ALLIANCE PROVIDES
LEGAL SERVICES TO ALL HELP
CONSUMERS IN EVERY COUNTY
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. AREA
LEGAL AID SERVES SEVEN COUNTIES
IN THE BAY AREA WITH FREE LEGAL
SERVICES IN REGARDS TO HEALTH
INSURANCE RELATED LEGAL ISSUES.
AND I HAD TO CLIENTS STORIES TO
SHARE WITH YOU TODAY BOTH
CLIENTS SOUGHT MEDICAL SERVICES
FOR KOBE TESTING AND BOTH HAVE
PRIVATE HEALTH INSURANCE PLANS
THAT ARE REGULATED BY THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. THE FIRST CLIENT
IS A FAMILY WITH A ONE YEAR OLD
DAUGHTER IN LATE MARCH OF THIS
YEAR THEIR DAUGHTER HAD CODE
NINETEEN SYMPTOMS INCLUDING A
FEVER. WORRIED ABOUT COVERT
NINETEEN THE PARENTS TOOK THEIR
DAUGHTER TO THE ER TO BE TESTED
FOR CODE NINETEEN. AT THAT TIME
IN LATE MARCH THIS HOSPITAL DID
NOT HAVE ANY COLOR NINETEEN
TESTS THAT THEY COULD
ADMINISTER ON THE CHILD TO THE
HOSPITAL DECIDED THEY WOULD
GIVE HER A TEST FOR THE FLU.
WHICH IF SHE TESTED POSITIVE
FOR FLU IT WOULD BE LESS LIKELY
BUT SHE WAS POSITIVE FOR
COCAINE. THE CHILD ENDED UP
TESTING POSITIVE FOR FLU AND
ARE SENT HOME A FEW MONTHS
LATER THIS FAMILY RECEIVED A
BILL FOR TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR THE ER VISIT. THIS FAMILY
CALLED US BECAUSE THEY WERE
CONFUSED AND FRUSTRATED FOR
RECEIVING THIS BILL. THE
HEADLINES ABOUT LAW CHANGES BUT
THIS FAMILY TO BELIEVE. THAT
THE SERVICE WOULD BE FULLY
COVERED. THE SECOND CLASS HAD
CONCERNS ABOUT TWO SEPARATE
COBRA TOPS. THE FIRST TASK THE
CONSUMER WAS HAVING SYMPTOMS
AND WANT TO GET A TOP FROM A
NEARBY HOSPITAL THE CONSUMER
LATER RECEIVED A BILL FOR A
HUNDRED DOLLARS THE CONSUMER
CHALLENGES BILL WITH THE
HOSPITAL AND THE HOSPITAL HAS
START BILLING HIM FOR THIS BUT
IT'S UNCLEAR WHETHER THE
HOSPITAL WILL CONTINUE TO BILL
FOR THIS TEST. THIS CLAN ALSO
HAD AN ISSUE ABOUT ANOTHER CO
PROTEST HIS THROAT SPECIALIST
DOCTOR ORDERED HIM TO TAKE
COVER TEST BEFORE HIS THROAT
EXAMINATION. THE CLIENT
RECEIVED THIS COVER TEST AT A
FACILITY WHERE THEY'RE THROUGH
DOCTOR REFERRED HIM TO. MONTHS
LATER THIS CLIENT RECEIVED AN
EXPLANATION OF BENEFITS FROM
HIS INSURANCE BUT STATED THAT
THE PATIENT PORTION FOR THIS
COVER TEST WAS FOUR HUNDRED
DOLLARS. THE CONSUMER HAS NOT
YET RECEIVED A BILL FOR THIS
AMOUNT BUT THERE IS CONCERN
THAT THIS PROVIDER WILL BUILD
THIS KIND OF ACTUALLY FOR THE
SERVICE BASED ON THIS
EXPLANATION OF BENEFITS. THAT
YOU TO WRAP UP SORRY. ANY
CALIFORNIANS WHO DOES NOT KNOW
WHO THEIR HEALTH PLAN REGULATOR
IS OR WHO HAS QUESTIONS ABOUT
THEIR BILL CAN CALL THE HELP
CONSUMER ALLIANCE FOR FREE
CONVERSATION WITH A HEALTH CARE
IT'S ATTORNEY. WE CAN BE
REACHED AT EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT
EIGHT ZERO FOUR. THREE FIVE
THREE SIX OR BY VISITING HEALTH
CONSUMER DOT ORG. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. LET'S NOW MOVE ON
TO- WILLIAM EISENBERG- CHIEF
QUALITY SAFETY OFFICERS UNDER
HEALTH- PROVIDING A PROVIDER
PERSPECTIVES. THIS PROJECT
WELCOME YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH ALL
OF YOU TODAY ABOUT THE
EXPERIENCES THAT PHYSICIANS
INCLUDING MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
HAVE WITH THE CURRENT CODE
NINETEEN TESTING REQUIREMENTS
AND GUIDELINES WELL APPRECIATE
THE GOOD INTENTIONS OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTHCARE IN DEVELOPING THESE
GUIDELINES ITS EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS HAVE CREATED
CONFUSION AMONG HEALTH PLANS
PROVIDERS AND PATIENTS AND IT
HITS THE STATE'S PUBLIC HEALTH
OBJECTIVES AS DEVELOPED BY HHS
AND THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH. AGAINST THE
NHC'S CURRENT REGULATORY
REQUIREMENTS INSTEAD OF MAKING
DIAGNOSTIC TESTING MORE
ACCESSIBLE TO PATIENTS AND THE
PUBLIC IS REGULATIONS ACTUALLY
CREATE BARRIERS BY PROVIDING
GUIDANCE ON HOW HEALTH PLANS
MAY IMPOSE UTILIZATION
MANAGEMENT RESTRICTIONS AND
COST SHARING OBLIGATIONS ONTO
THEIR ENROLLEES. WHO ARE
SEEKING TESTING. YEAH SHE'S
EMERGENCY REGULATE PLACE THE
BURDEN ON HIS. TO TRY WHO SENT
AND NONESSENTIAL WORKERS AND
THEREFORE FOR WHO UTILIZATION
MANAGEMENT PROCEDURES
CARSHARING OTHER REQUIREMENTS
WOULD APPLY. AND IN SUCH NON
VALUE ADDED MINISTRY OF TASKS
ON TO PHYSICIANS CONSUMES
PRECIOUS DIRECT HEALTHCARE TIME
FOR US DOCTORS. HERE BY.
ALTERNATELY DECREASING ACCESS
FOR OTHER PATIENTS ARLENE
ACTUALLY MAKES ANY SENSE.
ESPECIALLY DURING A PANDEMIC-
THE EMERGENCY RADIO HOW. THE
HEALTH QUITE WOULD BE NAY
MISTER. IS OPERATION
IMPRACTICAL GIVEN THE YOU'RE
ROLLING SELDOM IF EVER CONTACT
THEIR HEALTH PLAN TO MAKE AN
APPOINTMENT WITH THEIR POSITION.
IMPOSING THIS UTILIZATION
MANAGEMENT PROCEDURE WHEN
DETERMINING WHETHER OKAY
NINETEEN TEST IS MEDICALLY
NECESSARY FOR ENROLLEES. OFTEN
CAN DELAY THEIR ABILITY TO
DECODE THE NINETEEN TESTING BY
FOUR DAYS AND ULTIMATELY
RECEIVE NECESSARY CARE IF
POSITIVE I IN. THE SIX STATES.
BECAUSE SHARING IS CARING TAX
CODE NINETEEN PARTICULAR FOR
MEN IN. COMMUNITY AND WE KNOW
THAT THEY'VE BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY BY THIS
VIRUS. VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
WHO HAVE CHRONIC CONDITIONS
THAT OFTEN FOR TELEWORK
PROGNOSIS AND COPING ARE THE
PEOPLE THAT I'M TALKING ABOUT.
TO ACHIEVE HEALTH EQUITY
BARRIERS LIKE THIS MUST BE
REMOVED SO THAT EVERYONE IS
AVAILABLE HE COULD BE TESTING
AND TREATMENT OPTIONS. GIVEN
THERE'S I NEED ACCESS TO CODE
NINETEEN DIAGNOSTIC TESTING IN
FACT THEY WERE TESTING DESERVES
PARTICULARLY IN RURAL AND LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES. INDIVIDUAL
SHOULD BE ABLE TO GET THEIR
TESTS WHERE THEY CAN READ THEIR
GEOGRAPHICALLY LOCATED.
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER IT'S AN
IN NETWORK OR OUT OF NETWORK
PROVIDER AND ASK YOU TO WRAP UP
PLEASE THANK YOU. I SHALL- AS
YOU MENTIONED DR HAND IN YOUR
INTRODUCTORY COMMENTS FOR THIS
SESSION THIS PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS A WORLDWIDE PANDEMIC
REQUIRES EXTENSIVE TESTING
EXPANSIVE TRACING AND TREATMENT
OPTIONS. THIS DIAGNOSTIC
TESTING PER CODE NINETEEN
SHOULD BE MEDICALLY NECESSARY
BASIC HEALTHCARE SERVICE FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS AND THE
DECISION TO TEST SUFFICIENT
PROGRESS EXCLUSIVELY BETWEEN
PHYSICIAN AND PATIENT. WITHOUT
THE INTERPOSITION OF THE HEALTH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'M HAPPY
ARTICLE THANK YOU WE WILL BE
TAKING QUESTIONS AT THE END OF
THE PANEL- NEXT WE HAVE DEIDRE
DD KENNEDY PRESIDENT OF
DENNIS'S HEALTH INSURANCE
SERVICES AND CHAIROF THE
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE OF LOS
ANGELES SO SEASON HEALTH
WRITERS. WELCOME THANK YOU SO
MUCH- CHAIRMAN DAN AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR. INCLUDING US.
MONEY TO CANDIDATES PRESENT
BENEFITS HEALTH INSURANCE
SERVICES AND WE REPRESENT OVER
FORTY FIVE LARGE AND SMALL
EMPLOYERS. ACROSS CALIFORNIA
ROUGHLY FIFTEEN HUNDRED
EMPLOYEES. IN A WIDE VARIETY OF
INDUSTRIES- I AM SERVING
CURRENTLY AS THE LEGISLATURE
FOR THE L. A. IS THERE'S THE
ISSUE OF HEALTH UNDERWRITERS
AND HAVE. GONE TO SACRAMENTO
THE LAST TWENTY THREE YEARS TO.
OUR DAY AT THE CAPITOL AND
GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
LEGISLATURE IS FOCUSED ON
BALANCE BILLING. SPECIFICALLY
CODED BALANCE BILLING-
INTERESTINGLY. AND IRONICALLY.
CLOSE TO HOME WITH MYSELF AND
MY FAMILY MY SON WAS
EXHIBITING. SYMPTOMS WE CALL
OUR FAMILY DOCTOR WE WERE
REFERRED TO THE LOCAL HOSPITAL.
THE HOSPITAL DID. THE TEST. AND
IT CAME BACK NEGATIVE AND WE
FOUND. A BILL THAT DID COME TO
US A BALANCE BILL FOR A HUNDRED
DOLLARS IT WAS FOR A- SPECIMEN
HANDLING FEE. I CALLED THE
HOSPITAL'S BILLING OFFICE AND-
WAS PLACED ON HOLD THE CHARGE
WAS DROPPED FROM OUR ACCOUNT.
AND WHEN I CAN QUESTIONS YOU
KNOW WHY I WAS RECEIVING ON A
BILL ON SOMETHING THAT WAS TO
BE COVERED AT A 100% BECAUSE
SYMPTOMS WERE PRESENT. THE
BILLING CLERK COULD NOT GET OFF
THE PHONE FAST ENOUGH WHICH
REALLY. YEAH THE WAY THE CALL
WAS HANDLED. REALLY SHOWED ME
THAT THERE WAS- AWARENESS THAT
THIS WAS AN APPROPRIATE BALANCE
BILL THAT WAS SENT OUT. WE
HAVE- CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
AND THE L. A. S. WE POP TO A
LOT OF OUR- TO SEE THE PRO. OF
BALLOT BILLING AND WE'RE THAT
IT'S NOT AS PRO. AS IT MIGHT BE
I THINK I MAY BE ONE OF THE
ONLY INCIDENTS THAT. HAS COME
UP. IN MY ROLE AS A HEALTH
INSURANCE BROKER REPRESENTING
EMPLOYERS. IT'S OUR JOB TO
GATHER KNOWLEDGE AND TO PROVIDE
GUIDANCE TO EMPLOYERS AND
REALLY DO A GREAT DEAL OF THE
MEETING- FIVE OUTREACH. AND
BRIAN LAND ON THE CURES ACT WAS
PASSED AS WELL AS OTHER ACTS
AND OTHER. FEATURES OF THE
PANDEMIC ROLLED OUT WE REALLY
TOOK A- STRONG ROLE WITH
EMPLOYERS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY UNDERSTOOD WHAT THEIR
BENEFITS- OF. COVERED AND WHAT
THE REQUIREMENTS WERE IN TERMS
OF COVERING FOLKS THAT HAVE
EXPOSURE OR SOMETIMES. TO WRAP
UP. WE DEVELOPED A SERIES OF-
IN FACING. CAMINO WE A GREAT
DEAL OF OPPORTUNITY TO SUPPORT
EMPLOYEES AND WE ALWAYS MAKE IT
CLEAR THAT WHEN THEY HAVE A
ISSUE WITH THE BALANCE BILL
THAT THERE TO TURN TO US AND I
WOULD REALLY KIND OF EXTEND
THIS TO MR SHARK- I WOULD
SUGGEST YOU TURN TO YOUR AGENT
AND ASK THEM TO ASSIST WITH-
CLARIFYING WHY THAT'S GOING ON
AS WELL AS TO ADVOCATE ON YOUR
BEHALF. AND WITH THAT I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE HERE AND THANKS AGAIN THANK
THANK YOU THANK YOU- IT WAS
RUNNING OVER A LITTLE OVER
THERE TWO MINUTES HERE BUT- FOR
IMPORT INFORMATION- TRAINING
GONZALEZ VICE PRESIDENT POLICY
AT CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION WELCOME. TO GET OUT
OF HAND AGAIN MY NAME'S
TRAINING IS ALSO THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION THANK YOU
DOCTOR PAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THE HEARING TODAY AND
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE SOME
PERSPECTIVE FROM OUR HOSPITALS
AND HEALTH SYSTEMS ON THE FRONT
LINES I LIKE TO QUICKLY START
TAKING US BACK TO MARCH AND THE
BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC AT
THE TIME. AS A STATE WE HAD
LIMITED CAPACITY TO DO BECAUSE
THE NINETEEN CASTING AND NOW WE
HAVE SOME BETTER CAPACITY TO DO
MORE TESTING AND MUCH OF THIS
HAS COME DIRECTLY FROM THE
INVESTMENTS MADE BOTH BY THE
STATE AND BY HOSPITALS- SINCE
THE START OF A PANDEMIC BUT
EVEN WITH THESE COLLECTIVE
EFFORTS UNFORTUNATELY THERE ARE
SIMPLY INADEQUATE AT THIS TIME.
BECAUSE GIVEN THAT WE ARE NOT
ABLE TO DO MORE TESTING
CONFLICTING REQUIREMENTS AND
GUIDANCE FROM STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THAT'S CREATED
CONFUSION AMONG PATIENTS AND
PROVIDERS AND GIVEN THE CURRENT
SURGE AN EXPECTED INCREASE IN
DEMAND. FOR TESTING CLARITY IS
NEEDED. SPECIFICALLY PRIORITIES
FOR THE UTILITY OF. TESTINGS OF.
SHOULD BE PROVIDE FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH LOW. THIS CAN BE DONE BY
AN PROVIDING YOU. PROTOCOLS AND
PRIORITY. SUCH AS WHETHER BOTH
SYMPTOMATIC AND ASYMPTOMATIC
INDIVIDUALS SHOULD BE TESTED.
WE WELCOME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK WITH STAKEHOLDERS. TO
DEVELOP A SYSTEM FOR STATE WIDE
PRIVATIZATION BUT MAKES CLEAR
IN THE ORDER IN WHICH THESE
RESOURCES SHOULD BE EXPANDED.
AND ONCE THESE PRIORITIES ARE
ESTABLISHED PAYMENT POLITICIAN
SHOULD BE ALIGNED TO SUPPORT
THEM AND HELP ENSURE ADHERENCE.
LASTLY AND MOST CALIFORNIANS
ARE PROTECTED FROM BALANCE
BILLS IN THE CURRENT STATE LAWS
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA IS A LEADER
IN PROTECTING PATIENTS FROM
UNEXPECTED BILLS. HOWEVER HAS
ALREADY BEEN NOTED GAPS STILL
EXIST FOR PEOPLE COVERED BY
FEDERALLY REGULATED SELF
INSURED PLANS PROVIDED BY
EMPLOYERS AND UNION TRUST FUNDS
AND CERTAIN PPL PLANS. BOTTOM
LINE PATIENTS SHOULD BE
SHIELDED FROM THESE AND
EXPECTED BILLS. HAS COVERED
NINETEEN CONTINUES ITS
RELENTLESS SPREAD IN OUR STATE
AND THE NATION. EVERY
CALIFORNIA AND OTHER RECOVERY
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL IN HUNDREDS
AND THOUSANDS OF FRONT LINE
HEALTH CARE WORKERS ARE WORKING
TIRELESSLY TO CARE FOR THOSE IN
NEED. ON THE OTHER THEIR BEHALF
WE EMPLOYEE TO TAKE STEPS TO
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU THANKS VERY MUCH OF.
THOSE NEXT UP WE HAVE- BILL
BARCELONA EXECUTIVE VICE
PRESIDENT GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
FOR AMERICA'S PHYSICIANS GROUPS
WELCOME. THANK YOU DR PAN.
WELCOME OF THE COMMITTEE- BILL
BARCELONA A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
CALIFORNIA MEMBERS OF AMERICA'S
PHYSICIAN GROUPS WERE
PROFESSIONAL SOCIAIS HAITIAN
OF. PHYSICIAN ORGANIZATIONS
ACROSS THE NATION TO TAKE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR COSTS AND
PATIENT OUTCOMES. IN CALIFORNIA
REMEMBER SERVE EIGHTEEN MILLION
PATIENTS. CAPITATED MEDICAL
GROUPS ARE REQUIRED TO PROVIDE
FREE CODE TESTING WITHOUT CO
PAY. FOR THEIR PATIENCE. MANY
OF SET UP SPECIAL TESTING
CENTERS AFTER THE PANDEMIC
ROSE- IN ADDITION TO THEIR
USUAL. FALL CAMPAIGN TO SUPPLY
ANNUAL FLU SHOTS TO THEIR
PATIENT POPULATIONS. REMEMBER
POSITION ORGANIZATIONS ARE ALSO
REQUIRED TO PAY FOR THIRD PARTY
TESTING COSTS REGARDLESS OF
PRICE THAT MAY BE SUBMITTED. BY
THEIR PATIENTS DURING THE
EMERGENCY. MEDICAL GROUPS HAD
EXISTING CONTRACTUAL
RELATIONSHIPS WITH MAJOR
TESTING LABS AT THE BEGINNING
OF THIS PANDEMIC. AND WHEN THE
TESTING KIDS FIRST BECAME
AVAILABLE LEISURE CHEATED THEIR
EXISTING CONTRACTUAL RATES AND
SAID NO CHARGES FOR ALL CODE
RELATED TASKS THIS IS WHY DO A
MATTER AND NUMBER OF DISPUTES
THAT REMAIN UNRESOLVED AT THIS
TIME REGARDLESS OUR MEDICAL
GROUPS ARE STILL REQUIRED TO
PAY THOSE CHARGES AN IMPORTANT
ASPECT OF TESTING IS THE
AVAILABILITY OF TEST RESULTS TO
THE PATIENT'S REGULAR TREATING
POSITION. COORDINATION OF
TESTING RESULT AVAILABILITY HAS
BEEN DIFFICULT SO FAR DURING
THE PANDEMIC- THERE'S BEEN A
LACK OF DATA ACCESS- THAT CAN
DELAY EFFECTIVE TREATMENT IN
CASES WHERE THE TESTS ARE
REPORTED TO BE POSITIVE. KURT
COBAIN COSTS RUNNING
APPROXIMATELY TWO TO THREE
DOLLARS PER MEMBER PER MONTH.
ACROSS CALIFORNIA IN A
CAPITATED GROUPS. THERE WAITING
ANXIOUSLY TO SEE WHAT THE
EVENTUAL ADDITIONAL PRICING OF
THE CODE BAXEEN. WILL ADD TO
THAT PER MEMBER PER MONTH COST
BURDEN. SOME ORGANIZATIONS ARE
DEVELOPING THEIR OWN TESTING
CAPABILITIES HOWEVER- SUCH AS
THE UC MEDICAL GROUPS AND SOME
OF OUR- NUMBER F. Q. AC SYSTEMS
ACROSS THE STATE. AND THIS
PROVIDES MORE AFFORDABLE AND IN
SOME CASES EVEN MORE RAPID TEST
RESULTS. MESQUITE- UP UP. ABG
HAS BEEN IN. REGULAR
COMMUNICATION WITH DAMAGE SEAT-
WERE CONCERNED ABOUT THE-
HEALTH PLAN LAWSUIT AGAINST THE
EMERGENCY REGULATION. THERE'S
BEEN A HUGE AMOUNT OF
RESTRICTING ON THE MEDICAL
GROUPS THIS TIME BUT THEY
REMAIN- COMMITTED TO PROVIDING
ACCESS TO PATIENTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NOW WE'LL MOVE ON TO
CRISTINA KRISTI FORTY EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR TO CALIFORNIA CLINICAL
LABORATORY ASSOCIATION WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
MY NAME IS CHRISTY FOR NON
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA CLINICAL LABORATORY
ASSOCIATION. HE STILL IS PROUD
TO HAVE AS MEMBERS SEVERAL
LARGE COMMERCIAL LABORATORIES
SUCH AS QUESTION LAB CORE
HOSPITAL LABORATORY SUCH AS
CEDAR SINAI ACADEMIC
LABORATORIES SUCH AS UC DAVIS
AND OTHER INDEPENDENT LABS. IN
THE LABORATORY STATE CLERICAL
ROLE IN THE FIGHT AGAINST
CARBON NINETEEN WE APPRECIATE
THE EMERGENCY REGULATIONS
ISSUED OVER THE SUMMER BUT THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTHCARE. AT INTENDED TO
ALLOW FOR MORE TESTING FOR
CALIFORNIANS HOWEVER WE HAVE A
FEW CONCERNS OUTLINED BELOW.
FIRST WE ARE CONCERNED WITH THE
DEPARTMENT'S POSITION STATED IN
THE GUIDELINES TO HEALTH PLANS
BUT THEY DO NOT HAVE TO COVER
SEROLOGICAL TESTING FOR KOBE
NINETEEN ANTIBODIES. REGARDLESS
OF WHETHER OR NOT BEEN
ATTENDING PROVIDER HAS
DETERMINED THE ANTIBODY TESTING
TO BE MEDICALLY APPROPRIATE FOR
THAT PATIENT. HE'S REALLY
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREES WITH
THIS CONCLUSION THAT ANTIBODY
TESTING IS NOT DIAGNOSTIC IN
PART BECAUSE THE FDA AND CDC
DOES NOT PUBLICLY STATE
ANYWHERE THAT THERE IS NO
DIAGNOSTIC TOOL FOR ANTIBODY
TESTING. RATHER FDA AND CDC
BOTH CURRENTLY STRESSED
ANTIBODY TESTING PLAYS AN
IMPORTANT DIAGNOSTIC ROLE IN
THE FIGHT AGAINST CARBON
NINETEEN IN CERTAIN MEDICALLY
APPROPRIATE. SITUATIONS SECOND
WE HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
TREATMENT OF BILLION FOR
TESTING OF A SYMPTOMATIC THE
CENTRAL WORKERS WITH NO KNOWN
SUSPECT SUSPECTED EXPOSURE TO
CODE NINETEEN. SPECIFICALLY AS
IT RELATES TO THE ESSENTIAL
WORKER DETERMINATION AND THE
CAUTIONARY. IT IS CRITICAL THAT
IT BE MADE CLEAR THAT HEALTH
PLANS ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
DETERMINING THE ESSENTIAL
WORKER STATUS AND NOT THE LADS
SINCE CLINICAL LABS DO NOT
DIRECTLY INTERACT WITH PATIENTS
AND THEREFORE CANNOT GATHER THE
INFORMATION. TO THAT ED HEALTH
PLAN SHOULD NOT BE PERMITTED TO
DENY OR DELAY PAYMENT OR TO
SEEK RECRUITMENT OR OR REQUEST
DOCUMENTATION OF ESSENTIAL
WORKERS FROM THE PROVIDERS.
LIKEWISE HEALTH PLAN SHOULD NOT
BE PERMITTED TO IMPOSE COST
SHARING FOR A SYSTEMATIC
ESSENTIAL WORKERS FOR COVERT
TESTING AGAIN CLINICAL ABSENT
INTERACT WITH THE PATIENTS BUT
ARE FORCED TO TAKE ON SOME OF
THE BILLING COLLECTIONS
RESPONSIBILITY IN ADDITION THIS
COST SHARING MAY PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL DETERRENT. TO
TESTING FOR THESE A SYMPTOMATIC.
ESSENTIAL WORKERS. THE
REGULATION INDICATING CASES OF
DELEGATION THE RESPONSIBLE
REMAINS A HEALTH PLAN UNLESS
THE HEALTH CLINICS PHYSICALLY
DELEGATED THE FINANCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE TESTING.
EASILY IS CONCERNED ABOUT THE
OPERATIONAL CHALLENGES THAT
THIS PRESENTS AS CLINICAL
LABORATORIES WILL NOT KNOW
WHETHER A PARTICULAR PLAN HAS
DELEGATED THAT FINANCIAL RISK
FOR CO TESTING. TO PROTECT
LEARN INDEPENDENT PRACTICE
ASSOCIATION. FINALLY I PA'S
SHOULD BE REQUIRED TO RESPOND
TO THE CLAIMS FOR THE CODE
TESTING INDICATING THAT THE
FINAL FINANCIAL RISK HAS BEEN
DELEGATED OR NOT. IN TO PROVIDE
COMPLETE AND ACCURATE INSURANCE
CLAIMS INFORMATION TO ALLOW THE
BILLING RESPONSIBLE PLAN. THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TESTIFY. THANK YOU. FINALLY
WILL HAVE A NUCLEUS OF ICE
PRESENT LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS FOR
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HEALTH PLANS WELCOME. THANK YOU
MISTER- IN MEMBERS AND
EMPLOYEES IS HERE WITH
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HEALTH PLANS THANKS FOR
INVITING US TO THIS IMPORTANT
HEARING. ON CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH
PLANS TAKE SERIOUSLY THEIR ROLE
IN HELPING CALIFORNIANS THROUGH
THE COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
AND HEALTH PLANS ARE COVERING
TESTING FOR KOBE- PATIENTS WITH
ZERO COPAY. FOR OUT OF POCKET
EXPENSES TO INDIVIDUALS WITH
SYMPTOMS OR TO THOSE THAT HAVE
BEEN EXPOSED- ACCORDING TO
STATE AND FEDERAL REGULATIONS.
THOSE STATE AND FEDERAL
REGULATIONS- ARE CERTAINLY WELL
INTENTIONED IN THE PLANS ARE
DOING THEIR BEST TO MAKE THEM
OPERATIONAL. ON HOWEVER I
MEMBERS ARE WITNESSING SOME
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES- THE
GMAC TESTING REGULATIONS
INTENDED TO REDUCE BARRIERS FOR
ESSENTIAL WORKERS- OUR PLANS
HAVE INDICATED TO CAP- THROUGH
A SURVEY- THAT ABOUT 50% OF
THEIR ENROLLEES IN GROUP PLANS
ARE IN INDUSTRIES THAT WOULD BE
CONSIDERED ESSENTIAL. THIS IS
AT LEAST TWELVE TO THIRTEEN
MILLION CALIFORNIANS THAT'S THE
UNIVERSE OF INDIVIDUALS THAT
WOULD BE SUBJECT TO THE DMZ
REGULATIONS ON HIS MASSIVE.
TRYING TO MAKE A COMPLEX
REGULATION OPERATIONAL FOR
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE ON THIS
CHALLENGING FOR ALL PARTIES-
PROVIDERS AND HEALTH PLANS- IN
CAP MEMBERS HAVE IDENTIFIED TWO
SIGNIFICANT AREAS OF CONCERN.
ONE A DRAMATIC INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF OUT OF NETWORK CLAIMS
FOR TESTING AND SHE WAS
SIGNIFICANT VARIABILITY IN
TESTING COST BETWEEN IN
NETWORKING OUT OF NETWORK
PROVIDERS AND LABS- THERE ARE
SEVERAL REASONS WHY THIS
PROBLEM COULD BE OCCURRING-
INCLUDING- AND UNINTENTIONAL
MISCONCEPTION ON THE PART OF
PRIVATE AND PUBLIC EMPLOYERS.
ACCORDING TO A NATIONAL SURVEY
OF HEALTH PLANS NEARLY A
QUARTER OF CODE NINETEEN TESTS
ARE NOW ADMINISTERED OUT OF
NETWORK. FEES OUT OF NETWORK
COSTS FAR EXCEED IN NETWORK
COSTS. MEDICAID PAYMENT RATES
FOR A TEST IS ABOUT A HUNDRED
DOLLARS V. AVERAGE COMMERCIAL
RATE IS ABOUT A HUNDRED THIRTY
DOLLARS. CAD MEMBERS ARE
RECEIVED CLAIMS FOR NOT FROM
NON CONTRACTED PROVIDERS SOME
LABS THAT ARE MORE THAN THREE
TIMES A MEDICARE PAYMENT RATE.
I'M IN SOME- EVEN MORE
EXCESSIVE- OUR PLANS ARE SEEN
MAXIMUM CHARGES HIGH IS
FOURTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
ALTHOUGH WE BELIEVE THIS IS-
CERTAINLY AN ANOMALY HOWEVER
MANY PLANS OF REPORTED MAXIMUM
BILL CHARGES OF AROUND SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND ACCURATE.
SURE AT NEVER CROSSES PROBLEM
THE ENTIRE SYSTEM WE HAVE
CONCERNS THAT HIS ACTIVITY IN
COST PRESSURE COULD OUT AS YOU
MATTER PREMIUMS BEING COLLECTED
BY THE PLANTS- LOOK FORTY
EXPLORING WAYS OF THE
DEPARTMENTS- AND STATE ARE NOT
RESOLVING THIS ISSUE. THANK YOU
OKAY. THANK YOU I APPRECIATE
ALL THE DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES
WE ARE OVER HERE TODAY I KNOWTHAT SO. EACH PERSON HAD A
FAIRLY BRIEF PERIOD OF TIME.
NOW LIKE TO OPEN UP TO
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS FOR. OUR
REACTOR PANEL. RIGHT I DON'T
SEE ANY CANS UP THE MOMENTS-
OKAY. ALL RIGHT WELL ACTUALLY
THEN I WILL ASK A FEW QUESTIONS
HERE AND AGAIN I WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE WHO WHO PRESENTED- SO
I AIN'T I UNDERSTAND THAT-
THERE YOU KNOW SEVERAL OF YOU
HAVE TALKED ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES OF- I WAS TRYING TO
DETERMINE HIS AN ESSENTIAL
WORKER OR NOT- WELL MAYBE I'LL
START OFF MAYBE WITH THAT MR
LEE IT WITH NICK PLEASE US AT
THE- TELFORD SAYS HE HEALTH
PLANS SO YOU HEARD. PROBABLY
FROM SOME OF THE OTHER PANEL
MEMBERS SIR CHALLENGING YOUR
LAB YOU'RE NOT INTERFACING WITH
THE PERSON AND EVEN MEDICAL
GROUP AT CETERA- WHAT'S THE
PERSPECTIVE OF FIRST OF ALL THE
CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH PLANS ON-
THE DVT GAINS WITH THESE TEARS
AND TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW
YOU DETERMINE WHO. SUCH A
WORKER NINE HOW DO WE PREVENT
PEOPLE WHO MAYBE ESSENTIAL WORK
HOW DOES THE PLAN SORTED OUT.
YEAH SO IT'S SO THAT WE DON'T
END UP HAVING PEOPLE GETTING
NOTICES ALL THE TIME HAVING. TO
JUSTIFY WHETHER DURING SUCH A
WORKER NOT. YEAH YOU KNOW I.
WISH IMAGINED SOLUTION TO THAT.
QUESTION MISTER CHAIR- I WILL
SAY THAT WE ARE VERY
SYMPATHETIC TO THIS ISSUE- BE.
A SYMPTOMATIC SYMPTOMATIC
DISTINCTION DOES PROVE TO BE A
PRACTICAL AND OPERATIONAL
PROBLEMS FOR THE PROVIDERS. I'M
IN FOR THE PLANS. FOR PURPOSES
OF COMPLYING WITH THE
REGULATIONS- YOU KNOW. YEAH WE
HAVE TALKED OUR MEMBERS ABOUT
THIS- WE DO KNOW THAT- MANY OF
THE PLANS ARE PROVIDING A NON
MANDATORY GUIDANCE TO THEIR
PROVIDERS- ON THEIR PREFERRED
CODING- IN THE SITUATION SO
THAT THINGS CAN BE PROCESS
MORE. ARE CORRECTLYAND
EFFICIENTLY- HOWEVER THE CODING
IN AN OF ITSELF TO DETERMINE
WHETHER SOMEONE IS IT IS AN
ESSENTIAL WORKER- IS VERY
UNCLEAR- AT THIS MOMENT AND YOU
KNOW I. PERSONALLY AM NOT. OF
THE NUTS AND BOLTS PERSON THAT
TO TELL YOU EXACTLY WHERE WHERE
WHERE THE SPECIFIC PROBLEM-
EXISTS. BUT I'M NOT NOT ALL
LABORATORIES ARE USING THE SAME
PRACTICES ARE CODES- WITH
RESPECT TO ESSENTIAL WORKERS.
ON IT CAN BE HARD FOR BOTH-
WILL BE HARD FOR THE HEALTH
PLANS. TO IT TO MAKE THAT.
DETERMINATION- SO WE ARE SO. TO
IT WE'RE TRYING TO WORK WITH
OUR PROVIDERS- IN IN PROVIDING
AS MUCH GUIDANCE AS WE CAN ON
THE ISSUE BUT WE DO RECOGNIZE
IT AS A PROBLEM. OKAY AND THEN-
ACTUALLY- FOR KELSEY WALDRON-
OVER AT BAY AREA LEGAL AID- YOU
DITCH YOUR ABLE TO SHARE SOME
STORIES ABOUT PEOPLE WHO GUIDE-
DOES COST SHARE TO BALANCE
BILLED FOR THEIR TESTS- IN IN
YOUR WORK- WHAT SEEMS TO BE.
THE MAIN I GUESS TRIGGER FOR
THIS TO HAPPEN SO WE'VE HEARD A
PRESENTATION ABOUT THE FEDERAL
RULES ARE WE HAVE OUR STATE
RULES. WHERE WHERE DO PEOPLE
TEND TO GET TRIPPED UP- AND DAY
TO DAY YOU MADE SOME MENTION
THAT. PERHAPS SOMEONE ACTUALLY
KNEW THAT THEY WERE DOING THE
RIGHT THING BUT CAN YOU PERHAPS
ELABORATE A BIT THANK YOU TO
YOU GIVE US TWO STORIES I KNOW
IF YOU HAVE ANY BROADER DATA-
FROM- YOU. FROM EITHER YOUR
ORGANIZATION OR OTHER. LEGAL
AID ORGANIZATIONS IN TERMS OF
WHERE. THE AND WE DID YOU%
MISTER SHARP STORIES WELLS
WHERE WHERE WHERE DOES IT SEEM
LIKE THE CALL GETS DROPPED OR-
IS THIS- WHERE'S THE GAP. THERE
IN TERMS OF PEOPLE GETTING
BILLS. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THAT QUESTIONS. I THINK ONE OF
THE BIGGEST GAPS IS THAT
CONSUMERS FEEL VERY CONFUSED
RIGHT NOW- BECAUSE THEY SEE
HEADLINES THAT SAY. COME BEEN
TESTING SHOULD BE COVERED IT
WILL ALWAYS BE COVERED AND-
THERE'S JUST A GENERAL. FRIENDS
IN THE COMMUNITY BACK COVER
TESTING WILL BE COVERED- AND
CONSUMERS JUST DON'T HAVE THE
MORE NUANCED DETAILS LIKE WE'VE
BEEN DISCUSSING TODAY LIKE. IF
YOU'RE AN ESSENTIAL WORKER WILL
BE COVERED OR IF YOU HAVE
SYMPTOMS IT WILL BE COVERED AND
SO- AND A LOT OF CONSUMERS
DON'T WHEN THEY CALL. MOST
CONSUMERS WHO COSTS DON'T KNOW
WHO THEIR HEALTH PLAN
REGULATORS DON'T KNOW IF THEY
HAVE A FEDERAL REGULATOR PLAN
OR CALIFORNIA REGULATED PLAN
AND SO CONSUMERS REALLY ARE IN
THE DARK HERE. ABOUT WHAT IS
COVERED AND WHAT IS NOT AND- I
THINK THERE IS A LACK OF
COMMUNICATION. IT COULD BE
FIXED BY THE PLANS
COMMUNICATING MORE CLEARLY WITH
THEIR INSURED ABOUT WHAT IS
COVERED- OR- I'M I'M NOT
TOTALLY SURE HOW TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION BUT IT DOES SEEM LIKE-
PEOPLE JUST ARE UNCLEAR WHAT IT
WILL BE COVERED AND ONE IT
WON'T BE ON PEOPLE ARE FRANKLY
SCARED WHEN THEY HARD CODED
SYMPTOMS AND THEY WANT TO GET
IT PASSED- AND SO. THEY'RE NOT
EXACTLY THINKING ABOUT WILL MY
INSURANCE COVER THIS RATE
THEY'RE THINKING ABOUT THEIR
HEALTH AND THEY'RE AFRAID- AND
UNFORTUNATELY I DON'T HAVE ANY
BROADER DATA ABOUT- THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA MY ORGANIZATION
SERVES. SEVEN COUNTIES
THROUGHOUT- THE BAY AREA AND-
I'VE SHARED WITH YOU ALL THE
THREE CLIENTS STORIES THAT MY
OFFICE- HAS HAD INCLUDING
MISTER SHARP. ALAMEDA COUNTY-
AND SO. THAT'S REALLY ALL THE
DATA THAT WE HAVE UNFORTUNATELY
SHARE. THANK YOU ACTUALLY I
DON'T KNOW IF DOCTOR JACOBSON
STILL ON FROM CDPH CHANNELS ON
THE PREVIOUS PANEL ARE YOU
STILL ON OR NOT. I AM STILL ON
BOTH EXCELLENT THANK YOU SO I
DID WANT TO ASK YOU IS A PUBLIC
HEALTH PROFESSIONAL- WE HEARD
THAT YOU KNOW THAT- SOME OF
THIS IS CONFUSING BUT- BUT AT
THE SAME TIME. SHOULD THE
MESSAGE BE OUT TO THE PUBLIC IF
YOU'RE CONCERNED THAT YOU
SHOULD GO AHEAD AND GET A TEST
DO WE WANT TO CHANGE THAT
MESSAGE FROM A PUBLIC HEALTH
STANDPOINT I KNOW WE'RE CARE
DELVING INTO THE INS AND OUTS
OF THE REGULATIONS. IN TERMS
BUT- WHEN YOU GET A MESSAGE OUT
TO THE PUBLIC IN ORDER FOR THE
TO GET A BUS PUBLIC HEALTH
RESPONSE. WHAT KIND OF YOU KNOW
DO WE WANT TO GO AND SAID WELL
ACTUALLY SHOULD GO AND CHECK TO
SEE IF IT'S COVERED BY
INSURANCE ONLINE AND OF COURSE
A LOT OF PEOPLE DROPPED OUT
BECAUSE NOT JUST BECAUSE THEY
FOUND OUT IT ISN'T BUT PERHAPS
JUST BECAUSE THEY WILL GO
THROUGH THE BOTHER OF THAT OR
DO YOU THINK IT MIGHT NOT BE
COVERED. SO FROM A PUBLIC
HEALTH STANDPOINT YOU NEED TO
SPEAK TO WHAT SHOULD BE THE
PUBLIC HEALTH MESSAGE. OUT
THERE ABOUT TESTING. AND AND
THEN OF COURSE- EXPECTATIONS IN
TERMS OF- IMAGE. SHOULD BE
TRYING TO COVER EVERYBODY SO
THAT. WE DON'T HAVE PEOPLE
PULLING THEMSELVES BACK FROM.
TESTING SO. ADDICTED BECAUSE
THAT'S OUR CAME OUT OF THE- THE
COMMENTS FROM THE LEGAL AID
COMMUNITY. SO SENATE HEARING
POLICY OWNERS. YEAH I WANNA
MAKE SURE I UNDERSTAND YOUR
QUESTION SHOULD WE BE
ENCOURAGING FOLKS TO GET TESTED-
IS THAT BAY YES GOOD QUESTION
THE CRUX OF THE QUESTION IS
THAT SHOULD WE TELL IT SHOULD
BE FROM A PUBLIC HEALTH
STANDPOINT SURE WE TELL PEOPLE
YOU KNOW IF YOU'RE CONCERNED
GET TESTED RIGHT IF YOU THINK
YOU MIGHT BE EXPOSED YOU HAVE
SYMPTOMS OR EVEN IF YOU'RE A
SYMPTOMATIC BUT SOMETHING
HAPPENED YOU'RE WORRIED YOU GO
AHEAD TESTING OR SHOULD WE TELL
PEOPLE WELL ACTUALLY. IF YOU'RE
WORRIED. ALL YOUR HEALTH PLAN
FIRST. BEFORE YOU GET TESTED
GREAT BECAUSE THAT BECOMES A
BARRIER TO PEOPLE GETTING
TESTED AND YOU MAY HAVE PEOPLE
WHO ACTUALLY SHOULD BE TESTED
WHO ARE. NOW ITSELF. I AM I I'M
JUST INTERESTED FROM A PUBLIC
HEALTH STANDPOINT SO OBVIOUSLY
ALL THIS OTHER STUFF HAPPENS
THE BACKGROUND WE WANT PEOPLE
TO GET SURPRISE BILLS OR- GET
CAUGHT WITH BILLS. BUT FROM A
STRICTLY PUBLIC HEALTH
STANDPOINT WHAT SHOULD BE THE
MESSAGE VIA. TO THE PUBLIC IN
TERMS OF TESTING. YEAH SO
STRICTLY PUBLIC HEALTH BUT IT
SHOULD BE TO GO GET TESTED IF
YOU HAVE CONCERNS THAT YOU'VE
BEEN EXPOSED IF YOUR SYMPTOMS
THAT YOU. THINK MIGHT BE
COVERED SYMPTOMS. WE DEFINITELY
WANT YOU TO GET TESTED. OKAY
SO- ALL RIGHT NORTH I
APPRECIATE THAT BECAUSE I THINK
SOME OF THAT AND I REALIZE THAT
YOU KNOW WE OBVIOUSLY IT GETS
COMPLICATED AND THIS INVOLVES
MONEY AND- I DO HEAR FROM. FROM
MANY PEOPLE ABOUT. NOW HE'S
SUPPOSED TO PAY FOR IT NOW GETS
BOUNCED BETWEEN THIS
ORGANIZATION THAT ORGANIZATION
BUT- ALSO BUT I THINK
ULTIMATELY WE WANT TO TRY TO
GET TO A PLACE WHERE PEOPLE CAN
DO WHAT WE WANT THEM TO DO.
RIGHT AND I THINK I CERTAINLY
WHAT I UNDERSTAND THAT I THINK
THAT- THE- OUR REGULATORY
AGENCIES ARE. HAVE BEEN. TO
LEANING THAT DIRECTION IN
GENERAL BUT- BUT LET ME GO
AHEAD JUST A FOLLOW UP QUESTION
PERHAPS WITH THAT DR EISENBERG-
SO. ON THE FRONT LINES FOR-
PHYSICIANS ARE DEREK SINCE WITH
WITH SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT
COMES UP ABOUT COVERAGE- WHAT
SHOULD PHYSICIANS BE TELLING
THEIR PATIENTS WHEN IT COMES TO
GETTING TESTED SO THEY CALL
THEIR DOCTOR ARE TO SAID DOC
WHAT SHOULD I DO- WHAT KIND OF
MESSAGE SHOULD. DOCTORS BE
SENDING TELLING PATIENTS IN
TERMS OF GETTING TESTED CHECK
YOUR HEALTH PLAN FIRST BE SURE
COVERAGE OR- WELL YOU KNOW NOT
DEPEND I THINK YOU'VE POINTED
TO THE CONUNDRUM THAT I TRIED
TO- EXPLAIN THEIR WHICH IS.
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SO OUR ANSWER
TO THE QUESTION YOU POSED TO-
DOCTOR JACOBSON IS YES GET
TESTED IF YOU THINK YOU'VE BEEN
EXPOSED IF YOU THINK THAT THERE
IS A POSSIBILITY THAT YOU COULD
BE CARRYING THIS VIRUS. YOU
SHOULD BE TESTED. AND YOU KNOW
IT'S- LIKE ANYTHING ELSE IN
MEDICINE. WE DON'T WANT TO HAVE
TO. INTERPOSE SOMEBODY OUTSIDE
OF THE DOCTOR PATIENT
RELATIONSHIP TO DETERMINE
WHETHER THIS IS AN ELIGIBLE
PATIENT IT IS SOMEBODY THAT
SHOULD GO THROUGH THIS ROUTE
SHOULD GO THROUGH A DIFFERENT
ROUTE SHOULD CHECK WITH THEIR
HEALTH PLAN FIRST AND FIND OUT
IF THEY SHOULD WAIT TWO DAYS
FOR A CALL BACK FOR FOUR DAYS
FOR A CALL BACK. IF WE
DETERMINED AS THEIR POSITION
THEY NEED TO TEST IT SHOULD
YEAH THE PASSENGER
EXPEDITIOUSLY AS POSSIBLE SO
THAT WE CAN EIGHT BEGIN THE
PROCESS OF TREATMENT AND
BEATING IN THE PROCESS OF
CONTRACTORS SO LET ME JUST
QUICK FOLLOW UP ON THAT NOW- I
THINK QUITE HEARD EARLIER WAS
THAT IF THE DOCTOR SAYS YOU GET
TESTS FOR MOST. PART IT TENDS
TO GET COVERED. BUT WHAT ABOUT.
PEOPLE WHO DON'T. BOTHER GOING
TO THE DOCTOR AND SAID JAHNS
WORRIED AND YEAH WE HAVE
TESTING CENTERS SO FORTH AND
I'M JUST GOING TO GO GET THE
TEST AND THEY SAY HERE WORDS
INSURANCE INFORMATION AND THEY
GET A BILL. ON THE BILL GET
SENT OFF TO THE INSURANCE
COMPANY- SO DO YOU DO YOU HAVE
A- THOUGHT ABOUT THAT. ASPECT
OF THINGS SHOULD PEOPLE BE
GOING TO THE DOCTOR FIRST. WELL
I GUESS I ALWAYS. IF ANY
PATIENT ANY PERSON CALIFORNIA
HAS A HEALTH CONCERN. THEIR
FIRST CALL IS LIKELY TO BE
ADDED TO THEIR POSITION WE
DON'T WE DON'T CURRENTLY
EXPECT. IF PEOPLE WILL CALL
THEIR HEALTH PLAN FIRST HE
FIGURE OUT WHETHER THEY'RE IN A
SITUATION WHERE THEY SHOULD
CONTACT YOUR DOCTOR- IT'S- SORT
OF FOR A IT'S NOT LIKE I'M-
CONTEMPLATING HAVING. COSMETIC
SURGERY DONE AND I WANT TO BE
SURE THAT- SOME OF THEIR ALL OF
THEIR PORTION AND IT MIGHT BE
PAID FOR BY MY PLAN FIRST. I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT HAVING AN
INFECTIOUS DISEASE THAT HAS
RESULTED IN A WORLDWIDE
PANDEMIC. THEREFORE IT JUST
SEEMS THAT THE DIRECT FIRST
CONTACT SHOULD BE WITH THE
HEALTHCARE PROVIDER. IN OKAY
THANK YOU. AND THEN- THE
GONZALEZ IN WE HEARD STORY OF
MR. SOME OF THAT WILL. PLAN BUT
THEY GOT A BILL FROM THE
HOSPITAL AND IF YOU WERE ON FOR
THAT STORY- WHAT GUIDANCE IS
THE HOSPITALIZATION GIVING ITS
MEMBERS REGARDING PEOPLE WHO
ARE SHOWING UP- PERHAPS JUST TO
GET A TEST AND- GETS REDIRECTED
OR- IN TERMS OF- IN. TERMS OF
BILLING FOR OTHER SERVICES
ASSOCIATED. THANK YOU SO MUCH-
YES SO THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION'S BEEN IN CONSTANT
CONTACT WITH OUR MEMBERS
REGARDING THE EVER CHANGING-
LAWS AT THE FEDERAL AND STATE
LEVEL AS A RESPONSE THIS
PANDEMIC AND SO- THERE ARE WE
HAVE A WEBPAGE DEDICATED TO
GRANT THE CORONA VIRUSES
SPECIFICALLY FOR OUR MEMBERS TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
VARIOUS GUIDANCE DOCUMENTS IS
FROM THE FEDERAL AND STATE
GOVERNMENTS FOR THOSE COMING
FROM CD PH OR- THE FEDERAL
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES- WHETHER THAT'S ISSUES
COMING FROM THE DMH C. AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE.
REGARDING A PAYMENT AND I'M
SORRY THE RAIN COVERAGE EXCUSE
ME RELATED TO THAT- AND OUT
LIKE A LAMB AS WELL AS WANTING
TO ENSURE THAT CLAIMS ARE PAID
PROPERLY MISTAKES DO HAPPEN-
AND IF WE WANT TO HEAR ABOUT
THAT KNOW ABOUT THAT. AND THAT
COMES WITH THE COMPLEXITY
UNFORTUNATELY AS GLASS AND THE
SKILLS ASK KELSEY AS WE GET
NOTED THE COMPLEXITY AND
DEALING WITH EVERYONE'S
DIFFERENT HEALTH INSURANCE
PLANS- AND RESTORING WHEN
THINGS GO WRONG- BUT AS I THINK
TESTIFIED ALREADY PREVIOUSLY BY
A AB THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE AND YOU SEE WE HAVE
BEEN SEEING ANY WIDESPREAD
ISSUES- BUT CONTINUE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH OUR
MEMBERS AND- AND PATIENTS AS
THEY A. B. C. ARE POTENTIALLY
RECEIVE THESE KINDS OF BILLS.
OKAY THANK YOU AND FINALLY-
JUST ONE LAST QUESTION NICK
LOUISA'S- YOU DID MENTION THAT
YOU'RE HAVING A HIGH PERCENTAGE
OF OUT OF NETWORK- BILLS FOR
TESTING- CAN YOU PERHAPS TOUCH
I MEAN SO WE'RE TELLING PEOPLE
TO GO TO- YOU KNOW PLACES LIKE
VERILY OR- OTHER TYPES OF
PLACES TO GET TESTING TESTING
IS NOT ALWAYS WIDE DEPENDING
WHERE YOU ARE IN THE STATE
TESTING COULD BE MORE OR LESS
WIDELY AVAILABLE SO- SO CAN YOU
MAYBE TOUCH ON- WHERE. DOES
TESTS I MEAN THEIR ACT ARE YOU
CONCERNED THAT PEOPLE ARE
TRYING TO GET PEOPLE TO TEST
UNNECESSARILY. OR IS IT JUST
THAT PEOPLE I EARNED IT. I MEAN
I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO OF THAT
YOU HAVE IN TERMS OF TESTING IS
WITH THAT. HAVE A START TO AS
WELL BUT- AND ANSWER HEAR WHAT
YOU SAID ABOUT- ISSUES ABOUT TO
TAKE PROVIDER. CHARGING LARGE
AMOUNTS OF MONEY PARTICULAR
TASKS AND I THINK A- BUT CAN
YOU JUST PERHAPS SPEAK TO. ME
TO ME MAY NOT BE NECESSARY
UNEXPECTED AND SPECIALLY DURING
A PANDEMIC THAT YOU'D HAVE A
LARGE NUMBER OF POTENTIAL QUOTE
UNQUOTE OUT OF NETWORK TESTS
BECAUSE- PEOPLE ARE BASICALLY
JUST. TRYING TO FIND A- THE
TESTING. CENTER THAT'S
CONVENIENT TO THEM THAT MAY NOT
NECESSARILY HAVE. HAD A
CONTRACTOR DEMANDED SET UP
RECENTLY SO I DON'T KNOW HOW
MUCH OF IT IS. LIKE THESE
COMMUNITY TESTING SITES OR
OTHER TYPES OF THINGS THAT YOU
FIND YOURSELF. THAT YOUR
MEMBERS FIND YOURSELF PAYING
FOR. PIANO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- YOU KNOW THE BEST NUMBER
I HAVE IS- SOMETHING THAT COMES
FROM OUR PARTNER TREAT A HEN.
VIA NATIONAL TRADE FOR THE
HEALTH PLANS- YOU'D DID A
SURVEY NATIONALLY AND- THEY
INDICATED THAT. AMID THE
MAJORITY ABOUT 58% OF OUT OF
NETWORK TESTS. WITH PRICES THAT
EXCEED AVERAGE COST. BOND
WORRIED MINISTERED. IN
STANDALONE LABORATORIES- SO
THAT'S ONE YOU KNOW DEFINITIVE
NUMBER- THAT THAT I HAVE SEEN-
I THINK FOR A LOT OF THIS. OUT
OF NETWORK ACTIVITY- IS COMING
FROM IS- YOU KNOW IN TALKING TO
OUR MEMBERS AND ACCORDING TO
THEM IT APPEARS THAT MANY
EMPLOYERS WHETHER PUBLIC OR
PRIVATE- HAVE EITHER TAKEN TO
GMAC IS REGULATIONS OR
OTHERWISE TO MEAN THAT. THEY
COULD CONTRACT WITH THEIR OWN
TESTING VENDORS- AND ENROLLEES
COULD GO TO ANY OUT OF NETWORK
TESTING VENDOR- IN. IS A
MISINTERPRETATION- OF WHAT IS
INTENDED BY THE DEMAND SEE
REGULATIONS ON AND IS LEADING
TO A HIGH NUMBER OF OUT OF
NETWORK- BILLS BEING FORWARDED
TO THE PLANS. NOW YOU KNOW THE
PLANS ARE GENERALLY PAYING
THESE CLAIMS BUT- YOU KNOW AS
NOTED IN PREVIOUS TESTIMONY-
YOU KNOW BOTH STATE AND FEDERAL
REGULATIONS YOU KNOW DO LIMIT
THE REIMBURSEMENT RATES- THAT
THE OUT OF NETWORK PROVIDERS
ARE GOING TO RECEIVE- FROM THE
PLANTS WHICH EITHER- YOU KNOW
NEGOTIATED RATE A CASH PRICE-
THAT MUST BE LISTED ON THE
TESTING VENDORS WEBSITE. AND
YOU KNOW OUR PLANS DO SAY THAT
SOME OF THESE- TESTING
FACILITIES ARE NOT ACTUALLY
LISTING- THAT CASH PRICE ON
THEIR WEBSITE- WHICH YOU KNOW
TO MY KNOWLEDGE DOES NOT HAVE
YOU KNOW ANY PARAMETERS
ASSOCIATED WITH IT- AT LEAST
THAT'S MY UNDERSTANDING- YOU
KNOW OR- YOU KNOW THE PLAINTIFF
USUAL AND CUSTOMARY. CUSTOMARY
SO- SO THAT IS KIND WHAT WE'RE
WE'RE SO WHAT WE SUSPECT IS
LEADING A LOT OF THE OF NOW-
ACTIVE. THANK YOU. VERY MUCH
THANK ALL THE OF THIS FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY AND FOR ANSWERING-
THE QUESTIONS- PROPOSED I DON'T
SEE ANY OTHER HANDS UP FROM
OTHER MEMBERS OKAY- AND- AGAIN
I THINK THIS CAN BE VERY
HELPFUL AS WE- MOVE FORWARD-
PARTICULARLY- WHEN WE LOOK AT
WHAT WE NEED TO DO- THOSE-
COVERED CONTINUES
UNFORTUNATELY- WE'RE GONNA MOVE
NOW ON TO THE- NEXT SECTION OF
OUR A HEARING WHICH- WAS-
ACTUALLY ORIGINALLY GOING TO
FOCUS MAINLY ON PAYMENT FOR
TREATMENT- BUT- WITH. THE
ANNOUNCEMENT OF- AT LEAST TWO I
GUESS NOW THREE POTENTIAL
UNKNOWNS BEEN APPROVED YET-
VACCINES- THAT HAVE SHOWN
PROMISING RESULTS- WE ALSO WANT
TO CUT. TOUCH ON- COVERAGE FOR-
KODJAK SCENES ONCE- WE HAVE
APPROVAL AND THEN WAITS FOR
DISTRIBUTION AND THEN OF COURSE
ALSO WITH TREATMENT OF- COVE IT
AS WELL- IT OF WHAT ARE THE-
FEDERAL AND- REGULATIONS-
RECOGNIZING THE CODE IS A
CONTAGIOUS DISEASE- SO WE JUST
TALKED ABOUT TESTING BUT- WHEN
PEOPLE AREN'T ABLE TO GET.
THEIR ORDER NOT ABLE TO GET
THAT PREVENTION LIKE A VACCINE-
THEY CONTINUE TO BE A RISK TO
THE GENERAL POPULATION IN TERMS
OF BE ABLE TO PASS ON. THIS A
VERY SERIOUS VIRUS SO WE'RE
GOING TO BEGIN THIS DISCUSSION
AGAIN- ONE OF WELCOME BACK
SABRINA- CORE COLLETTE HE'S
GOING TO TALK ABOUT- WHAT IS
THE CURRENT FEDERAL. GUIDANCE
REGULATIONS ON COVERAGE NOW OF-
TREATMENT AND FLEET THAT ACT-
COVER NINETEEN VACCINES AS WELL
THANK YOU. WELCOME WELCOME BACK-
GOOD TO MEET- OKAY SO MISTER MY
SCREEN AGAIN- HOPEFULLY YOU ALL
CAN SEE THAT- SO. ON TO VACCINE
I SO WHAT HOPEFULLY GOOD NEWS
AND SORT OF INCOME AS COVERAGE
FOR TEST IS- THANKS AT LEAST IN
LARGE PART TO THE AFFORDABLE
ACT LET'S HOPE THAT COVERAGE
FOR VACCINES IS A LITTLE
SIMPLER- SO UNDER THE ACA
INSURERS MUST COVER AND WE'VE
COST SHARING OR VACCINES THAT
ARE RECOMMENDED BY TE CDC'S
ADVISORY COMMITTEE ON
IMMUNIZATION PRACTICES FOR
ROUTINE USE. UNDER THE ACA
PLANS AND INSURERS WERE GIVEN
UP TO TWO YEARS YOU IMPLEMENT
THAT RECOMMENDATION INTO THEIR
BENEFIT. WITH THE CARRIERS ARE
IN. OF THIS YEAR WHY- SO THAT
TIME FROM YEARS TO FIFTEEN GATE.
THE ONCE IT'S SET ISSUES IT'S
WRECKED. PLAN NOW HAVE DAYS. TO
IMPLEMENT THE COVER MANDATE- WE
ALSO SOME WILL THEY CAN JUST
LAST MONTH- THEY CLARIFY. THAT
NEEDS AN ANSWER HAVE TO. NOT ON
A MINUTE. OF THE- I'M THAT
THOSE OUT OF NOT FOR HAVE TO
RISK A- PAYMENTS IT DOESN'T OF
REASONABLE IT SAYS THAT ON.
RATE WE BE REASON ACCORDING TO
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. AND
PROVIDE IN THE BACKS PROGRAM
WHO FROM BALLOT BILLING OUT.
EASTON'S MAXINE'S. I'M RULES
ALL SAY THAT ACT DOES OF THE
BACK IS ROOMS YOU WILL NOT BE
REQUIRED IS OKAY. I'M.
RECOMMENDATION THERE'S NO TIME
LIMIT ON HOW LONG IT MIGHT TAKE
A STEP THE ISSUE THE
RECOMMENDATION AFTER. GOOGLE
THE- I SUSPECT WILL BE UNDER
PRESSURE TO A QUICK RECOMMEND
BY THERE'S NO. THE OTHER ISSUE
OF COURSE IS NOT AC COMPLIANT
PLANS ARE EXACT SO HEALTH CARE
SHARING MINISTRIES. GRANDFATHER
SIXTEEN DOWN PRODUCTS FOR TERM
ARE ALL EXEMPT FROM THIS
REQUIREMENT. THIRD I'M PLANS
ARE STILL ALLOW TO ARMS
EXERCISE REASONABLE MAN. WE NOW
OF UP TO THREE MANY. WITHOUT
THERE'S NO REQUIRE IN FEDERAL
LAW FOR PLANS TO COME ALL THREE
BACK BY ALL FREE AND- SO IT'S
HARD THAT THEY MAY JUST TO COME
ONE NOT ENOUGH. ALSO THAT I OF
NETWORK PROTECTION APPLY ONLY
TO THE PUBLIC HEALTH. WHICH IS
STATED THIS CURRENTLY SUPPOSED
AND I'M. TWENTY YOU THAT ALL OF
THE IS BOY. IF THE AFFORDABLE
CARE IS OVERTURNED IN
CALIFORNIA TEXAS WHICH IS.
BEFORE SUPREME. I'M WE SEEM
LIMIT STATE. ON THAT COVER TO
OUR EARLIER THIS AND FOR-
COVERAGE SINCE WITH THE LAW
WHICH IS- WAIVER OF. FOR A
FUTURE. I WOULD I LOOK FORWARD
TO QUESTION. REGARDING
CORPORATE NINETEEN VACCINATIONS
ON JUST THE ACCU ECHO WHAT
PROFESSOR CORLETTE SAID. UNDER
CURRENT FEDERAL AND STATE LAW
HEALTH PLANS MUST COVER.
WITHOUT COST SHARING ALL
PREVENTIVE SERVICES WITHIN A OR
B. RATING FROM THE UNITED
STATES PREVENTIVE BIRTH THE
PASSPORT. AND IMMUNIZATIONS
RECOMMENDED BY THE PDP EITHER%
BINARY COMMITTEE ON
COMMUNICATION PRACTICES. WE
THEREFORE DURING THE CALL THE
NINETEEN VACCINE WILL MEET THE
STANDARD IN WHICH CASE THE PLAN
WILL HAVE TO COVER KOBE
NINETEEN VACCINATIONS WITHOUT
COST SHARING. ADDITIONALLY
UNDER CURRENT LAW HEALTH PLANS
MUST ASSUME THE FINANCIAL RISK
FOR ADULT AND CHILDHOOD
IMMUNIZATION. OF THE PLAN WILL
NOT BE ABLE TO PASS THESE COSTS
ON TO THE PROVIDER. UNLIKE THE
PROVIDER IN THE PLAN HAVE THE
TYPICALLY AGREED OTHERWISE. AND
THEN FINALLY REGARDING HOBART
NINETEEN TREATMENT- PLAN WILL
COVER ALL MEDICALY NECESSARY
SERVICES AND TREATMENT. I
CURRENT LAW ALLOWS PLANS TO
CHARGE COST SHARING AS ALLOWED
BY THE LOWLY IN THE CONTRACT
WITH THE PLAN AND THE FULL TO
TRUE FOR KOBE NINETEEN
TREATMENT AND SERVICES. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NOW LET'S MOVE
ON TO BRUCE- HìNH SEE WITH-
DEPARTMENT INSURANCE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR INNOCENT
RIGHT HAND HOME SABRINA ALREADY
TOLD YOU THE FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE
REGARDING- COLONEL VIRUS
VACCINATION ONLY APPLY TO. NON
GRANDFATHERED ACA COMPLIANT
COVERAGE NOW THE INSURANCE CODE
PREVENTIVE CARE STATUTES. WHICH
IS A SEXUAL ONE A ONE ONE TWO
POINT TWO OF THE INSURANCE CODE
SIMILARLY ONLY APPLIES TO NON
GROUND FROM THE COVERAGE. OF
INSURERS ARE REQUIRED TO COVER
PREVENTIVE CARE WITHOUT PATIENT
COST SHARING OF. ACQUIRED IN
NETWORK. THAT WOULD INCLUDE THE
VACCINATIONS- HOWEVER THE
TIMELINE CURRENTLY BAKED IN LAW
STATUE. AS POSSIBLE YOU KNOW TO
IS THE- OBLIGATE TO PROVIDE
THIS PREVENTATIVE CARE ONLY
COMES INTO EFFECT ONE YEAR
AFTER THE FEDERAL ADVISORY
COMMITTEE ON IMMUNIZATION
PRACTICES WHICH MET THIS
MORNING- MAKES ITS
RECOMMENDATION SO THE STATE
LEGISLATURE MAY WISH TO
CONSIDER REQUIRING THAT
GRANDFATHER COVERAGE ALSO
EXPLICITLY COVERED THE KOBE
BAXEEN WITHOUT COST SHARING.
AND REQUIRED INSURERS COVER THE
BAXEEN FIFTEEN BUSINESS DAYS
AFTER THE RECOMMENDATION OF THE
PREVENTIVE SERVICE NOW WITH
REGARD TO TREATMENT OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE
BELIEVES THAT ALL INSURERS TO
COVER COVERT NINETEEN
TREATMENT. HOWEVER TO THE
EXTENT THAT SUCH TREATMENT MAY
NOT BE COVERED WOULD BE DUE TO
THE FACT THAT THE INSURANCE
CODE DOES NOT REQUIRE THE
INSURANCE COVER BASIC HEALTH
CARE SERVICES OUT FAR OUTSIDE
OF THE NORM GRANDFATHERED.
INDIVIDUAL AND SMALL GROUP. SO
DOES APPLY TO FATHERED. DOESN'T
APPLY A LARGE GROUP AGAIN THE
STATE LEGISLATURE MAY WISH TO
ADOPT REQUIRING A LAW REQUIRING
ALL HEALTH INSURERS TO COVER
BASIC HEALTH CARE SERVICES IN
ALL MARKET SEGMENTS INDIVIDUAL
SMALL AND LARGE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THE NEXT WE HAVE
TRICIA- BLUE BLUE BLUE CHURCH I
HAVE A MISPRONOUNCE YOUR NAME-
FROM THE DIPPY DIRECTOR FROM
DIVERSITY PARAMUS OFFICE OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH THE- WELCOME. THANK YOU
YES GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
NUMBERS I'M TRICIA BLOCKER
BLOCKERS THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS OFFICE
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH I APPRECIATE YOUR
INTEREST IN THE STATE'S WORK IN
PREPARING FOR A CARBON TAX SEEN
I'VE BEEN ASKED TO PROVIDE AN
UPDATE ON THE VACCINE
DISTRIBUTION PLANNING LIKE THE
STATE'S OVERALL RESPONSE TO
CURB IT NINETEEN WERE USING
DATA AND SCIENCE TO GUIDE OUR
PLANNING AND IMPLEMENTATION. OF
THE VACCINE PROGRAM. AS THERE'S
NO IT A VACCINE YET
CALIFORNIA'S PLANNING PROCESS
INCLUDES INSURING THE CURVE IN
NINETEEN VACCINE MIXTAPE THE
REQUIREMENTS. ENSURING THE
VACCINE IS DISTRIBUTED AND
MINISTRY EQUITABLY AND ENSURING
TRANSPARENCY FREE BRINGING
COMMUNITY STAKEHOLDERS FROM THE
OUTSET. GOVERNOR NYESOM
RECENTLY NAMED A SCIENTIFIC
SAFETY REVIEW WORKGROUP
COMPRISED OF PHYSICIANS
SCIENTISTS WITH EXPERTISE IN
IMMUNIZATION AND PUBLIC HEALTH.
SHORTLY FOLLOWING THE
ANNOUNCEMENT WASHINGTON OREGON
AND NEVADA JOINED OUR EFFORT.
THIS GROUP IS CURRENTLY STAYING
ABREAST OF THE VACCINE TRIALS
REVIEWING THE EVIDENCE OF
SAFETY AND EFFICACY AND
PROVIDING RECOMMENDATIONS.
GOVERNOR SOME ALSO ANNOUNCED
THE DRAFTING GUIDELINES WORK
GROUP THIS GROUP IS CHARGED
WITH DEVELOPING THE ALLOCATION
FRAMEWORK FOR WHEN VACCINES ARE
IN LIMITED SUPPLY. AND SOON IN
UPCOMING ANNOUNCEMENTOF THE
COMMUNITY VACCINE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE WHICH WILL PROVIDE
INPUT AND FEEDBACK FOR ONGOING
PLANNING EFFORTS TO ENSURE
EQUITABLE VACCINE ALLOCATION
DISTRIBUTION AND ADMINISTRATION.
READ TO WORK DILIGENTLY TO
PREPARE FOR THE EVENTUAL
DISTRIBUTION AND ADMINISTRATION
OF VACCINES IN CALIFORNIA. THIS
INVOLVES PLANNING WITH
CALIFORNIA'S LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS MULTIPLE
STATE AGENCIES COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. WE'RE LEVERAGING
CALIFORNIA'S WELL ESTABLISHED
EXISTING IMMUNIZATION FRAMEWORK
AND EMERGENCY RESPONSE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO COORDINATE
OUR EFFORTS BETWEEN STATE LOCAL
AND TRIBAL AUTHORITIES. LOCAL
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENTS WILL
BOTH ADMINISTER VACCINES AS
WELL AS ALLOCATE TO ASSIST IN
THEIR JURISDICTIONS. TO
PROVIDERS. THE ROLE OF
DIFFERENT PARTNERS SUCH AS
HOSPITAL SYSTEMS HEALTH CLINICS
PHARMACIES AND OTHERS IN THE
VACCINE DISTRIBUTION WILL
DEPEND ON THE VACCINE SUPPLY
AND THE STAGE OF THE VACCINE
DISTRIBUTION PLAN. THEY'LL BE
SEVERAL PHASES OF THIS PLAN.
FIRST IS THE PRE BAXEEN WHERE
WE ARE RIGHT NOW IN THE
PLANNING PHASE- AND THEN THE
FIRST PHASE OF THE LIMITED
DOSES THAT ARE WILL BE
AVAILABLE AND WHEN THE
ALLOCATION FRAMEWORK WILL BE
UTILIZED. AND THEN FINALLY
SUFFICIENT WIDESPREAD SUPPLY
INDUCES FOR THE ENTIRE
POPULATION. THE VACCINATION
COMMUNICATION PLAN IS FOCUSED
ON ENSURING EVERYONE LIVING IN
CALIFORNIA RECEIVED TIMELY
ACCURATE AND ACTIONABLE
INFORMATION ABOUT. THE CARBON
NINETEEN VACCINATION PROGRAMS
AT EACH STAGE OF IMPLEMENTATION.
IN ADDITION THE CDPH SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERTS WILL WORK
CLOSELY WITH FEDERAL AND LOCAL
PARTNERS TO CREATE THE
APPROPRIATE GUIDANCE NEEDED AND
WILL DISSEMINATE IT THROUGH ALL
COMMUNICATION CHANNELS FOR
PROVIDERS AND PUBLIC ALIKE.
RIGHT NOW CITY PH IS IN THE
EARLY PROCESS USE OF RECRUITING
AND ENROLLING COBIT NINETEEN
VACCINE PROVIDERS INCLUDES
COLLABORATION WITH OUR LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENT'S
IMMUNIZATION COALITIONS AND
STATEWIDE ORGANIZATIONS AND
ASSOCIATIONS. WORK IS UNDER WAY
TO ENSURE THE INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY INFRASTRUCTURE IS
ROBUST AND WILL MEET THE
EXTENSIVE IN THE REGION. IRONS
FROM CDC SOME OF THOSE
REQUIREMENTS INCLUDE PROVIDERS
NEEDING TO REPORT ADMINISTERED
DOSES WITHIN TWENTY FOUR HOURS
INTO THOSE DATA SYSTEMS. OUR
DEVELOPING STATE RIGHT BACK UP
PLANS FOR ULTRA LOW COLD
STORAGE AND DRY ICE TO SUPPORT
THE STORAGE REQUIREMENTS FOR AT
LEAST ONE OF THE LEADING
VACCINES. AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
INTEREST IN THE WORK TO DATE ON
THE VACCINE DISTRIBUTION PLAN.
WE STILL HAVE A NUMBER OF
UNKNOWNS ABOUT TIMING QUANTITY
AND EFFICACY OF THE EVENTUAL
BAXEEN AND THERE'S SEVERAL
VACCINES AT VARIOUS STAGES IN
DEVELOPMENT AND TESTING. WE
CONTINUE TO WORK DILIGENTLY TO
PREPARE AND BE READY TO
DISTRIBUTE THE VACCINE AS SOON
AS IT'S AVAILABLE THANK YOU AND
I LOOK FORWARD O YOUR
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
TRICIA BLOCKER- LET'S NOW MOVE
ON TO QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS.
ARE THERE QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS. K. I DON'T SEE ANY
HANDS UP AT THE MOMENT. RIGHT
SO I DO HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS-
ACTUALLY FACT MY FIRST
QUESTION- PREPS FOR. SABRINA
CORLETTE- SO IT'S BEEN
SUGGESTED FOR EXAMPLE WE HAVE
GRANDFATHER PLANS WE HAVE SOME
OTHER TYPES OF PLANTS WHO MAY
NOT HAVE TO FOLLOW SOME OF THE
ACA REQUIREMENTS IF THE STATE
IMPLEMENTED OUR OWN LAWS.
THROUGH FOR THESE REQUIREMENTS-
DESSERTS SUBJECT US TO
ADDITIONAL STATE COSTS BECAUSE
THAT FALLS AFOUL OF ESSENTIAL
BENEFITS SIR. DO OF YOU HAD ANY
COMMENT- THOUGHTS ABOUT IT'S
THE STATE TRIED TO MOVE ON ITS
OWN TO TRY TO PULL SOME OF
THESE PLANS IN. INTO A AT AND
FUTURE LEGISLATION. THE
REQUIRED COVERAGE. NO NO I'M NO
IF THE STATE WERE TO MANDATE
THAT FOR EXAMPLE- GRANDFATHER
PLANS OR- AFTER SHARING
MINISTRIES ARE OTHER PLANTS
THAT ARE DON'T HAVE TO COMPLY
WITH THE ACA. ARE TO COVER THE
VACCINE THERE'S NO- THERE'S NO
REQUIREMENT FOR THE STATE TO
DEFRAY ANY ADDITIONAL COSTS.
OKAY THANK YOU FOR THAT SIR
HELLO- AND THEN AS- FOR- I
GUESS CENTER REEM AND- BRUCE
HINES THE- IN TERMS OF- BUT-
WHAT ARE WHAT ARE YOUR
RESPECTIVE- AGENCIES PLANS FOR
ISSUING GUIDANCE. TO THE TO THE
HEALTH PLANS YOU REGULATE- SO
FOR EXAMPLE SAID. WE DON'T KNOW
WE COULD END UP HAVING TWO OR
THREE- VACCINES OUT THERE IT'S
POSSIBLE THAT ONE VACCINE MAY
BE MORE AVAILABLE IN ONE AREA
ANOTHER AND ANOTHER AREA GIVEN
JUST EITHER NUMBERS OR
DISTRIBUTION. FRANKLY I THINK
IN THE BEGINNING IT'S GONNA BE
AN ISSUE OF HAVING ENOUGH
VACCINE FOR ALL THE PEOPLE WHO
ACTUALLY WANT IT. VERSUS
GETTING- PEOPLE- OTHER PEOPLE
VACCINATED OR A THIRD OF THE
PARTICULAR GUIDANCE- THAT- BOTH
TEAMMATES CNC EYES THINKING
ABOUT IN TERMS OF- FOR HEALTH
PLANS IN TERMS OF THE COVERAGE
OF- THE- VACCINE. THE POTENTIAL.
AGAIN NONE OF HAVE BEEN
APPROVED YET BY STA BUT AT THAT
AT THE POINT WHICH THIS HAPPENS.
ASSEMBLY WILL BEGIN WITH THEIR
REMOTE READYMADE C. YES AND WE
ARE BETTER THAN ISSUE THAT WE
ARE LOOKING AND INTO NOW AND-
DEVELOPING A RECOMMENDATIONS
AND GUIDANCE FOR HOW WE WOULD
WHAT WE WOULD REQUIRE OF THE
PLANT BUT WE EXPECT THE PLANS
TO DO- IF THERE HOPEFULLY ARE
MULTIPLE. VACCINES AVAILABLE
HOW WE WOULD EXPECT THEM TO
COVER THOSE. OKAY AND SO MANY
MORE SPECIFICALLY AND WAS
MENTIONED AND IT'S POSSIBLE
THAT WE CAN HAVE DIFFERENT
VACCINES AT DIFFERENT PRICE
POINTS BUT THEN ALSO DIFFERENT
AVAILABILITY DEPENDING ON
GEOGRAPHY AND AMOUNT OF
MANUFACTURING OF THE CDPH WILL
HAVE PRIORITIES BASED ON.
CERTAIN POPULATION GROUPS ARE
CERTAIN WORKERS GROUPS AND SO
FORTH BUT THAT IS FOR EXAMPLE
IS- THOUGHT THAT- THAT- THAT
SALE THE ACTUALLY REQUIRED TO
COVER WIDER VACCINES ACTUALLY
AVAILABLE IN THE AREA VERSUS
SAYING WON'T COVER THIS ONE AND
IF IT HAPPENS NOT TO BE
AVAILABLE IN YOUR AREA EVEN
THOUGH THE OTHER VACCINE IS.
YOU GOTTA WAIT- TOO BAD THERE-
I DON'T O I DON'T KNOW IF I
DID THAT THAT. PARTICULAR ISSUE
BEING CONSIDERED. IT CERTAINLY
HAS SOMETHING THAT WE WHAT
THINKING ABOUT AND TALKING
ABOUT- OBVIOUSLY OUR PRIORITY
IS TO. ENABLE AS MANY PEOPLE AS
POSSIBLE TO GET VACCINATIONS
THE QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. THAT
IS DEFINITELY SOMETHING THAT IS
ON OUR RADAR- YOU KNOW I. AGAIN
WE'RE WORKING WE'RE STILL
LOOKING INTO AND DETERMINING
HOW WE'RE WHAT. WE'RE GOING TO
PROVIDE THE PLAN BUT I WOULD
ANTICIPATE- WHERE NOT
CONTEMPLATE THAT UP COULD. DID
NOT COVER FOR A VACCINE THAT'S
AVAILABLE. AT THAT. AND TIME-
BECAUSE THEY HAVE MOBILE
MECHANICS THE DOT BACK THE THAT
IS AND THEN IS THE IN THE AREA
AND NOW I MEAN ARE. IS THAT
PLANS WOULD COVER- WIDELY
ACTING FOR THEIR THE LATE BY
AND HOW MUCH COORDINATION AND
I'M GONNA DEAL I IS TO. HOW
MUCH. IS TO GO ON WITH. I OF
THAT- AT LEAST I REALIZE YOU
YOU REGULATE SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
DROP THEIR HEALTH PLANS BUT
THERE'S SOMETHING DIFFERENT
ANIMALS. TERMS OF THEIR
CHARACTERISTICS- HOW MUCH
COORDINATION IS THERE WITH THE-
I GOING ON TO BE SURE WE SEND A-
SIMPLER MESSAGE OUT TO EVERYONE
ABOUT WHAT'S COVERED WHAT ISN'T.
CHAU AREN'T HELPING I TALKED TO
BRUCE FAIRLY FREQUENTLY
BRITAIN. I THINK WE TALKED
MAYBE YESTERDAY. NO WE TRY TO
COORDINATE- BUT WILL END IN
THESE ISSUES THAT CUTS BOTH ARE
REGULATED PLANNED THEN THE CD I
REGULATED INSURERS OKAY AND-
BRUCE HEINZ G. DO YOU WANT TO
ANSWER THE QUESTION GOING THE
OTHER WAY. SIX CERTAINLY- AND
I'M ALWAYS HAPPY TO SPEAK WITH
SERRA THE- IN TERMS OF THE
VACCINE. AVAILABILITY AND
PAYMENT. THE FEDERAL- FOR YOUR
ROOM FINAL RULE THAT WAS
RELEASED ON. STATES THAT THE
TAXI ITSELF IS PAID FOR BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. AND IF. ARE
D. VACCINATE. WHATEVER ENTITIES
THAT ON CAN- NOT BALANCED BILL
AND KNOCKED- CHARGED OKAY SO
THERE'S NO COST TO THE PERSON
WHO RECEIVES THAT ON INCLUDING
UNINSURED PERSON AND IN TERMS
OF THE AVAILABILITY OF THE
DIFFERENT VACCINES AND THEIR
DISTRIBUTION ARM SO WE'RE GOING
TO BE LOOKING TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH-
AND THE GOVERNOR'S- VEXING TASK
FORCE THAT THE IMAGE C. AS A
MEMBER OF. TO OUR PROVIDE A
STRUCTURAL GUIDANCE FOR HOW
THAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN I
PERSONALLY CANNOT IMAGINE A
SITUATION WHERE AN INSURER IS
GOING TO ONLY COVER A
PARTICULAR VACCINE SINCE THE
COST OF THE. VACCINE IS PAID
FOR BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
WELL AT THE A TEACHER'S I KNOW
A LITTLE WITH THE NOT TO ABOUT
PAYING FOR THE- BUT IF YOU'RE A
PHYSICIAN OR OTHER PROVIDER YOU
MAY ACT YOU KNOW YOU HAVE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH- DEPENDING ON
WHETHER YEARS DOING ANY OF THE
STORIES YOU'RE NOT
ADMINISTRATION COSTS AND SO
FORTH- IS THERE ANY- SO. IT'S
GREAT THAT THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S PAYING FOR THE
VACCINE ITSELF FOR EXAMPLE IT
HAPPENS IN THE VACCINES FOR
CHILDREN PROGRAM MEDIC CAL AND
WE'RE TALKING MY SHIRTS
COMMERCIAL INSURANCE HERE- WHAT
DO YOU SEE IS GOING TO HAPPEN
REGARDS TO- I GUESS
EXISTENTIALLY ADMINISTRATION
CAUGHT MINISTRY OF COSTS
RELATED TO ACTUALLY DELIVERING
THE VACCINE YOU NEED. NURSE
TIME OR SOME HELP SPECIAL TIME
THAT YOU NEED OTHER SUPPLIES AS
WELL- THERE SO SEATED TO
MINISTER TO VACCINATION- DTC
ANY ISSUES IN THAT REGARD AND
BEING SURE IF WE HAVE- FOR
PREPAYMENT AND THEN SOME OF
THESE. PLACES THEY'RE
DELIVERING THE VACCINE
DEPENDING WHERE IT'S COMING
FROM- MAY NOT SHOW UP IN ALL
THE DOCTORS OFFICES ESPECIALLY
IN THE FIZER VACCINE IT'S STILL
NEGATIVE SEVENTY SO YOU MAY
HAVE OUT OF NETWORK PROVIDERS.
WHO ARE THE ONES ADMINISTERING
THE VACCINE- SO THERE IS A
SEWER. TURKEY JUST MAYBE SPEAK
TO SOME OF THE ISSUES. THAT YOU
ARE CONSIDERING REGARDING-
VACCINE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
COST OF THAT BEYOND JUST THE
COST OF. VACCINE ITSELF. AGAIN
THE- LAW IS ACTUALLY VERY ABOUT-
NETWORKS. HOME ISN'T RELEVANT
IN TERMS THE- EXPOSURE RUFFIAN.
PERSON TO ANY COSTS. MMHM I AM
VERY CONFIDENT THAT THE
INSURERS ARE GOING TO COVER THE
ADMINISTRATION COSTS. HOME AND
HE SORT OF ANCILLARY COSTS
AROUND N THE- MINISTRATION OF
THE VACCINE HAS REQUIRED BY
FEDERAL LAW AND THAT WOULD BE
OUR EXPECTATION. OKAY AND-
SERINE ANY ANYTHING TO ADD TO
THAT FROM DIMITRI. WELL I WOULD
I WOULD ECHO EVERYTHING THAT-
RETURN DATE JUST THAT WAY OUR
EXPECTATION THAT THE PLANT WILL
COVER THE MINISTRATION- IN THE
RETAIL STORAGE- ALL THAT THEY
ASSOCIATE COSTS WITH DELIVERING
THAT ACTING TOO IN EARLY. OKAY
THEN THE OTHER QUESTION I HAD
FOR ACTUALLY BOTH OF YOU THAT-
NOT ASSOCIATED WITH THE VACCINE
BUT JUST TREATMENT IN GENERAL-
SO- I BELIEVE RIGHT NOW AND
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG YOU
KNOW IF YOU HAVE KOPEN NINETEEN
AND YOU NEED TREATMENT- IT'S-
IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE COVERED-
BUT WHAT HAPPENS IF SHE IS
THERE SOME SOME X. WELL LET'S
SEE WHAT HAPPENS IF. THE IF
SOMEONE SAYS WELL GOD WORKPLACE.
YOU KNOW YOU'RE YOU'RE IN A
HIGH RISK WORKPLACES HERE.
WORKER WILL HIDE IT IS A- AND
GET A PLAN AND ACTUALLY WELL
THERE'S A STATE REGULATED OUT
OF YOU CAN COMMENT ON THAT'S A
ITSELF. A SELF INSURED PLAN
TODAY SAY WELL ACTUALLY THAT'S
A WORKERS COMP CLAIM. IT'S NOT
YOU KNOW IT'S NOT SO WE WANT TO
YOU KNOWGO GO SOMEWHERE ELSE
TO GET. YOUR REIMBURSEMENT FOR
THIS YOU GOT AT WORK- SO CAN
YOU SPEAK TO. TO THAT ISSUE FOR
BOTH STATE REGULATED PLANS AND
IF YOU'RE ABLE TO COMMENT. ARE
YOU HAVE KNOWLEDGE ABOUT WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN IN A NON STATE
REGULATED PLANNED- IN ITS IT'S-
THE PLAN SAYS DETERMINED THAT
THEY THOUGHT THAT IT WAS
ACTUALLY WORKPLACE. EXPOSURE OR
INFECTION. AND THEN DECIDED TO
SAY WELL ACTUALLY THAT'S NOT
OUR THAT'S A- THAT'S A WORKERS
COMP CLAIM AND NOT A- A. HEALTH
COVERAGE ISSUE. YOUR AYE. THE
END OF THE TERROR I CAN I CAN I
JUMP IN HERE FOR. WE WERE NEAR
THAT SITUATION AS SIMILAR TO-
IF SOMEONE CONTRACTED ANOTHER
TYPE OF COMMUNICABLE DISEASE
POTENTIALLY AT THE WORK SITE OR
IF THEY WERE INJURED AT THE
WORK SITE- IT COULD BE HUMANE
THAT THERE IT COULD BE A
WORKERS COMP CLAIM BUT OUR
EXPECTATION WOULD BE BAD. THE
IF BE ENROLLING A PRESENTED AT
THE HOSPITAL- OR AT THEIR
PROVIDERS FOR TREATMENT
REPUBLIC NINETEEN. THE
TREATMENT WOULD BE RENDERED AND
THEN IT WOULD BE BETWEEN THE
HEALTH PLAN- AND THE WORKERS
COMPENSATION KERRIER
POTENTIALLY Q. FIGURE OUT WHO
WHO IS RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT
THAT BILL RATHER THAN- ALLOWING
THE PLAN TO. TURN THE ENROLLEE
AWAY POTENTIALLY- THAT WOULD
NOT BE OUR EXPECTATION ARE
EXPECTATION WOULD BE THAT THE
EMBOLI WOULD RECEIVE THE CARE
THEY NEED AND THEN BEING THAT
WAY AND THEN THE WORKERS
COMPENSATION CARE WOULD. FIGURE
IT OUT ON THE BACK AND OKAY
THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT THAT'S
WHAT IT'S FOR THE INSURERS AND
DRUG CALLED KERRIER. TO
RESOLVED AFTER MAJOR OKAY AND
SO THIS YEAR. OKAY THANK YOU
AND SO JUST SO THAT WILL BE
SURE THAT THE WORKER WHO'S ALSO
THE PATIENTS IT DESN'T GET
CAUGHT UP IN THE MIDDLE WITH
EITHER COSTS ANY SOME SOME FOR
COST SHARING ASPECT OR- OTHER
TYPES OF- ISSUES THAT MAY ARISE
WHEN YOU HAVE TO. INSURERS
BATTLING AUS TO WHO WHO'S IS IT
POSSIBLE FOR THE BILL. THAT'S
RIGHT AND THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS
NOW FOR ANY WORKPLACE INJURY
THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE GONE TO
YOUR PROVIDER. THERE'S A LITTLE
QUESTIONNAIRE YOU FILL OUT
SOMETIMES AFTERWARDS. WITH
YOUR- EXPLANATION OF BENEFITS
YOUR WERE YOU INJURED AT WORK
THIS IS THIS IS NOT A NEW OR
UNUSUAL PHENOMENON AND THERE'S
A SYSTEM FOR. OKAY THANK YOU-
AND ACTUALLY- FOR TRICIA A
BLOCKER FROM THE FARM PUBLIC
HEALTH APPRECIATE YOUR
PRESENTATION ABOUT WHAT. HE-
FANS ARE HER- TO GET VACCINES
OUT TO THE PUBLIC- SO WHAT-
FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE AND CDPH
WHERE SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
WE SHOULD DO IS A STATE IN
REGARDS TO OUR HEALTH PLANS
INSURERS THAT WOULD HELP
FACILITATE- DATE BASICALLY
PEOPLE WELL I GUESS
DISTRIBUTION AND AT AND THEN IT
WILL ACCESS TO AND AN
ACCEPTANCE OF THE VACCINE AT
LEAST RELATED TO ANY EXPENSES
THAT MAY BE ASSOCIATED ORDERED
ADDITIONAL THINGS WE SHOULD BE
LOOKING AT AS THE LEGISLATURE
TO HELP- FOR NEXT YEAR. TO HELP
FACILITATE YOUR WORK AND-
GETTING- IN VACCINES OUT TO THE
GENERAL PUBLIC. I THANK YOU FOR
THAT QUESTION- I THINK- AS WITH
THE ENTIRE VACCINATION PROGRAMS
THAT COMMUNICATION PIECE IS
GOING TO BE ONE OF THE- THE
MOST CHALLENGING SO I THINK
THERE'S- IF THERE'S ANYTHING.
ZERO READ THE TO HELP US WITH
THAT THE COMMUNICATION NODES-
YOU KNOW THIS. YOU CAN GET A
VACCINE AND- WILL NOT COST YOU
ANYTHING OR OR AND THIS IS WHY.
SO I THINK THAT WOULD PROBABLY
BE THE MOST HELPFUL. OKAY ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY
PREOPERATIVE LASTING TOO RIGHT
WE WANT TO BE SURE PEOPLE. KNOW
THAT THEY CAN GET THEY CAN GET
IT AND- WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
THROWING UP FINANCIAL BARRIERS
FOR THEM. OKAY ARE THERE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I STILL DON'T SEE ANY
HANDS UP. CASING NINE I WANT TO
THANK ALL OF OUR PANELISTS- THE
FOR THIS PRESENTATION AND WE
WILL NOW HAVE MOVE ON TO OUR-
IT'S A REACTOR PANEL SO- SO
AGAIN THANK YOU AGAIN TO
SABRINA CORLETTE- WITH- GEORGE
TOWN- MCCOURT SCHOOL PUBLIC
POLICY SERINA TEAMMATE SEE.
BRUCE HìNH Z. AS PART OF
SHARON'S AND TRICIA BLOOD
BLOCKER OF RED TO DEPART PUBLIC
HEALTH. IF YOU ARE ABLE TO HANG
IN THERE THERE MAY BE I DON'T
KNOW IF THERE WILL OPEN UP ANY
QUESTIONS MIGHT WILL COME BACK
TO YOU ON IN TERMS OF THE-
AFTER THE REACTOR PANEL BUT
AGAIN I WANT THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. SO LET'S
MOVE ON TO OUR- REACTOR PANEL-
WE CANCEL. NEWS LET'S SEE ONE
TWO THREE FOUR WE HAVE FOR A
RESPONSE SO WE HAVE. DR DAVID
THE BAR SKI- CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER AT UC DAVIS- HEALTH AND
VICE CHANCELLOR AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT HE WILL ALSO
HAVE WITH HIM. DR TIMOTHY
ALBERTSON- TO HELP ANSWER
QUESTIONS BUT NOT ACTUALLY
TESTIFYING ON THE PNEL WHO IS
ALSO- IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
INTERNAL MEDICINE AND PRINCIPAL
INVESTIGATOR FOR THE FINES ARE
COPA NINETEEN VACCINE TRIAL UC
DAVIS HEALTH. SINCE ALSO
SPEAKING ON A PANEL IS- TRINA
GONZALEZ- WILL BE COMING BACK
FOR REFUSING HOSPITALS
ASSOCIATION JEFF HORTON- SENIOR
VICE PRESIDENT OF PRODUCT
EMPLOYER COMMERCIAL POLICY
AMERICA'S HEALTH INSURANCE
PLANS AND FINALLY DIANE
DOUGLAS- WITH HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA. SO LET'S GO AHEAD
BEGIN WITH DOCTOR OF OUR SKI
WELCOME. THANK RICHARD- CHERRY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TO YOU. ABOUT THE
COVERAGE AND DELIVERY OF THE
CODE NINETEEN BACKSEAT- I'M
SPEAKING AS A TRUSTEE OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION-
AND ALONG WITH BEING THE
PHYSICIAN CEO UC DAVIS HEALTH
HOWEVER. MY VIEW SHOULD NOT BE
CONSTRUED AS REPRESENTING A
SPECIAL POSITION OF YOU SEE
HEALTH- I DID BRING ALONG DR
ALBERTSON WHO'S THE SMARTEST
GUY I KNOW WHO KNOWS MORE ABOUT
VACCINES AND I EVER WILL IN
CASE THAT HAPPENS TO BE A-
SPECIFIC TECHNICAL QUESTION.
ABOUT SINCE HE HAS HAD PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE IN ADMINISTERING THE
PFIZER VACCINES. I'M OVER THE
LAST WEEKS NEWS ABOUT THE
ADVOCACY OF THE COPA NINETEEN
VACCINE TRIALS HAVE BEEN VERY
PROMISING AS A- DOCTOR AND
MENTIONED- THERE ARE TWO MORE
ON THE HORIZON. AND THIS WILL
GIVE US HOPE AS WE NAVIGATE
CODE CITY. AND REDOUBLE OUR
EFFORTS AT REMAINING SAFE OVER
THIS HOLIDAY SEASON. AND WHILE
THIS NEWS IS ENCOURAGING THERE
ARE STILL MANY ISSUES THAT WE
NEED TO ADDRESS. BEFORE ANY
VACCINE CAN BE DELIVERED
EFFECTIVELY AND EFFICIENTLY.
INITIALLY IN ADDITION TO THE
PLANNING NEEDED TO DEVELOP
ALLOCATION FRAMEWORKS TO
COORDINATE VACCINE DISTRIBUTION
AND ADMINISTRATION. AND
COMMUNICATE ITS BENEFITS TO THE
PUBLIC. INSURANCE COVERAGE FOR
THE VACCINE IS A CRITICAL
COMPONENT OF OUR PREPARATION
I'M VERY GLAD TO HEAR EVERYBODY
SEEMS TO BE IN AGREEMENT. THAT
THIS IS ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL.
THERE'S NO QUESTION. THAT
PAYERS BOTH PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
MUST PROVIDE COVERAGE OF THE
KOBE BAXEEN FREE OF PATIENT
COST SHARING. TO ENSURE THERE
ARE NO SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS TO
VACCINATION. THIS IS ESPECIALLY
TRUE WITHIN LOW INCOME AND
MINORITY COMMUNITIES HIT
HARDEST BY THE VIRUS. ANY
SUGGESTION OF A CO PAY FOR COST
SHARING. WOULD BE A TREMENDOUS
BARRIERS TO EQUITABLE AND
ETHICAL DISTRIBUTION. FEDERAL
GUIDE TO DATE IS ALSO ALIGNED
WITH THIS PRINCIPLE SO WE'RE
NOT. SAYING ANYTHING THAT ISN'T
GONNA PRETTY WELL GENERALLY
ACCEPTED ACROSS THE UNITED
STATES. IN ORDER TO ENROLL AS A
PROVIDER FOR VACCINE
ADMINISTRATION THE PROVIDER
MUST AGREE TO ADMINISTER THE
VACCINE REGARDLESS OF THE
RECIPIENT'S ABILITY TO PAY. AND
PROVIDERS WILL BE PROHIBITED
FROM CHARGING CONSUMERS THREE
MINISTRATION TAXI SO TEAMS ARE
ALL THE SAME PAGE ON THIS. THE
FEDERAL GUIDANCE SEEKS TO MAKE
CLEAR THAT PLANS INSURERS WILL
COVER THE COST OF
ADMINISTRATION I THINK THAT'S
ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL WE WANT
EVERY SINGLE PERSON. WORKING AS
HARD AS HUMANLY POSSIBLE TO GET
THE VACCINE OUT. AND TO SEE
THAT DUTY AS ONE THAT THAT IS
NOT A- CASE OF CHARITY BUT A
CASE OF DEDICATION THAT IS
REASONABLY REVERSES IT
DISPLACES OTHER CARE THAT MIGHT
BE PROVIDED. IN OPPOSITIONS
OFFICE AND ASK YOU TO WRAP UP.
SHORT WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO
MAKE SURE IS THAT THE STATE
ENTITIES CONSULT WITH A
PHYSICIAN EXPERTS. HAPPILY
PROVIDED BY THE CMA AND OTHERS
AS TRUSTED PARTNERS IN
DEVELOPING GUIDELINES AND
DISTRIBUTION PLANS. WE WANT TO
REALLY MAKE SURE. THAT THE END
PROCESS IS NOT ONE OF THE STATE
LEVEL MANDATE THAT TAKES AWAY
THE FLEXIBILITY THAT POSITIONS
NEED. IN ORDER TO DECIDE WHICH
PATIENTS. NEED FIRST BACKTRACKS
SCENE AND HOW TO MAKE THOSE
DECISIONS WELL WE WELCOME
GUIDELINES WE ASK THAT THE
PHYSICIAN LEADERSHIP OF THE
STATE INCLUDED IN THAT PLANNING
AND IN THOSE GUIDELINES
DECISIONS. TO BE A GUIDELINE
AND NOT A MANDATE THAT WILL GET
US WHERE WE NEED TO BE. AND
MAKE SURE THAT EVERY SINGLE
PATIENT GETS THE VACCINE IN THE
RIGHT ORDER AND ARE IN A MANNER
THAT IS CONSISTENT WITH THE
BEST MEDICAL CARE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU TO THE
RESCUE LET'S NOW MOVE TO TRINA
GONZALES VICE PRESIDENT POLICY
AT CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION WELCOME BACK. BUT
YOU'RE GONNA TO PAN- AGAIN AS
YOU KNOW AS AS BETTER EVEN
ARTICULATED TODAY THE CURRENT
VACCINE COULD BE AVAILABLE AS
SOON AS POTENTIALLY. NEXT MONTH
DEPENDING ON THE FTA A APPROVAL.
AND HOW. SPECIFICALLY WILL
PLANT ROLE IN ADMINISTERING THE-
DURING THE FIRST PHASE ONE HEH
CARE WERE WILL BE PRIOR. THIS
IS IN PART BECAUSE THE FIZER
VACCINE SPECIFICALLY WHICH IS
THE FIRST ONE THAT IS LIKELY TO
GAIN APPROVAL. REQUIRE STORAGE
AT AN ALL TIME LOW TEMPERATURE
OF NEGATIVE NINETY FOUR
FAHRENHEIT. IN ADDITION TO
OFFERING A VACCINE THE VACCINE
TO THEIR EMPLOYEES AND STAFF.
MANY HOSPITALS WILL BE
VOLUNTEERING TO SERVE AS CLOSE
POINTS OF DISPENSING. FOR
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES
PARAMEDICS AND OTHER HEALTH
CARE WORKERS WHO MIGHT BE
PRIORITIZE FOR THE VACCINE. IN
ADDITION THE CENTERS FOR
MEDICARE AND MEDICAID SERVICES
HAS RELEASED BUT A FINAL RULE.
THAT INCLUDES A VACCINE
ADMINISTRATION COVERAGE
REQUIREMENTS FOR HEALTH PLANS
AND FROM MEDICAID SPECIFICALLY.
THROUGH THEIR SCHOOL THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES LABOR AND TREASURY.
IMPLEMENT THE CARRIAGE ACT
REQUIREMENT THAT NON
GRANDFATHERED GROUP HEALTH AND
INDIVIDUAL PLANS MUST COVER
WITHOUT CARSHARING QUALIFYING
COVERED NINETEEN PREVENTIVE
SERVICES. THIS INCLUDES ALL
DOSES OF ANY APPROVED COVERED
NINETEEN VACCINE. THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE VACCINE
FOR ALL REQUIRED DOSES AND THE
OFFICE VISIT DURING WHICH THE
VACCINE IS ADMINISTERED. UNDER
THE FAMILIES FIRST ACT THE
OTHER FEDERAL ACT IN QUESTION
HERE RIGHT NOW I'M IN IN
DISCUSSION HERE STATES ARE ALSO
ENTITLED TO A TEMPORARY SIX
POINT TWO PERCENTAGE INCREASE.
AND THEY'RE FEDERAL MEDICARE
MEDICAL ASSISTANCE PERCENTAGE
OR F. MAP. ON THE CONDITION
THAT THE STATE COVERS WITHOUT
COST SHARING. COBIT NINETEEN
VACCINES AND THEIR
ADMINISTRATION FOR CERTAIN
MEDICAID ENROLLEES. AND WHILE
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
PROVIDED THIS NATIONWIDE GOT
THIS NATIONAL GUIDANCE IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT THERE ARE STILL
CALIFORNIA SPECIFIC GUIDANCE SO
THAT WHEN THE VACCINATIONS
BEGIN IT WILL SMOOTH THE WAY.
FOR FRONTLINE HEALTH CARE
WORKERS AND LATER THE GENERAL
PUBLIC TO HAVE ACCESS TO THESE
IMPORTANT VACCINES IT WOULD BE
HELPFUL FOR THE STATE TO
DEVELOP SOME CLEAR PRIORITIES
AND GUIDEPOSTS. AND ALIGN THEM
WITH PAYMENT PRIORITIES. IN
ADDITION NEW THERAPEUTIC AND
NEW THERAPEUTIC TREATMENTS ARE
WILL CONTINUE TO BE DEVELOPED
WE CURRENTLY HAVE THREE MAJOR
ONES AND AT LEAST SIXTEEN IN
THE PIPELINE. WITH GENERAL
DISTRIBUTION STILL MONTHS AWAY
AND IT'S CASES CONTINUES TO
SURGE WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT
THESE NEW TREATMENTS WILL BE
COVERED FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS SO
THAT INDIVIDUALS ARE NOT BILL
BECAUSE INSURANCE ARE NOT
COVERING THESE NEW FORMS OF
CLINICAL CARE. AS THEY COME ON
LINE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. NEXT UP WE HAVE
GENET THORTON. A SENIOR VICE
PRESIDENT PRODUCT EMPLOYER IN
COMMERCIAL POLICY FOR THE
AMERICAN HEALTH INSURANCE PLANS
WELCOME. THANK YOU SEVEN PAN ON
BEHALF OF THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME- AND PLANS REMAIN COMMITTED
TO HELPING OUR MEMBERS AND
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY BOTH
WAVING TESTING FOR COST SHARING
IN TREATMENT AND PREPARING FOR
THE EVENTUAL APPROVAL OF A
VACCINE. WE KNOW THAT THERE
WILL BE CHALLENGES THAT WE ARE
COMMITTED TO PARTNERING WITH
POLICYMAKERS IN THE STATE TO
ENSURE THAT THE CALL THE
NINETEEN VACCINES ARE ROLLED
OUT IN THE STATES AND
COMPREHENSIVE FASHION. AS WAS
MENTIONED INSURERS HAVE TO
COVER THE VACCINE BOTH IN AND
OUT OF NETWORK AT NO COST TO
THE INDIVIDUAL. REGARDLESS OF
INSURANCE COVERAGE IN THE
VACCINATORS ARE NOT PERMITTED
TO BALANCE STILL. WE ARE
CLOSELY MONITORING THE STA
PROCESS IN THE E. C. I. T. FOR
THE RECOMMENDATIONS AS WAS
MENTIONED UNDER CURES INSURANCE
PROVIDERS HAVE TO COVER THE
VACCINE WITHIN FIFTEEN BUSINESS
DAYS. BUT CMS AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAVE SEEN ALL THAT
WE WILL NEED TO BE READY
IMMEDIATELY WHEN THE TRUCKS
START TO ROLL LITERALLY. HEALTH
INSURANCE RIGHT NOW ARE
PREPARING TO WIND WILL
PROVIDERS AND ACCEPT CLEANS FOR
PAYMENT OF THE COVE IN NINETEEN
ADMINISTRATION SEAT. IN SOME
CASES WILL BE RECEIVING CLAIMS
FROM PUBLIC HEALTH. ENTITIES
THAT HAVE NOT TRADITIONALLY
BUILD COMMERCIAL INSURANCE
COMPANIES. THERE ARE SEVERAL
AREAS WHERE WE STAND READY TO
ASSIST. INFORMING OUR MEMBERS
IF THEY NEED TO CREATE AFTER
GETTING THE VACCINE AND WHERE
THEY CAN GET IT. USING OUR
AVAILABLE DATA TO HELP IDENTIFY
PRIORITY POPULATIONS. HELPING
ASSIST IN FOLLOWING UP TO MAKE
SURE THOSE VACCINATED RECEIVED
IN MANY CASES THE REQUIRED
SECOND DOSE. HELPING TRACK
ADVERSE EVENTS AND ALSO-
GETTING READY TO WOULD THAT
ADDRESS DATA CHALLENGES YOU
KNOW IF WE DON'T RECEIVE A
CLAIM WE MIGHT NOT KNOW THAT
OUR MEMBER HAD RECEIVED A CALL
THAT VACCINE. AND SO WE ARE
CRITICALLY INTERESTED IN
WORKING TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE PART OF THE DATA AS WELL.
AND FINALLY WE WILL SERVE AS A
CREDIBLE SOURCE OF INFORMATION
ON BOTH VACCINE SAFETY AND
EFFECTIVENESS FULL FOR
PROVIDERS. AND PATIENTS AND OUR
MEMBERS. THERE ARE SEVERAL
DIFFERENT AREAS WHERE WE CAN.
FURTHER PARTNERSHIP WE AGREED
IT IS CRITICAL FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO DO WHATEVER IT
CAN TO MAKE DATA. I'M VACCINE
ADMINISTRATION PLANS AVAILABLE
HEALTH INSURANCE PLANS AND WE
AGREED THAT THE STATE NEEDS TO
BE AS TRANSPARENT AS POSSIBLE
REGARDING VACCINE SUPPLY. KNOWS
THE SIZE OF THE ALLIANCE THE
TIMING OF THE LATINS WHAT WHAT
WHAT'S COMING IN FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WHERE IT'S
GOING ACROSS THE STATE IN WHICH
PROVIDERS ARE BEING SELECTED TO
ADMINISTER. THE STEPS. WILL
HELP- STANDS FULL SCALE. OF
WHERE WE MY RECEIVE DOSES IN
WHERE MY MIGHT BACKS NAY AND
HOW ENSURE THAT OUR MEMBERS
JACKSON AND IT'S- WAY. IN
CLOSING WE STAND READY TO US IN
THE CAL RESIDENTS FAX. OVER THE
COMING MONTHS AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO YOUR QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU THANKS VERY MUCH-
FINALLY WE HAVE DIANA DOUGLAS
POLICY LET'S LEAVE ADVOCATE
FROM HEALTH ACCESS CALIFORNIA
WELCOME. GOOD AFTERNOON AND
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE AND DIANA
DOUGLAS POLICY ADVOCATE WITH
HEALTH ACCESS CALIFORNIA
STATEWIDE HEALTH CARE CONSUMER
ADVOCACY COALITION. AS CONSUMER
ADVOCATES WE'VE APPRECIATED THE
QUICK RESPONSE OF THE PANDEMIC
ON PART OF THE LEGISLATURE IN
THE ADMINISTRATION. HOWEVER WE
REMAIN CONCERNED THAT DESPITE
MUCH NEEDED STATE ACTION FEWER
STEPS HAVE BEEN TAKEN TO MAKE
SURE PEOPLE ARE NOT LEFT PAYING
FOR EXPENSIVE COST SHARING. AND
ALSO DEDUCTIBLES THAT MIGHT BE
IN THE THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
EVEN FOR MIDDLE INCOME
CALIFORNIANS AS WE HEAD INTO
THIS NEW WINTER WAVE OF
INFECTIONS WE SHOULD ALL BE
CONCERNED THAT THOSE WERE BEING
DIAGNOSED NOW- WILL BE
POTENTIALLY NEEDING TREATMENT
OVER THE COMING WEEKS. IT WILL
REALLY BE A HOLIDAY SEASON
PERSONALLY WHEN MANY FAMILIES
MIGHT BE STUCK HAVING TO SCRAPE
TOGETHER FUNDS TO COVER THEIR
SHARE OF COST AND OTHERS MIGHT
BE FACED WITH. THE REALLY
DIFFICULT CHOICE OF WHETHER TO
SEEK TREATMENT AT ALL AND MISS
UNCERTAINTY OF WHAT THE COST
MIGHT BE. WE APPRECIATE THE
HEALTH HEALTH PLANS THAT HAVE
WAIVE COST SHARING FOR
TREATMENT HOWEVER IT'S UNCLEAR
HOW MANY PLANTS HAVE DONE THIS
AND- REALLY MANY CALIFORNIANS
ARE UNSURE ABOUT EXACTLY WHAT
THEY'LL BE RESPONSIBLE TO PAY.
AS WE'VE HEARD OVER AND OVER IN
THIS HEARING CALIFORNIANS AND
PRIVATE HEALTH INSURANCE ARE
CONFUSED ABOUT WHAT THEY MIGHT
HAVE TO PAY FOR WHAT THEIR COST
SHARING MIGHT BE. AND AS
IMPORTANT AS IT'S CLEAR AS IT
IS TO CLARIFY COVERAGE BENEFITS
FOR TESTING ALSO PATIENT BILLS
FOR TREATMENT ARE YOU KNOW
EXPONENTIALLY HIGHER SO IT'S-
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT THAT
FOLKS KNOW WHAT THEY MIGHT BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR SHOULD THEY
UNFORTUNATELY NEED TREATMENT.
WE ALSO KNOW THE EFFECTS OF THE
VIRUS ARE ONE LIVES THAT WE
MUST MAKE SURE ANY REQUIREMENTS
FOR TREATMENT COVERAGE STAND AT
LEAST SOMETIME PASSED THE END
OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY.
LUCKILY VACCINES ARE ON THE
HORIZON COVERAGE FOR EXACT
EXCHANGE MIGHT SEEM MORE CLEAR
CUT BUT THERE ARE STILL
CONCERNS ABOUT WHETHER IN FACT
ALL PLANS COVER THE VACCINE. OR
VACCINES WITHIN FIFTEEN DAYS OF
THE FEDERAL ADVISORY
COMMITTEE'S RECOMMENDATION AND
ALSO QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
INTERPLAY OF VACCINE COVERAGE
FEDERAL ADVISORY RECOMMENDATION
AND ALSO OUR GOVERNOR
SCIENTIFIC REVIEW WORKGROUP AND
HOW THOSE WORK TOGETHER. WE
CAN'T AFFORD TO LEAVE ANY OF
THESE. QUESTIONS UNANSWERED WE
HAVE TO ADDRESS THESE SHE'S NOW
HAD ON SO THAT THE STATE'S
READY TO MOVE. THAT
CALIFORNIANS BE COVERED ONE SEX
CAN BE DESTROYED. ESPECIALLY
THAT CALIFORNIANS CAN BE CON.
IN THEIR COVER AND GET BACK.
BUT ANYHOW. WHATSOEVER THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY THANK YOU
THANKS VERY MUCH- NOW WE'LL-
GET READY FOR MEMBER QUESTIONS
BEFORE WE DO MEMBER QUESTIONS I
DO JUST WANT TO REMIND AT
PEOPLE WITH- DEVICE. LIKE TO
REMIND MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
AND LIKE TO INVITE THEM. THAT
THEY WISH TO PARTICIPATE
THROUGH OUR TELEPHONIC SERVICE-
TO PLEASE CALL AND NOW. YOU CAN
PLEASE DIAL THIS TOLL FREE
NUMBER EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR.
AND WHEN PROMPTED USE THE
ACCESS CODE EIGHT FOUR NINE
SEVEN ONE THREE EIGHT. SO IF
YOU CAN IF YOU'RE INTERESTED IN
MAKING PUBLIC COMMENTS AFTER A
TELEPHONIC SYSTEM PLEASE CALL
AND NOW. WILL NOW MOVE BACK TO-
BRING DISCUSSION BACK TO THE
MEMBERS OF THE QUESTIONS. FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MA'AM
OKA OKAY NOT SEEING ANY CANS
UP- I DID- IT DIDN'T PUT IT YET
IS- TRICIA BLOCKER. THE STILL
ON FROM CDPH. YES YES THANK YOU
SO WE HEARD FROM AMERICAN
HEALTH INSURANCE PLANS ABOUT
THE IMPORTANCE OF- DATA
TRANSPARENCY AND ALSO THEIR
WILLINGNESS TO WORK. AND
TRACKING SO MAYBE YOU CAN SPEAK
TO IN YOUR VACCINE DISTRIBUTION
PLAN- ARE YOU PLAN ARE YOU
PARTNERING WITH FOR EXAMPLE
HEALTH PLANS ARE OTHERS IN
TERMS OF TRYING TO TRACK WHO
GOT THE VACCINE WHO HASN'T HAVE
YOU SEE IN THE BEGINNING I
THINK THAT'S GOING TO BE. TO BE
QUITE. HELLO DIMITRIJ DEMAND
EXCEEDING SUPPLY- AND THEN OF
COURSE I KNOW YOU'RE WORKING ON
PLANTS PRIORITIZE. AND THEN
ALSO IN ADDITION. IN TERMS OF-
PROVIDING DATA TO PEOPLE ABOUT.
HOW MUCH HOW MANY VACCINE DOSES
WE HAVE AND WE'RE LOCATED AND
SO FORTH BECAUSE WE HAVE TO
ALSO. TRACK YOU KNOW WHO GOT
THE ONLY ONE WHO GOT THE SECOND
ONE AND SO FORTH. SO CAN YOU
PERHAPS SPEAK TO THE-
DEPARTMENTS PLANS FOR. FAXING
DISTRIBUTION RELATION TO
PARTNERSHIPS WITH. OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS FOR DATA AND DATA
TRANSPARENCY. SURE THANK YOU.
WE ARE. WELL AS I MENTIONED
THERE ARE A LOT OF DATA
REQUIREMENTS THAT CDC HOUSE FOR
ALL OF THE VACCINATIONS THAT
WILL BE ADMINISTERED- SO WE DID
THAT WILL BE THE FIRST PLACE
WHERE WE'LL BE ABLE TO- TALK
ABOUT HOW MUCH EACH COUNTY WAS
ALLOCATED HOME WHICH WAS
ADMINISTERED- AND BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE SOME CONTEXT AROUND
THERE WE'RE WORKING ON ON THOSE
ELEMENTS RIGHT NOW AND HOW WE
WANT TO BE ABLE TO REPORT THAT
ON IT IN A TIMELY WAY TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYONE KNOWS ON.
HOW MUCH VACCINE IS THIS-GETTING. ADMINISTERED
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. SO-
MORNING THERE CERTAIN WORKING
TO HAD. BE ABLE TO DESCRIBE-
AND DIVEST THAT WE CAN AND HOW
HOW AND WHO'S GETTING THE
VACCINE WITHOUT- I. DISRUPTING
ANYONE'S PRIVACY AND ISSUES- IS
THAT SOMETHING YOU SEE THAT SO
TO HELP ANSWER TALKED ABOUT
THEIR POTENTIAL ROLE IN THIS IS
THAT SOMETHING THAT- THE
DEPARTMENT ISRAELI ENGAGED WITH
THE HEALTH PLANS OR DO YOU SEE
THAT ARE. EITHER YOU'RE DOING
IT ARE YOU LOOKING TO DOING IN
THE FUTURE. WE'RE SENDING OUT-
ADD OPPORTUNITIES TO TALK WITH
ALL STANDS IN THE IMAGE C. N.
AND OTHERS SO THAT WE WERE ABLE
TO COORDINATE WITH THEM AND
MAKE SURE THAT WE'VE GOT A GOOD
INFORMATION FLOW AND CAN.
ADDRESS THESE THESE NEEDS OKAY
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU AND I KNOW
THAT- ALL THESE ORGANIZATIONS
WORK LEVEL DATA- I DID HAVE A
QUESTION ACTUALLY FOR- DOCTOR
ALBERTSON- SHE'S ON THE LINE.
SO YES SO GET IT SO YOU YOU ARE
THE TRANSFERRED US TO CATER FOR
THE FIZER COVED NINETEEN
VACCINE TRIAL ALSO. MAYBE FROM
YOUR EXPERIENCE DOING THE TRIAL
A THEIR THINGS THAT PROVIDERS
NEED TO KNOW AND THEN OF
COURSE- THEIR MEDICAL GROUPS
ARE HEALTH PLANS. IN TERMS OF.
IT DELUDE STORING ADMINISTERING
THE VACCINE OTHER TYPES OF
THINGS THAT- WANTS THAT PEOPLE
SHOULD BE AWARE OF AS WE
DEVELOP POLICY FOR COVERAGE AND
ALSO FOR- PROVIDERS IN TERMS OF
TO SET EXPECTATIONS ABOUT WHAT
THEY WOULD NEED TO DO TO
EFFECTIVELY- YOU'LL RECEIVE AND
THEN DISTRIBUTE THE VACCINE-
AND I RECOGNIZE THAT. PLACES
REQUIRES ALL TO COLD STORAGE SO
MAYBE INDIVIDUAL PROVIDERS
WON'T BE DOING IT BUT MAYBE YOU
CAN SPEAK A LITTLE BIT TOO WHAT
FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE SOMEONE
ACTUALLY HAD TO ORGANIZE THIS
ON THE GROUND WHERE SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT NEED TO BE
CONSIDERED WHEN IT COMES TO-
ACTUALLY ADMINISTERING THIS
VACCINE ON THE FIELD. THANK YOU
SENATOR. THIS IS GONNA BE A
HUGE ISSUE. I THINK THAT THE
DATA EXCHANGE BETWEEN- THE-
STATE AND THE PROVIDERS AND THE
HEALTH INSURANCE IS GOING TO BE
ONE OF THE KEY AREAS THAT WILL
EITHER FAIL OR- WERE I MAKE
THIS WORK- DAY TO. VACCINES
THAT ARE CLOSEST TO BEING
APPROVED HAVE. DIFFERENT
INTERVALS BETWEEN THEM AT LEAST
IN THEIR STUDIES ONE IS- TWENTY
ONE DAYS ONE IS TWENTY EIGHT
DAYS. SO IT WILL WILL NEED TO
KNOW ABOUT WHAT DRUG THEY HAD
WHAT TIME THEY HAD IT WHAT LOT
THEY HAD. IT AND THAT'S GOING
TO BE VERY DYNAMIC BECAUSE THIS
IS WE'RE TRYING TO RETURN TO
MUNITY SO THIS IS GOING TO BE
GOING ON. ALL OVER THE PLACE.
SO IT'S GOING TO BE A REAL
CHALLENGE IS GOING TO BE
SOMETHING THAT I THINK THE
PROVIDERS ARE GOING TO BE
EXCITED ABOUT. BUT I THINK WE
WILL NEED INFORMATION AND- I'M
HOPING THAT THE- DATABASE. THAT
IS PROVIDED. GIVES THAT KIND OF
HIM. AND MAKES IT AVAILABLE TO
PROVIDERS I HOPE IT'S NOT A
CURIOUS TYPE DATABASE THAT
TAKES YOU KNOW FIVE TEN YEARS.
GET TO A POINT WHERE WE CAN
ACTUALLY USE A CLINICALLY. SO
SOME SORT OF INTERFACE WITH
EPIC OR CERNER THE MAJOR IBM
OURS WOULD BE JUST UTSTANDING-
IN TERMS OF THE PROBLEMS THAT
WE'VE SEEN- GIVING IT TO
PROBABLY ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY PATIENTS GOT ACTIVE DRUG
OUT OF THE TWO THIRTY. NOT MUCH-
PAIN AT THE SITE OF INJECTION
MALAISE FOR A DAY TREATED WITH
NONSTEROIDAL ALL GOT BETTER. SO
I THINK I THINK THIS IS GOING
TO BE OUR OUR REAL INFLECTION
POINT TO. MAKE A CHANGE IN THIS
DISEASE THANK YOU FOR
LISTENING. AND MAYBE JUST
ANOTHER QUESTION- AND- RELATION
TO THAT- WHAT IT COMES SO. WELL
FIRST ALL I ATE PERHAPS IT'S
SELF EVIDENT TO THOSE OF US WHO
WHO ARE IN MEDICINE BUT MAY NOT
BE SELF EVIDENT IS THAT WE HAVE
MULTIPLE VACCINES THEY REQUIRE
TWO DOSES YOU CAN'T GIVE ONE
DOES ONE VACCINE AND GIVE THE
SECOND DOSE OF THE OTHER
VACCINE CORRECT. IS THAT WOULD
BE MY UNDERSTANDING IT'S NEVER
BEEN DONE. OKAY ALL RIGHT. WELL
SO IS A PEDIATRICIAN SOMETIMES
YOU'RE LIKE OKAY WE GAVE ONE
HEAD THAT WE HAVEN'T HAD THAT.
SO THIS SO IN TERMS OF THE
DISTRIBUTION OF VACCINE AND
THEN ALSO THE COVERAGE OF THE
VACCINE. THEN YOU'D HAVE TO
ACTUALLY IF YOU GAVE ONE THOSE
TWO PERSON THEN SOME PLACE YOU
HAVE TO KNOW THERE'S A SECOND
AS COMING. OR DEALING WITH. YOU
DON'T EXACTLY CHANCE THAT YOU
STILL HAVE A SCOND DOES AT THE
TIME SECOND DOES IT DO RIGHT.
AS YOU KNOW FROM YOUR PEDIATRIC
EXPERIENCE- I WE HAVE A MOBILE
POPULATION SO AND NOT ONLY WILL
WE EDUCATE THEM AT THE TIME OF
THEIR FIRST DOSE WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO TRACK AND- MAKE SURE
THEY COME FROM THE SECOND DOES.
BECAUSE WE HAVE NO DATA ON
WONDER WAS BEING- APPLICATIONS.
CLOSER IT'S GOING TO BE HERE
IT'S COULD BE A LOT OF WORK. TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE GET THOSE
SECOND DOSES AND WITH THE RIGHT
DRUG AT THE RIGHT TIME. OKAY
AND DEPENDING ON THE TIMING OF
MAYBE THIS IS A QUESTION FOR-
THE HELP. AMERICA'S HEALTH
INSURANCE PLANS AND MAYBE EVEN
FOR TEAMMATES SEE IF- YOU KNOW
COMING UP IN OPEN ENROLLMENT SO
IT'S POSSIBLE WE COULD BE
ADMINISTERING VACCINES WHERE
SOMEONE GOT WIND OF THIS AND
THEN THEY CHANGED PLANS. FOR
AND THEN THE SECOND DOSE IS DO
SO IS THAT THE SENATE IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT YOU FOR C. IS
BEING A PROBLEM OR IS TO
EXPECTATIONS VERY CLEAR THAT
WHOEVER INITIATED. IS COVERING
BOTH DOSES. SURE CHAIRMAN PANIC
CAN SPEAK TO THAT SO JUST
WANTED TO CLARIFY TO YOU THAT
THERE IS GOING TO BE A SEPARATE
CODE FOR EACH PARTICULAR
VACCINE EACH PARTICULAR DOES
WHETHER IT BE THE FIRST OR
SECOND DOSE. SO IN THE SYSTEM
WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO KNOW
WHICH ACTUAL VACCINE THEY GOT
AND WHETHER IT WAS THE FIRST.
OR SECOND. BUT IT. GRAYSON DOES.
PLANS DO. HEALTH INSURER IN
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY ONE IT WE
WOULD NOT HAVE ANY RECORD OF
WHETHER THAT INDIVIDUAL WAS
VACCINATED UNDER THEIR PRIOR
INSURER NOT. AND THIS IS WHY
IT'S SO IMPORTANT THAT- THE
DATABASES THAT TRICIA BARKER
SPOKE TO. ARE AVAILABLE SO THAT
THE STATE AND FEDERAL
AUTHORITIES CAN'T TRACK. THAT
INDIVIDUAL THAT SITUATION HELP
ENSURE THAT THEY DO GET THAT
CRITICAL SECOND DOSE. OKAY NOW
WOULD IT BE SIMPLER IF WE
SIMPLY SAID WHOEVER COVER THE
FIRST AT NINE WE KOW SINCE WE
KNOW THIS IS A TWO DOSE VACCINE
I DON'T WANT OTHER FUTURE
VACCINES ARE GOING TO COME OUT-
RELATED. IS THERE SOME THIS IS
LADY SAID SIMPLY BECAUSE FIRST
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT'S PLANNED IN
MY TO SWITCH TO WE DON'T EVEN
KNOW WHETHER YOU. WERE NOW ARE
NOW AN INSURED OR WHATEVER
ELSE- BUT AT THE END REASONABLE
TO SAY WHAT WOULD YOU START OF
WITH ONE THAT THAT HEALTH PLAN
COVERS. THE WHOLE SERIES WHICH
IS REALLY TO. AS A THAT MAKE
THINGS EASIER. I JUST WANT TO
BE CLEAR SO FOR ALL OF THE
DOSES THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS PURCHASED THAT
ARE BEING RUN THROUGH WHAT'S
CALLED OPERATION WORKS FEET
RIGHT THE VACCINATORS CASTS YOU
BACKS TO MEET THAT PERSON
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THEY'RE
INSURED OR NOT OR WHICH
INSURANCE THEY HAVE. OKAY THAT
INDIVIDUAL IS GOING TO GET THE
VACCINATION IF THE PERSON IS
UNINSURED THERE'S GONNA BE A
FINE THAT THEY CAN SEE THAT
FUNDING TO GO FOR THAT
VACCINATION ADMINISTRATION.
NASA SO WHAT OF AND- THEY HAVE.
WE GET THE CLEAN AT THE BACKEND
OF COURSE GET A CLEAN FOR A
VACCINE ADMINISTRATION. WE HAVE
TO COVER IT UNDER THE FEDERAL
AND- STATE FEDERAL LAW AND THE
REGULATIONS THAT WERE DESCRIBED
EARLIER HOPE THAT MAKES SENSE.
OKAY LIKE FOR THAT PERSON IT'S
VERY SEAMLESS. THEY'RE GETTING
THE VACCINATION. NO BALANCE.
OKAY ALL RIGHT- AND THEN I DID
HAVE ANOTHER QUESTION FOR YOU.
JEFF THORTON- SO WE'VE BEEN
TALKING A LOT OF VACCINES IN
TERMS OF- TREATMENTS AND
THERAPEUTICS AND YOU MADE
MENTION THE OTHER ART DIRECTOR
A LOT COMING DOWN THE LINE AND
I THINK WAS MENTIONED BY THE
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATIONS WELL-
SOME HAVE. BEEN SAMPLE I TAX
CLERK WHEN BASICALLY STUDIES
HAVE SHOWN IT'S NOT
PARTICULARLY EFFECTIVE THERE'S
SOME QUESTIONS WHO'S NOW SAID-
HAD RAISED SOME QUSTIONS.
ABOUT THE THINGS WRITTEN
LETTERS HERE. WHAT HOW WANTED
TO HEALTH PLANS DOING IN
RELATION TO COVERAGE OF
DIFFERENT TREATMENTS AND
DECIDING WHICH THERAPEUTIC
STILL COVER OR NOT. GREAT THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN YEAH THAT'S A
REALLY GREAT QUESTION I WILL
SAY THAT A NUMBER OF OUR
MEMBERS HAVE VOLUNTARILY WAIVED
I CALLED IN NINETEEN TREATMENT
COST SHARING THROUGH THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY AND SOME CASES
EVEN BEYOND THAT- BUT TEARS
SPECIFIC QUESTION AROUND WHICH
A SPECIFIC TREATMENTS ARE
COVERED BY THE PLAN. YOU KNOW
WE HAVE- ALL OUR PLANS YET
VERY- CHIEF MEDICAL OFFICERS
WHO LOOK AT THE DATA AND
EVIDENCE TO HELP MAKE THOSE
DECISIONS ON BEHALF OF THEIR-
INSURANCE PLANS ARE FORTUNATE
SEMI QUITE AREA OF EXPERTISE
FOR EXAMPLE WE DO KNOW THAT
THEY REVIEW THE EVIDENCE AND
ARE HELPING MAKE THOSE
DECISIONS AND I THINK. WE'VE
BEEN CLOSELY MONITORING THE
STA- TO SOME RECENT
ANNOUNCEMENTS OF THE LAST DAY
OR SO HOW THEY MAKE THOSE
COVERAGE DECISIONS JUST MAKE
SURE THAT PEOPLE CAN GET ANY
TREATMENT OKAY SO BUT AND I
GUESS AND- SORT OF FOLLOW UP TO
THAT DOES- I MEAN I CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND- THE- MALE MEDICAL
DIRECTORS HELPING PROVIDE.
DIRECTION AND GUIDANCE AND
ABOUT WHAT'S- HOW'S THAT
COMMUNICATED DENTED THE
PROVIDER COMMUNITY BECAUSE THIS
IS A AGAIN THIS IS FAST MOVING
RIGHT SO- DATESAND THINGS ARE
CHANGING RAPIDLY AND AT THE
SAME TIME YOU'RE- A DOCTOR YOU
SEEN THE PATIENT AND- YOU
CHOOSE. A PARTICULAR TREATMENT
AND THEN. THE MEDICAL DIRECTOR
AS WELL WE JUSTICE LAST WEEK
BASED ON SOMETHING AND AFTER
THAT WE'RE GOING TO COVER THIS
ANY. THE THOUGH WE COVER IT.
TWO WEEKS AGO- SO HOW HOW HOW
DO YOU SEE THAT BEING
COMMUNICATED TO. TO PHYSICIANS
AND OTHER PROVIDERS IN TERMS
OF- THESE TYPES OF GUIDELINES
INCISIONS. SO SHERIN DAN FIRST
AND I HAVEN'T REALLY HEARD ANY
STORIES OF PEOPLE. GETTING
NEEDED COVERAGE FOR SOME OF
THESE NEW THERAPIES COMING ON
THE MARKET SO IT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT HAS COME ACROSS
MY DESK RECENTLY SO I DON'T.
KNOW JUST BECAUSE IT'S NOT A
WIDESPREAD PROBLEM OR WHAT HAVE
YOU SO I REALLY HAVEN'T HEARD.
OF THAT DAY NOT A PROBLEM IN
SOME OF THESE NEW TREATMENTS
HAVE BEEN COMING. OUT AND SOME
OF THEM HAVE BEEN IN QUITE
SHORT SUPPLY- IT'S BEEN A
BIGGER ISSUE AS WELL I WILL SAY
THAT IN GENERAL HEALTH
INSURANCE PLANS REALLY WORK
HARD TO KEEP THEIR COVERAGE
POLICIES UP TO DATE. ON THEIR
RECENT PROVIDES SEVERAL
RESOURCES FOR THEIR- PROVIDE
THEIR PROVIDERS AND WHICH SORT
OF WHAT'S WHAT'S COVERED. UNDER
THAT JONES. THE MEDICAL
COVERAGE POLICIES. OKAY AND- I
AT A THE BARS. DID YOU WANT
MAKE A COMMENT ON ON THAT AS A-
THE HEAD OF A- NINE YEAR OLD
CMA AND ALSO AS A PHYSICIAN
WHO. IS OVERSEAS A LARGE HEALTH
SYSTEM. WELL I YOU KNOW I THINK
THE WHOLE KEY HERE IS YOU KNOW
WE CANNOT ANTICIPATE. EXACTLY
WHAT'S GONNA GO ON AND THIS
GOES BACK TO MY PREVIOUS
COMMENT I'M NOT TRYING TO
LEGISLATE THINGS AS MUCH AS
CREATE- EVOLVING GUIDELINES
ABOUT WHAT'S BEST PRACTICES.
AND IN LISTA CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION AND THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION-
IN THAT EFFORT TO MAKE URE
THAT EVERYBODY'S DOING EXACTLY
THE RIGHT THING AND THE RIGHT
THING MIGHT CHANGE A LITTLE
BIT- AS NEW- YOU JACKSON'S COME
OUT AND- AND- YOU TO MAKE THE
RIGHT DECISION FOR EACH
SPECIFIC PATIENT- SO I'LL JUST
LEAVE IT. OUT LEAVE IT THERE.
OKAY TRAINING IS ALSO G. ONE OF
MAKING COMMENTS. FOR THE
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION ON THAT.
SO I THINK- DELIVERS THE KIND
COVERAGE A LOT OF THIS- AND AS
I SAID IN MY REMARKS IT'S-
THOSE THE KINDS OF THINGS THAT
WE JUST WANT TO KIND OF MAKE
SURE THAT OUR PROVIDERS-
HAPPENS OUT HAVE ACCESS POINTS
AND ARE ABLE TO TREAT THE
PATIENT AS AS THEY COME. OKAY
AND THEN I STANDARDLESS I'LL
GIVE YOU THE LAST WORD IS
CONSUMER REPRESENTATIVE ADDED
THINGS THAT WE SHOULD BE
CONCERNED ABOUT- THAT STATE.
FOR IN TERMS OF ACCESS TO
TREATMENTS. SIDE VACCINES. I
THINK AS FAR AS ACCESS TO
TREATMENTS WE NEED TO ENSURE
THAT THAT FOLKS- KNOW WHAT
TREATMENTS ARE COVERED AT NO-
YOU KNOW FOR HOW LONG ONCE A
PUBLIC HEALTH. EMERGENCY ENDS
ARE THEY GOING TO BE ABLE TO BE
COVERED FOR. ANY ON GOING
ISSUES- AND- REALLY I THINK
RIGHT NOW THE NUMBER ONE THING
IS JUST PROVIDING CLARITY WHAT
WE DON'T WANT TO- PEOPLE
SITTING AT HOME WORRIED ABOUT.
BILLS I'M COMING OUR WAY AND
NOT SEEKING TREATMENT WHEN THEY
REALLY DO. OKAY THANK YOU AND I
APPRECIATE THE RECOGNIZING THIS
YOU KNOW THE FACT THAT THERE
ARE MANY PEOPLE WHO. WE OFTEN
TALK ABOUT THE NUMBER OF CASES
WE EVEN TALK ABOUT THE NUMBER
OF DEATHS WHICH IS OVER TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND WHICH IS
HORRENDOUS. BUT ALSO THERE'S
MANY PEOPLE WHO HAVE SURVIVED
COVETED BUT ARE STILL SUFFERING
FROM CODED THIS IS. I THINK
SOMETIMES FROM THE LONG
HAULERS. BUT THAT'S BECOMING AN
EVER INCREASINGLY LARGE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE AS WELL AND THEY NEED
ONGOING TREATMENT- ON AN
ONGOING BASIS SO- EFFECTIVE FOR
THEM BECAUSE OF IT IS A PRE
EXISTING CONDITION THAT THEY
NEED CONTINUING CARE FOR- SO
WITH THAT. IN MIND JUST TURN
BACK OR THERE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS. I SEE
NO HANDS UP AT THE MOMENT. OKAY
SEE NO OTHER QUESTIONS AND I
THINK AGAIN OUR PANEL SAID
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH. FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY AND FOR.
ANSWERING OUR QUESTIONS HERE.
AND SO AGAIN WHAT PRECIADO YOU
TAKE YOUR TIME OUT AND- AND
SHARING WITH US YOUR YOUR-
PERSPECTIVES AND EXPERTISE- WE
ARE NOW GOING TO MOVE ON TO.
OUR PUBLIC COMMENT. IT HERE-
AND- SO AGAIN DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE LINK
OF HEARINGS TO KNOWLEDGE
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS- COMMITTEE CHAIR IS
GOING TO BE INSTITUTING- TIME
LIMITS ON THE TESTIMONY- SO
WE'RE GOING TO ALLOW ONE
MINUTE- PER PERSON FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT RELEVANT TO THE TOPIC
OF THE HEARING- AND- WE WILL-
SO ALL. AND WE DO WILL HAVE A
HARD STOP OPEN NOT ABLE TO GET
THROUGH EVERYONE AT FIVE PM-
BUT WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH
WITNESSES HERE IN THE GALLERY-
SO THERE ANY WITNESSES WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY AT THE GALLERY. A
PLEASE COME TO THE MICROPHONE
AND- PLEASE INTRODUCE YOURSELF
IF YOU REPRESENT AN
ORGANIZATION IN AB
ORGANIZATION. AND THEN- YOUR
TESTIMONY AND AGAIN WE ASK THAT
YOU KEEP YOUR TESTIMONY TO A
MINUTE IF YOU HAVE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION YOU WISH TO SUBMIT
TO THE COMMITTEE PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO SUBMIT IT ON THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AND SO IF
YOU CAN PLEASE DO THAT IF YOU
HAVE MORE THAN YOU WANT TO
SHARE WITH US THAT YOU'RE ABLE
TO THEN YOU'RE ABLE 2% IN THE
THIRD TIME THAT. WE ARE
ALLOWING FOR PUBLIC COMMENT SO
WE ARE VERY INTERESTED IN
HEARING FROM YOU- IN REGARDS TO
YOUR PERSPECTIVES SO WITH THAT-
WILL GO AHEAD AND BEGIN.
WELCOME EXERCISE EXERCISE
EXERCISE COBIT NINETEEN WILL BE
UNDERSTOOD AS EXERCISE KOBE
NINETEEN EXERCISE WILL ONLY BE
TERMINATED WHEN A SUFFICIENT
MAJORITY OF THE POPULATION IS
VACCINATED ESPECIALLY CHILDREN
THE ONLY IMMUNITY OFFERED IS
IMMUNITY FROM LIABILITY THAT'S
RIGHT EVERYONE INVOLVED IN THE
MURDER OR ASSAULT OF CHILDREN
WILL BE A 100% COVERED BY THE
PRESS ACT THERE'S NO INSURANCE
POLICY THAT COMPARES TO THE
CHILD BECOME VACCINE INJURED OR
DIE RIGHT AFTER BEING SHOT UP
BY THE CO NINETEEN VACCINE IT
DOESN'T MATTER BECAUSE PREP ACT
HAS YOU COVERED. DID YOU
PARTICIPATE IN THE MASS CHAU
GENOCIDE OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
DO YOU TO KOBE NINETEEN VACCINE
YOU'RE IN LUCK AND BACKED UP BY
PRESS ACT THE BEST INSURANCE
FREE OF CHARGE. THIS EXERCISE
IS A MAKE A RITUAL TO SATAN ALL
PROCEEDS GO TOWARDS HIM
LIABILITY YOU MAY NOT EVER BE A
FACTOR IN THIS LIFE BUT YOU CAN
COUNT ON BEING LIABLE WHEN YOU
MEET YOUR MAKER IN TEXAS VERY
MUCH PLEASE BE AWARE THE SECOND
DAY. IN WHICH YOUR SOUL WILL
HAVE NO FOR THE RESURRECTION
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE SIR. SIR RIGHT NEXT
WITNESS. I SAID. BY THE WAY
RIGHT MICHAEL. RIGHT RIGHT NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. RIGHT. PLEASE
INTRODUCE YOURSELF WELCOME. HI
SO WHAT HEALTH INSURANCE COVERS
THE FUNDING YOU DIDN'T PUSH ME
OUT OF YOUR BODY AND YOU
THEREFORE DO NOT HAVE THE RIGHT
TO PLEASE INTRODUCE YOURSELF MY
NAME IS DANNY I WAS HERE LAST
WEEK CAN YOU CUT ME OFF. DO YOU
EVEN KNOW WHAT CONSENT IS. OR
DO YOU JUST RIDE YOUR WAY
THROUGH LIFE. WHY DON'T YOU
EXPLAIN HOW ALUMINUM ABORTED
FETAL CELLS FORMAL THAT HAD
MERCURY LATEX. PLEASE AND HOW
HARD TO HELP GIVE KIDS SOME
FANTASTIC COMMUNITY. THAT'S
RIGHT KIDS. IT IS A
PEDIATRICIAN WHO HONESTLY
SHOULD HAVE JUST WON THE
OLYMPICS FOR SPENDING. MAYBE IN
BETWEEN RUNNING AWAY FROM
PEOPLE AND NOT LETTING THEM
INTO THE CAPITAL YOU SHOULD
LOOK INTO TRYING TO GROW BY
SOME OF YOUR HAIR. MAYBE YOU
SHOULD DEVELOP A VACCINE FOR
BALDING MCCARTY WILL LIKE THAT-
NEXT WITNESS.
PLEASE INTRODUCE
YOURSELF WELCOME. NOT SURE IF
YOU CAN HEAR SPEND WITH THE
PEOPLE WE PLEASE INTRODUCE WE
ONE THE CLOVER THE VACCINE
WOULD YOU PLEASE INTRODUCE
YOURSELF WE DON'T WANT THE
MASKS WE DON'T WANT SOCIAL
DISTANCING DON'T WANT LOCKDOWNS
BILL ONE THE INTAKE CABS NO
LUCIFERASE IN OUR BODY NO
HYDROGEL NO NANO PARTICLES NO
CRYPTOCURRENCY NO TOTAL CONTROL
HEAR ME NOW PAN. AS FAR AS I AM
CONCERNED TO SPEND THAT MAKE IT
NEVER EXISTED AND IT IS ALL
OVER TODAY NO HOSPITALS ARE HAD
BEEN OVERRUN BY PATIENTS PEOPLE
ARE NOT FALLING DOWN THE
STREETS. AS A MATTER OF FACT
HOSPITALS AND PHYSICIANS
OFFICES ARE EMPTY. YOU SHOULD
KNOW IF YOU STILL HAVE ONE. NO
MORE MASS NO BAXEEN NO B. S. IF
YOU HOWEVER TO BE CAN I CAN
RECOMMEND A FEW COUNTRIES DO
YOU TO RELOCATE WELL YOU WOULD
FIT RIGHT IN. TELL EIGHTEEN
PROGRAM ONE ZERO THREE EIGHT IS
STILL A FEDERALLY PUNISHABLE
CRIME HE PATTY ONCE YOU GO TO
PRISON IT YOU WILL HAVE THE
CHANCE TO BE VACCINATED BUT THE
THING OF IT THE VACCINE NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. NO THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. MA'AM NEXT
WITNESS. SO I WOULD MAKE NOTE
FOR THE AUDIENCE THAT- THE
FAMILIES OF THE TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND AMERICANS WHO
HAVE DIED FROM TELEVISION
ACTUALLY MORE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND I'M SURE WOULD
DISAGREE WITH THOSE COMMENTS
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. HI MY
BEAUTIFUL YOUNG AND I SAT
THROUGH THIS HEARING AND I
HEARD A LOT OF TALK ABOUT
TESTING. AND INSURANCE
COMPANIES PAYING FOR TESTING-
STARTING AT. THANKS WE DIDN'T
TALK ABOUT THE LACK OF ACCURACY
WITH TESTING AND- KERRY MULLIS
THE INVENTOR OF THE PCRTEST
STATED IT WAS NEVER TO BE USED
AS A DIAGNOSTIC TOOL YEAH WE
ARE LOCKING DOWN OUR STATE
BASED OFF A SYMPTOMATIC TESTING
WE ALSO DIDN'T SPEAK UP THE
REASON WHY WE'RE WALKING DOWN
THE STATE IS GAVIN NEWSOM HAS
PERSONAL INVESTMENT. IN THE
MODERN OF VACCINE FOR DAVID
MARTIN PHD AND FOUNDER OF H.
TWO ONE HUNDRED THE COMPANY
THAT GRANTS MEDICAL PATENTS
MUSEUM IS HEAVILY INVESTED SO
PERHAPS HE CAN HELP PAY FOR
WHAT THE INSURANCE COMPANIES
DON'T PAY FOR OR ANY INJURIES
DUE TO THE CORONAS VACCINE
SINCE WE WILL ALL BE GUINEA
PIGS. THIS IS NOTHING MORE THAN
A PONZI SCHEME AND YOU ARE ALL
COMPLICIT. RIGHT NOW THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ITS NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. CASEY NO OTHER
WITNESSES HERE WE HAVE ONE MORE
OKAY. PLEASE INTRODUCE YOURSELF
HE ALSO HAS A PROCESS OF MOVING
BECAUSE OF MY DISABILITY SURE
MY NAME IS DOCTOR DICKEY I GOT
A PHD IN DUCT TAPE SCIENCE NOT
PUT MY PHD AGAINST YOURS ANY
DAY OF THE WEEK. YOU'RE A
PEDIATRICIAN SHOULD BE ASHAMED
OF YOURSELF I SUFFER FOR THREE
PLUS HOURS THEY'RE- WEARING
THIS FREE TO MASTER SUITE USES.
A CORNISH SILVA REYES OXYGEN
BUT NOT ALL MY HEADACHES. WERE
STRUGGLE. YOU SHOULD YOU SHOULD
BE A OF YOURSELF. LAWRENCE THIS
IS ABOUT TWO OR THREE THOUSAND
PEOPLE DIE HELLO WILL NEVER DIE
THEIR VERY. THE TALK ABOUT- ALL
THESE PEOPLE THAT WILL GET THE
FORCE BECAUSE EVERYONE ELSE.
RELATED BUT YOU KNOW YOUR. TWO
THOUSAND PEOPLE DIE. PERCENT.
ONE HELLO INTRODUCE YOURSELF MY
CHECK THANK YOU YEAH YOU DON'T
YOU YOU KNOW ME- I AM A
CONSTITUENT OF KEVIN KILEY IS
WHO'S THE ONE COMING UP THROUGH.
AND YOU CAN'T YOU CAN'T PLEASE
WAIT YOUR MASK MA'AM. OKAY
RICHARD PAN YOU KNOW ME I'VE
BEEN FOLLOWING YOU AROUND FOUR
YEARS TALKING ABOUT THE
HYPOCRISY IT SAYS RIGHT ABOVE
YOUR HEAD LATIN YOUR SPOKE TO
THE OTHER IS SUPPOSED TO
PROTECT THEY'LL CALL ME WELL
NOT HELD YOU GOT IT TWISTED.
STAY ONE PEDIATRICIAN AND LEAVE
THE WELL TO SENATORS LIKE. ONE
THREE CARE ABOUT IS REPUBLIC
THE ONES YOU GUYS LITERALLY.
FOR ILLNESS HOW. DEMOCRATS JUST
LIKE YOU YOU'LL HAVE SOLD OUT
CALIFORNIA AND NOW YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO IT WITH ANOTHER
TEAM YOU. MATHIS YOU. ONE
THIRTY YOUR MASCOT PROP AND
DINNER WITH NEW STUFF AND ALL
THAT THESE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR AND YOUR ANY OTHER
WITNESS AND GALLERY. YEAH WE'LL
GO INTO RECESS- THANK YOU
WILL RESUME PUBLIC COMMENT. ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE WHO WISH TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC CONTACT. YOU KNOW HOW
YOU DEAL WITH THEM SENATOR PAN
HART WE PLEASE ENJOY YOURSELF
IN THE BILL. WE PLEASE
INTRODUCE YOURSELF WHICH
POISONS IN A BILL. WE INTRODUCE
YOURSELF SIR GOING TO KILL ME
MAIM AND INJURE MAKE YOU ILL
VIOLATE AGAINST OUR WILL.
EXPERIMENTS AGAINST OUR WILL-
COVER MY FACE. BECAUSE WE'RE
AFRAID THAT I'M GONNA PASS IT
OUT TO ALL THESE EMPTY CHAIRS
IN HERE. YEAH. EVERY YEAR
YOU'RE ADDING MORE EVERY SHOP
IN EVERY STORE VIOLATE IS AT
THE CORE OF THIS ATTACK MUST BE
IN DO OR- WHY WON'T WE JUST
REMAIN IN SILENCE WHY WON'T WE
JUST BOW DOWN IN COMPLIANCE.
BECAUSE OF ANTI. IT I'M ANTI
LEGISLATION HOME ANTI
SEGREGATION- ANTI FORCED
VACCINATION YEAH I'M ANTI ALL
OF THAT AND YOU ARE PRO ALL OF
THAT WE HAVE A NATION OF BIG
DIVIDE HERE SENATOR PAM. ALL
YOU EVER HE'S A VERY NICE VERY
CALM THE VACCINATION PROGRAM IS
SO FREAKING WEIRD DUDE YOU HAVE
NO NONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES WHEN PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
OR THIS. MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE- PROMPT THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO BUY PUBLIC COMMENT.
AND IF YOU CAN GIVE ME AN
INDICATION OF HOW MANY PEOPLE
ARE WAITING AT THE MOMENT. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE THANK YOU AND
THANK YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT OVER THE PHONE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND ONCE AGAIN LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT TO OVER
THE PHONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. OKAY LET'S GO AHEAD
AND BEGIN. AND WE DO HAVE SEVEN
OR EIGHT IN THE QUEUE AT THIS
TIME ONE OF THEM SO PEOPLE CAN
START OFF FIRST QUESTION COMES
BURKE COMMENT COMES FROM LINE
TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU DR PAN MEMBERS MAKING TO
WORK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH PLAN
ADVOCATES REPRESENTING THE
THIRTEEN HUNDRED COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTERS IN CALIFORNIA
WHAT I THINK YOU AND THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND PANELISTS
FORGET HEARING TODAY I'M GONNA
TRY TO BE VERY QUICK AND
HEALTHY- THE REQUIRED TO SEE
ANY PATIENT WHO WALKS THROUGH
THEIR DOOR REGARDLESS OF THE
PATIENT'S ABILITY TO PAY AND
DURING. THE PANDEMIC HEALTH
CENTER COULD REPORTED AN
INCREASED NUMBER OF
COMMERCIALLY INSURED PATIENTS
WHO COME TO HEALTH CENTERS FOR
KOBE NINETEEN PACKED DAY-
ALTHOUGH CLINIC FOR ABLE TO
PROVIDE I THINK PERMITTED
BILLING PRODUCTOR BECAUSE HAD
CREATED SOME CHALLENGES AS YOU
HEARD EARLIER IN THE CARE ACT
REQUIRES. PLANS REIMBURSED OUT
OF NETWORK PROVIDERS BUT THERE
HAVE BEEN- SOME ISSUES WITH
SOME PLANTS BEING NON
RESPONSIVE TO THOSE CLAIMS
ADDITIONALLY THE CARE ACT-
UNDER THE CARE BACK HEALTH
PLANS WILL BE REIMBURSED OUT OF
NETWORK PROVIDERS THAT THE
PROVIDERS. TESTING FEES THAT
YOU HEARD EARLIER- BUT THAT
ALSO HAS CREATED SOME CONFUSION
WITH MEDIC CAL AN UNINSURED
PATIENT TO THINK THAT THEY
MIGHT HAVE TO UP FRONT THOSE
COPPER THE TEST AND PERHAPS
MOST IMPORTANTLY AND FINALLY AS
YOU HEARD EARLIER THE CARE ACT
REQUIREMENT IS CONTINGENT ON
THE FEDERAL A PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY DECLARATION. THIS
MEANS WHEN THAT PHD SUBTYPE OR
TERMINATED HEALTH PLAN WILL NO
LONGER BE REQUIRED TO REIMBURSE
OUT OF NETWORK PROVIDERS FOR
THAT STONE OBVIOUSLY WE BELIEVE
IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT EVERYONE
BE SURE TO TACTIC THEY SHOW UP
IN ECONOMIC AND THAT EVERYONE
GET REIMBURSED FOR THEIR
SERVICES AGAIN WE APPRECIATE
THE COMMITTEE'S WORK ON THIS
ISSUE THANK YOU. THANKS VERY
UCH. NEXT WITH THIS PLEASE.
NINE NINE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
WENT AWAY WE LET YOU AND I'M ON
POVERTY BIG HOLDING HEARING
SOMETHING THAT MAKE DIFFICULT
FOR IF THAT COULD YOU OF COLOR
IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOT HOLD
THAT LOOK STRUCTURES TO.
DISTRIBUTE CAPTAIN TREATMENT
EXACTLY. ANY WORK HAS TO WORK
OUT OF THE HOME DURING THE TIME
SHOULD BE PRESUMPTIVE EXPOSED
CALL THAT SHOULD BE IS NOT THE
CASE IN OUR REVIEW HOW HEALTH
PLAN. THREE THOUSAND ONE COULD
NOT COVER TO THAT A REQUIRED BY
AN EMPLOYEE. THE STATE AND
LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH HAVE
STEPPED INTO THE AND ON THEIR
OWN TESTING. DID NOT COLLECT
PLAN DATA WITH LIAM AND END OF
FEDERAL FUNDS THE COST IN THE
HAVE TO FIGHT FOR PEOPLE AND BY
OUR PUBLIC. WALKED PLAN HAVE. I
THINK AND EVEN RUN AMOUNT
CURRENTLY MULTI HEALTH FOR
FUTURE HEALTH CONSIDER ROLE HOW
PLAN IN PLACE MANAGE A MEMBER
HOW TO CONDITION WHICH MAKE
INTO. MORE SUSPECT TO THE
AFFECT CONTENT THE VIRUS WE
APPRECIATE THAT THE STATE
MAKING TO. DISTRIBUTE THE BACK
BUT THERE IS A JUST AND WELL
FOUNDED FEAR KEY COMMUNITY OF
COLOR THAT THEY KNOW BETWEEN AS
CAN PIGS I DID CREDIT FOR THE
DAY TO PARTNER WHICH I THINK
CAN YOU MEMBERS IN TESTING
TREATMENT. THANK YOU AND THAT
ARE OUT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH EXCELLENT PLEASE.
JOINT OF CARE COBEN NINETEEN
TEST- THAT CAN BE. USED FOR
SCREENING OF ASYMPTOMATIC
INDIVIDUALS DENTAL OFFICES WILL
NEED TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE THIS
SERVICE TO SCREEN ALL DENTAL
PATIENTS REGARDLESS OF CLOSE
CONTACT OR SUSPECTED EXPOSURE.
ALTHOUGH RAPID TESTS WOULD NOT
BE USED OR DEFINITIVE
DIAGNOSIS IN THE DEMONSTRATING
THE ABILITY TO USE TESTS TO
SCREEN AND READ POSITIVE
TESTING PATIENTS INTO
APPROPRIATE MEDICAL CARE. WILL
BE CRUCIAL FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
SURVEILLANCE AND- THAT. THAT
MAINTAINING THE POPULATION
HEALTH. BOTH THE NECESSITY FOR.
TO BE UNMASKED AND THE PROBLEMS
OF AEROSOL GENERATING
PROCEDURES HAVE FORCED DENTAL
OFFICES TO ASSUME EVERYONE IS A
POTENTIAL CARRIER HOWEVER-
THESE ARE NOT CONSIDERED
SUSPECTED PATIENTS UNDER CDCR
CAL OSHA DEFINITION AND
THEREFORE CURRENTLY NOT
AVAILABLE FOR. CASH TO BE
REIMBURSED BY PLANS BY THE
PREVALENCE OF ASYMPTOMATIC
INDIVIDUALS INFECTED WITH
COVERT NINETEEN AND THE NATURE
AND PRACTICE OF DENTISTRY- CDA
BELIEVES THAT. WHEN SCREENING
FOR ASYMPTOMATIC PATIENTS IS
pHEALTHCARE PROVIDERS THE
TESTING SHOULD BE COVERED BY
INSURANCE AT THAT TIME THANK
THANK YOU THANKS VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. NINE SEVENTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS JOANNA.
YOU CAN HEAR ME YES AGAIN. IAN
THANK YOU. I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO
SAY ANYMORE I FEEL LIKE NO
MATTER WHERE THE TEN PEOPLE
SPEAKING OUT AGAINST THIS OR
HAVE A THOUSAND OR TWO THOUSAND
IN THE HALL. YOU'RE GONNA GIVE
US ONE MINUTE TO SAY OUR PEACE.
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHAT
EVERYBODY SAYS YOU'RE GOING TO
DO WHAT YOU. DO TO LINE YOUR
POCKETS BECAUSE YOU DON'T WORK
FOR US THE PEOPLE. WHO WORK FOR
THOSE THAT. CAN'T YOU READ. AND
YET YOU REELECTED. I DO NOT
WANT A MANDATED VACCINE I WILL
NOT TAKE IT MY CHILDREN WILL
NOT GET MY FAMILY WILL NOT TAKE
IT. YOU CAN WRAP UP ALL OF YOUR
MANDATE SENIOR PRETTY PACKAGES
OF COERCION BUT THEY ARE JUST
THAT THEIR COERCION YOU GUYS
NEED TO STOP THIS I'M MOVING
OUT OF THIS CORRUPT STATE.
WHERE YOU SENATOR PER HAND TAKE
AWAY THE RIGHT OF INDIVIDUAL.
BERMAN AND LITTLE TO A PLACE
WHERE I WILL BE FREE AS AN
AMERICAN TO MAKE CHOICES FOR
MYSELF AND HOPE THAT YOUR
CORRUPT POLITICS YOU NINETY IN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I WOULD
MAKE NOTICE BEFORE IT MOVED TO
NEXT WITNESS THERE IS NOW NO
LONGER CITY CALIFORNIA
MANDATING A COVERT VACCINE.
NEXT WITNESS. NINE TWENTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU CARE MEMBERS
AND STAFF STATE BORDERS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
UNDERWRITERS THE STATE'S
LARGEST ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
INSURANCE AGENTS BROKERS AND
INDUSTRY PROFESSIONALS. AGENTS
ALL PROBLEMS AND TRUSTED
ADVISORS WITHIN THEIR
COMMUNITIES THAT THEY SERVE I
THINK WE AGENTS OR THE FIRST TO
BE CALLED WITH QUESTIONS ABOUT
HEALTH INSURANCE AND BECAUSE OF
THEIR EXPERTISE. EXPERIENCE AND
RELATIONSHIPS THAT. HE DIDN'T
CAN OFTEN PROBABLY INCLUDING.
BILLING FOR COLD ED CAFFEINE
TREATMENT OF QUICKLY AT NO COST
TO THE CONSUMER. HE ALSO
PROVIDE HUMAN RESOURCE SERVICES
PARTICULARLY TO SMALLER
BUSINESSES NECESSARY TO INSPECT
THE EMPLOYER AND THEIR
COMPLIANCE RESPONSIBILITIES AND
OBLIGATIONS INCLUDING COVET
ACTING. HEALTH INSURANCE AGENT
BRING THE IRREPLACEABLE HUMAN
TOUCH NECESSARY TO PROVIDING A
TRUE QUALITY SERVICE
EXPERIENCE. THEIR INDIVIDUAL
SENIORS AND SMALL AND LARGE
EMPLOYER GROUP CLIENTS. WITH
THE FLURRY OF CHANGING
CIRCUMSTANCES WE UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE ARE AND WILL BE MANY
QUESTIONS PERTAINING TO HEALTH
INSURANCE. PLEASE ASK AN AGENT
THANK YOU THANKS. VERY MUCH
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. NINE
THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YEAH HI THANK YOU MY
NAME IS WENDY AND I REPRESENT
MILLION MAMA'S MOVEMENT AND I'M
ASKING YOU PLEASE TO VOTE
AGAINST THAT THAT WE NEED TO.
AND THE BEST FORCED MANDATORY
VACCINATION BUT YOU SAY IT'S
NOT HAPPENING YET BUT IT'S
USUALLY RIGHT BEHIND THE BILL
LIKE THIS. AND WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT IF PEOPLE WANT USED
TO HAVE HAVE. THAT THERE'S NO
TRACKING AND THAT THE-
INSURANCE COMPANY DOES NOT
ENFORCE THAT SOMEBODY MUST BE
OUR MANDATE IT SHOULD BE
ACTUALLY ACTIVATED AGAINST
THEIR WILL THERE NEEDS TO BE
FREEDOM THERE NEEDS TO BE
HEALTH CARE THAT. EVERYONE AND
THE BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE DO
NOT NEED TO BE FORCED TO DO
SOMETHING AGAINST THEIR WILL.
SO ASKING YOU TO PLEASE MAKE
SURE THAT YOU CROSSED EVERY T.
AND DOT EVERY I IN TERMS OF
FREEDOM FOR INDIVIDUALS AND
HEALTH. HELP NOT UNIT MEASURES
THAT TAKE. AWAY PEOPLE
TREATMENT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. NINE
TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
JILL I'M FROM SANTA MONICA
CALIFORNIA I'M I'M DENNIS IT'S
JEFF. START LOOKING AT BODY
HARDLY DIFFERENT WAY I HEAR
YOUR CONVERSATION. YOUR MEETING
AND IT SEEMS LIKE A LOT OF
WASTED ENERGY IN THE WRONG
PLACES- BECOME ACROSS THOUSANDS
OF VIRUSES EVERY DAY. IS A
NINETY NINE POINT NINETY EIGHT
SURVIVAL RATE. AND CENTER PAN
THE CO THE DIAGNOSIS BCAUSE
FEDERAL MONEY SO WE NEED TO ASK
YOURSELF WHY WHERE DID THE
MONEY GO WHERE DID YOU CAN'T
THE BEST WAY TO REACH THE HEART
ATTACK THAT GO WHERE DID ALL
THE OTHER DATA BLUE THAT GO
DURING THE TIME CODED DURING
THE- EAGLES FEDERAL. MONEY AND
DEFINITELY UNINTENDED KIND OVER
90% PEOPLE BACK EVERY DAY THAT
GOES FOR ALL ELECTED WHETHER
THERE IS A VACCINE OR NOT. AND
WE NEED TO START TALKING ABOUT
HOW. FOR THE MUSEUM. TO BE
HEALTHY WE ARE ACROSS THOUSANDS
OF OUR- EVERY DAY. I. YEAH I
NEED YOUR THOUGHT PROCESS ABOUT
PUSHING BACK THE- TECHNOLOGY
ARE IF THERE CAN. YOU KNOW YOU
CAN'T EVEN CLEARWATER PLUMBING
IMPROPER TO THANK YOU TO MUCH
INTO THAT THANK YOU. B. AND
IT'S A CRAP WITNESS. I KNOW
QUESTION FROM NINE TWENTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME KAREN I ALSO
LIVE IN SAN MONICA AND- I'M
HERE IN PANAMA TO ANY OF YOU
KNOW MANY OTHER. THIRTY THREE
HAVE PREPONDERANCE OF HOME
PEOPLE OVER THE- IT'S NOT
WEARING MASKS THERE SHOULD.
THEY ARE DRUGS THEY ARE SICK
THEIR OLD THEY'RE. NOT GETTING
AND WE ARE COMPLETELY IGNORING.
THE BASIC AND WE HAVE MORE.
PEOPLE COMING TO THAT SHUT DOWN
A LOCKDOWN OF THE ECONOMY WE'RE
SPENDING ALL THIS MONEY
TRACKING AND TRACING AND-
MEETING EVERY. BREATHABLE SPACE
WHICH BACKING AGENDA YET
PLANNING ANTI DISCREDITING
ANYBODY WHO WHO QUESTIONS THE
VACCINES AND WE HAVE I THINK.
WE HAVE TO GET AWAY FROM THAT
WE HAVE TO GO BACK TO THE
BASICS WHICH IS HIGH HI HYGIENE
AND CLEAN WATER AND SANITATION.
AND NUTRITIOUS FOOD NONE OF
WHICH WE HAVE IN THE HOMELESS
POPULATION OR IN THE POPULATION
HAS BEEN. BEING IMPOVERISHED BY
THE SHUT DOWN OF THE ECONOMY.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. OUR
LAST QUESTION COMES FROM LINE
TWENTY SEVEN LINE TWENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MY
NAME IS. SAM I HAVE BEEN
LISTENING FOR COUPLE HOURS NOW
AND I NEED. YOU QUESTIONS BUT
HAVEN'T BEEN A DOCTOR ALL-
COMMITTEE. TRICIA- LOESCHER
BELIEVE PRONOUNCED ABOUT HOW
LONG THEIR ABUSING CALL MICHAEL
LEVEL COULD WOULD BE IN. WHY OR
WOULD YOU MAKE SURE THE YOU
THERAPY ARE. THIRTIES ACROSS
THE US AND THE STATE HAS TO DO
ONE SO CAN MAKE THAT. THIRD
SHOULD BE SOME OF MORE FEDERAL
YOU. RIGHT THE OTHER QUESTION I
HAVE IS WHAT ABOUT AND SHE
COMPANIES WHO ARE ALREADY
THREATENING TO DROP PATIENTS IF
THEY REFUSE THE VACCINE. THAT'S
GOING TO BE ANY OVERSIGHT FROM
THE STATE ON- INSURANCE
COMPANIES TRACKING THEIR
PATIENTS. AS A PARENT WHO HAD-
BEEN VACCINE INJURED CHILDREN
WHAT THING THAT HAPPENS TO BE
FAIRLY COMMON IS THAT. DOCTORS
OFFICES WILL REFUSE TO SEE YEAH
BECAUSE WE REFUSE GREATER
VACCINE SO HOW WE TO KEEP
DOCTORS. THANKS FOR THE BILLION
CREATION BECAUSE THEY IS A RARE.
THING YOU. THERE ANY OTHER WAY
ON THE MODERATOR. THERE NO
FURTHER WITH IN THE QUEUE.
THANK YOU MODERATOR. HAVING
HEARD ALL PUBLIC TESTIMONY-
MEMBERS ARE THERE ANY OTHER
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. OKAY SEEN NO HANDS%
UP I DO WANT TO ADDRESS. A
COUPLE STATEMENTS ARE
PREVIOUSLY MADE FIRST OF ALL
UNFORTUNATELY WE'VE NOT ONLY
HAD OVER TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DEATHS FROM DIRECTLY
ATTRIBUTED TO COPE IN. HERE IN
THE UNITED STATES WE ALSO KNOW
THAT THE NUMBER OF EXCESS
DEATHS IN THE COUNTRY'S EVEN
LARGER THAN THAT. SO THAT
PROBABLY IT'S LIKELY CODES HAVE
BEEN EITHER DIRECTLY OR
INDIRECTLY INVOLVED IN EVEN
MORE DEATHS AND UNFORTUNATELY
DO STILL CONTINUE TO HAVE
PEOPLE DIE OF OTHER CONDITIONS
AS WELL- CERTAINLY UNDER STATE
LAW- SOMEONE CANNOT BE DENIED
COVERAGE- JUST BECAUSE THEY
HAVE A PRE EXISTING CONDITION.
PROUD TO HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN
THE OFFERING OF THAT
LEGISLATION- SO THAT APPLIES TO
MANY DIFFERENT CIRCUMSTANCES
THAT REFER TO- BUT WITH THAT I.
WANT TO AGAIN THANK ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY- IF YOU.
AND ALSO YOU CAN SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE SENATE HEALTH
COMMITTEE OR WHETHER- WE VISIT
OUR WEBSITE. YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY AN OFFICIAL HEARING
RECORDS. I ALSO WANT TO THANK
OF ALL OF THE- PEOPLE WHO SPOKE
AT OUR HEARING- I THINK ALL THE
STAFF HERE WHO ARE HERE. WITH
ME HERE IN THE CHAMBERS TO BE
SURE THAT. WE ALLOW THIS
HEARING TO RUN SMOOTHLY.
FRANKLY WANT TO THANK TERRY
BOWDEN. ON MY HEALTH COMMITTEE
STAFF WHO'S WORKED HARD TO
PREPARE THIS- HEARING TO
ADDRESS THIS. ACTUALLY FAIRLY
COMPLEX TOPIC. THAT WE'RE GOING
TO BE LOOKING AT AS WE- BEFORE
THE NEW SESSION AND I ALSO WANT
TO GIVE PARTICULAR THANKS TO
THE US SERGEANTS HERE WHO HAD
TO MAINTAIN ORDER HERE. ONLY
HIS CHAMBER OF IN THE
BUILDING. AND INCLUDING- HAVING
TO DEAL WITH US OCCASIONALLY
PEOPLE WHO HAVE NOT A HEARING
TIGHTLY TO PUBLIC HEALTH
GUIDELINES. AS WELL SO THANK
YOU SO VERY MUCH FOR YOUR- WORK
HERE AND INSURING THAT WE HAVE
A US MOVIE RUN HEARING. SO WITH
THAT I DIDN'T WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE WHO PARTICIPATED- AND
ONE OF THANK EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION. WE
HAVE CONCLUDED THE AGENDA OF
THIS INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON
THE COVE IN NINETEEN- RESPONSE
IN TERMS OF TESTING
REQUIREMENTS- GUIDELINES IN
COST AND ALSO IN RELATION TO-
COVERAGE OF- TREATMENTS AND
VACCINES. AND. WITH THAT THIS
HEARING IS ADJOURNED.